[Music]
thank you
yeah yeah
Sunday Sunday
my check how my levels are sounding
welcome round
what's going on little tiny little tiny
long long week shout out to Brandon
Pearson what's going on hey yo Hold the
Line movement what's up Lillian Master
what's going on what's going on
spots already starting beefy top
pop not what's going on young dreads the
young artist man young dreads outside
salute to him you know what I mean
hustle motivate what's going on but how
my levels are signing Shady aftermath
was going on Atomic Sans what's going on
what's going on there are levels to this
Kevin ball when they're all level my man
black conflict x what um
beef what are you doing
he got everything in there he got the
shield he got hold the line he got oh he
got the soldier I'm a soldier she do
Nick what's going on gaming News Now
podcast GNN GNN okay let's do this
testing now and it got me tested I can
actually force a a test on that end
I know I know I know because the chat
complained I wanted to hit me all right
so let's let's do it let's do it all
right so sugar just went through
remember I'm not on the main scene
though it doesn't matter it'll still
come through
job
it was at 30 I'm gonna drop it down to
10. yeah that's perfect perfect my attic
behind the scenes Guardian nuclear
merchandise was at 50. oh yeah I'm gonna
drop it down to ten too yeah that's
that's fine
Lewis Jimenez what's going on Zach Dobby
was going on yo what's going on anime
cap compilations starting that beefy
talk yeah you know so yeah we're gonna
get the legendary here young yeah up in
here big fan so it's long overdue to
bless them treat them right in the realm
and we love it for the show we got a fun
show today lined up like the theme music
little Dallas salute so yeah we'll be
back and make sure everything is good
we're just tested some things out and
we'll get Young and the rest of the
Lords up in here good to see y'all
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame that
they can sourcing up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless back weed with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
thank you
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell an Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's who
let's do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Fred and Kruger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rain uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard a boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with Django cougars and I'm
going places better tell an Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be the original y'all feel
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just to Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but a man
talk social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know we're about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't gotta say
it I'm embarrassed for you I always been
a nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with that's
do that again foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
weed with messaging people on AIM check
my vocals all on Twitter but a man time
social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my CD but I'm still by
Coastal I got you that's
[Music]
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with that's
let's do that again
yeah yeah yeah what's going on around
just a little uh technical difficulty
can I messed up
told young gay the wrong time but we got
it straightened out we got it
straightened out west coast East Coast
thing he's on his way so we're just
gonna hold the fort we're gonna hold the
fort down four don't hold the line we're
gonna hold the line we're gonna hold the
line for the foot for young you know
what I'm saying but yeah about four [__]
messed up and um I was gonna say also
real quick legitimately and King will
not
um disagree please send some love to
Saul we got something going on and um
this is for Real This Is For Real a
sense of love to our brother and uh we
will inform you you know nothing all
details but just before he was alive too
as well so hold on young age coming you
know what I'm saying we still gonna have
a good show and he will be so we're just
gonna give him a few minutes to get in
here it's [__] messed up all right
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just for target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless and people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got you oh
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if he flies you steal
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
uh my check my checks real quick young
gonna get a young yeah I need I need one
of those young yeah there we go oh mama
had a bike check real quick
what's going on guys
I like that I like that King The King
get about check and King young yeah
with the Epic vid no doubt here you hear
you and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 314.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
I'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got kazavakirio in the
realm today Xbox you already know Xbox
game pass core multiple PS5 skus and PC
profits versus console profits to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whose
Journey as a content creator truly
reflects some of the most comprehensive
and informative takes within the games
industry this Law's dedication and
transparency with his core audience has
now fittingly made him responsible for
one of the most iconic voices in Triple
A games today
introducing the creating host of The
Young yeah YouTube channel and now the
English voice actor of the historic
Kazama carry you from the Yakuza series
the Lord and new dragon of dojeva metal
gear Aficionado and with one sacred
bracelet was co-signed by the legend
takiakorada young out passed out
live from L.A and making his debut into
the realm of the Lord my man Lord young
yeah how we doing sir
man you know how to make those intros
epic uh that I I feel we're like royalty
today and I'm I'm doing awesome thank
you for having me uh this is just a
really good good group of people a lot
of cool stuff happening in my life it's
uh just nice to be able to chat with
folks and uh you know sharing the
passion of gaming and all these things
that we love so yeah thank you for
having me absolute pleasure man glad you
you can make it your lord in your realm
super proud of your journey we're gonna
have some fun in the realm today
um just quickly with all the stuff you
got going on like have you got a chance
to be playing any games lately any games
been getting played any games I'm still
getting through Final Fantasy 16 and
tears of the Kingdom uh tears of the
Kingdom I'm really taking my time with I
didn't have to I didn't get a review
copy for that so I I actually get the
chance to just kind of enjoy the ride
and and come back to it and play an hour
or two at a time instead of you know
having to rush through it which I
actually appreciate and then like trying
to balance that with Final Fantasy 16
um and I'm so yeah exactly a lot you
picked too big exactly yeah yeah and
then trying to get through uh I haven't
played through like a dragon issue yet
so I'm trying to get through that and uh
so yeah I'm juggling a couple things
here and there no doubt yeah that's a
lot it's a lot no doubt good that you're
still rocking I like that you're doing
your homework with the with the issue I
see what you do you get yourself all the
way for sure to where you need to be the
more I listen to kudela's Performance
the more in in his uh in his Vibe I can
get so you know any any excuse to just
like absorb that performance the better
you know of course of course wait he got
the bracelet on today I was looking for
the bracelet oh man I haven't read me
right now because
you playing that that man's voice we
expect a dragon on your back
that's a lot I got a whole tattoo on my
back imagine if that's like a
requirement when you look into it would
fill out the application are you are you
okay with putting it put a tattoo on the
back and sign a contract you gotta sign
a contract
there's enough money
I got a whole tattoo on my chest man
please what you get what you got young
what you got I did get this uh dragon
the the Kiryu patch jacket patch on my
leather jacket on the back so I tweeted
about that I think and uh so for those
who want to take a look at that yeah it
looks dope and I figured that was a good
alternative to getting a full backpack I
respect it very expensive very uh
extensive process and probably painful
in certain parts of my back so you know
I'll ease into into that I'll think
about it respectfully not today not
today no not today respectfully knowing
that they say oh [__] turn ax Mike up
just a little bit just a little bit oh
my gosh this would be getting on my
nerves with these people one week they
say it's too loud I turn it down I'm
gonna just let the people
so look we got the horsemen of gaming
but uh we're one Horseman down I've
gotten King's blessing in addicts
blessing to say blessing for me oh damn
anyway to send some love to solve y'all
a little situation came up for him last
minute uh physically so I'll go check
out our brother make sure he's okay
because he called me he felt really bad
he wanted to be here for young so this
was really last minute so go check on
him make sure our brother is all right
we're gonna keep it pushing but uh we
still got my co-host with the cold notes
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show back
to back how are we doing sir doing
pretty good how is how do I sound now
chat and I'm only gonna listen to like
the first three or four people the rest
after the first three or four people you
just you just you know they're putting
up limitations limitations man you know
I put King's personas behind a behind a
like wall so I can play listen uh people
uh we gonna put added gameplay
sir what have you been playing
I've been playing a lot of persona
actually here recently I've been trying
to actually get through that like my
thing when it comes to the Persona
franchise is I started on the
PlayStation 4 and then I didn't know
that I was under the impression that all
I had to do was just upgrade to that
tier the uh the PlayStation Plus and
then I would just take it with me right
I know that's not how it works you did
the mistake I made when you got PS5 I
lost it all yeah I didn't realize I had
to manually upload my stuff to the cloud
and I thought it was how it works over
there
there you go with the Xbox one again
here we go here we go situations
bringing yourself down a level
Persona I was on like the fifth fourth
or fifth Palace and it's a wrap I'm just
starting the whole game over at that
point oh man it's probably about going
into McDonald's and expecting caviar oh
my God I have probably wasted maybe 300
350 hours of persona are you going
through 5 Royal right now yeah I'm going
through five Royals I still haven't
played the Royal version actually I
played the original it was like 110
hours long or something so Royal ads
like an extra chunk it's like 130 some
hours I gotta get on that yeah man it
says just playing catch up getting
getting your time getting things done in
Persona yeah I have been I played that
sea of sea of stars sea of stars I
played that demo it's actually a pretty
one that's coming out next week the real
game oh the one that you didn't know
about until I said no no no I didn't I
don't know about anything until the
drops in game
passes again because I'm consumed
and you know want to address the chat
real quick last week you know my IPS was
a little high last week you know what
gets on my nerves is Keith just
interrupt me like eight times I don't
want to say nothing in the chat no we'll
go see not in the comment section what
king does is completely overlooked but
when an attic does anything we gonna be
on him in that that comment it was
because it's red it's rare for kicks so
they let it slide yeah
almost weekly anyway that's Vanessa yeah
that's it
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the whole the line Xbox movement
beloved Lord King how we doing sir well
first I'm super happy today you know we
got a younger here and I'll get us you
know a little story about that later but
last night I went live for the first
time on uh Twitter now everybody that's
used to combat talk being on YouTube it
will migrate straight over to Twitter
because there's certain things that I'm
able to do logistically with Twitter as
far as showing you the fights now what I
am disappointed in is you guys oh damn
show up how you gonna not show up
y'all on my Twitter all the time when
I'm doing uh crazy stuff and putting up
uh weird tweets going at the opposition
you guys are there so hey show up for
the fights right why because the fight
was paid for and y'all got a chance to
see said fight also come
um Kos is gonna be up there that's King
of the Saturday nice well we're going to
be doing weekly reads so I'm gonna go
into the vote of the 62 000 comic books
that I got we're gonna start shifting
through and see what we want to read so
we're going to get two cent comic books
out we're gonna get one cent comic books
out we're gonna go to the origins of you
know the Champions and so y'all can get
some comic book history and then we do
live unboxings I'm gonna do live
unboxings also when we have uh sponsors
that send over product I'll be doing
live unboxings on Twitter so Twitter is
going to be a lot active so you might
want to be part of my members in the
community so you guys can uh you know
get stuff ahead of time also I'm
thinking about doing behind the scenes
at shows so okay I'm talking to Cog
about doing that in attic so we're going
to be down Astro pirate king in the chat
set he was there I don't know what
you're talking about
his bag he said he's bad he's gonna be
there next fight for sure you're bad for
a lot of things
[Laughter]
exactly so I might have to go to my man
Alex on this all right y'all what's up I
heard the number 62
000 Comics was that I purposely or is
that a literal number serious what 62
thousand yeah all right I would have had
more but when I was growing up
um you know as you know like 10 to 12
years old or whatever yeah I sell some
of my comic books to buy my mother on
Mother's Day gifts oh wow um you know so
a lot of my comic books went there but
an older where I was working I was able
to keep my books so yes I just kept my
books kept stacking them and um this
weird Trend started where people started
slabbing me bucks that's when you uh
send your books out to go get graded and
then they put it through into a plastic
uh binder yeah not open and it's sealed
I I don't think that's where the fun
leaves right I'm a book so I want to
open my books and read them and if um
they degrade a little bit because of
that then whatever but I didn't buy them
to sell them I brought them to read and
and yeah 100 that's what I got but I got
62 000. um that's insane
what I've been playing is fortnite uh
back on I saw you catching somebody
W's I swear down victories uh shout out
to the Sinister he jumped in my party
yesterday and you know um one of the
channel five uh originals and he worked
behind the scenes the iron Lords podcast
it was really fun to hang out with my
brother and we got a good epic run we
was playing another YouTuber and that
was really fun uh so I encourage
everybody you know if you see me on if
we are friends just send me an invite
you won't see me on I'll be invisible
Justin
okay I get you just just send an invite
in a random invite and hope that kicked
David would join your party guys if
you're in fortnite it snitches on you oh
yeah that's true
there's some Diablo I was playing
New Seasons out and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
Lord Cognito spreading everything around
the IOP not telling what you want in but
what you need to hear shout out to Mr
Maddie plays shout out to finally dude
had a good one just talking about
everything uh ABK in the aftermath with
Microsoft acquisition
um shout out to the last word with
I got Travis this week he was uh
traveling was talking Destiny the new
Solstice event uh Diablo's new content
Remnant two and for me it's been uh
taking a closed beta I'm such a
tekkenhead are you a beta boy come on
come on I'm definitely listen listen for
checking I'm gonna be available
let me tell y'all right now
this is
no hyperbole
ue5 in that game I am sorry there's
nothing that looks better this game I I
Mortal Kombat I'm not saying it's not
gonna be good I'm being respectful
because I love Mortal Kombat and Street
Fighter I love you you're great but
ue5 and from the startup screen when you
see kazuya's face and you can maneuver
the camera it is
insane now as far as the game itself
they really bro they rewrite all the
animations Everything feels completely
different from kazia
um you know obviously I'm a harem mean
and like
Korean take what I knew he was my man I
knew he was my man anyway hey bro so
like if you played while on for all
those years there's a feel to him right
now he feels heavy the animation so the
kicks the way the impact is different
obviously he's got the new look going on
he's got the smoke he's kind of like
bayek Master Vibes with yeah yeah like
he's got some back to sun moves as well
yeah yeah punch counter from Beck doosan
a lot of bro he I just love the vibe it
is just crazy and the thing that changes
the game characters a lot so clock
Claudio was in this demo which is his
debut
um we got your man oh man Leroy you know
what I'm saying
um Brian Fury is a beast because who is
in it June Kazam is in in it um Jane of
Court Jill is oh my God Jill it's
ridiculous they really yeah they really
fuse Devil Jin and him yeah very well
now he he's got a unique style he's a
match for kazuya now because
uh because Julia's still kind of got to
I see some combos that right now people
want to come here uh body check oh into
some like demon power thing and they
like harada this gotta get nerfed like
people already they tweaking harada
already so yeah listen man it is amazing
and I will say the neck cold yeah
excellent I didn't have any issues look
the game is fired take your time uh
where are you playing it at sir I'm
playing PlayStation closed betas this
week they got the I guess the marketing
for one week earlier
there's no outrage here
but X should get it the I believe it's
uh the next week so it doesn't matter
anyway go check that out and it's coming
to PC steam they'll be a closed beta so
all three will be next week but yeah it
is it is absolutely amazing so hopefully
that and that's been pretty much for it
for me
um attic is there a lot of super chats
otherwise we could just get into it if
there's a if there's a lot
how many we're looking at
he's muted I think I had it yeah do you
have something uh uh going your way
because I think you supposed to be uh PC
Master race as well sir oh yeah but I
haven't got it yet so he's getting that
thing how's your anticipation for it or
do you do you feel a little anxious or
do you feel hype are you looking at the
mail every day what's up looking at the
middle every day that's how I was when
my rock was coming I was checking the
mail I was looking at the cameras to see
it for me looking at the cameras uh you
know did pick up the Final Fantasy uh
pixel remastered
well the pixel collection you can't
Remax the pixel collection they've
already been remastered so I'm gonna try
those out on the steam deck and uh you
know I to be continued you know that
thank you for interrupting me on
the Lord shout out to the hashtag
greybeards yes hashtag we dem boys we
outside uh Xbox World Order is fully
operational okay Xbox
xwo super trap from Robert kellett
welcome to the realm Youngy uh how does
it feel to meet Lord pifi for the first
time and congrats on being the uh uh uh
congrats on being the voice actor for a
huge character ah well thank you so much
I mean we met in person yeah and that's
how we uh got all this set up and uh it
was just an immediately good vibe and
positive vibe and so I was very happy to
get the invitation and uh fortunately we
found the the time to do it and I'm
getting lots of good vibes today so just
happy to be here man and to talk about
games which is what we all love and yeah
and the love Yeah that's what it's about
brother that's what it's about what else
we got attic cheers from Robert Kelly so
y'all selling kidneys for 9.99 PS5 Pro
um
we all good uh we all good wishes to
Lord solve hopefully no joysticks inside
during his recovery and then ironically
all right let's play with each other's
joists what did he say oh Lord he said
what happened to soft I'll be praying
for him this Sunday instead of preying
on you yo
joystick but behave yourself behave
yourself uh hopefully he's okay joystick
but your concerns is very valid so do
pray for him thank you so much no doubt
all right from Hollywood rules so we got
two more Hollywood rolls better remember
for 18 months apologize to my brother
King couldn't do the full uh the fight
uh spent the whole evening with the lady
wish my brothers uh a good show well a
great show IOP the best park ever oh
thank you brother thank you uh two
dollars for Robin Kayla how do you
pressure comic your collection King how
do I preserve it
I just put him in Bad Boys and Plastics
just like you know yeah and but what I
do do I have a um all right so remember
the cardboard crates that we had the
white ones yes now they do have a fire
resistant water resistant uh breathable
fabric that you can put them in oh and I
have that they're collapsible they hold
are they attic resistant yeah definitely
attic resistant they they hold 200 in
each uh Bin so I brought a ton of those
because it was on sale I think people
didn't know about them and uh from an
upstart company and it's fantastic
really good what else we got five five
dollars from Black Cobra hey how are you
guys doing so I was thinking Microsoft
fixed the old called Sir servers what if
they did that so they can bring the old
cards on the switch
that would be phenomenal which did get a
10-year deal after the result of the ABK
deal so yeah what do you think Young
that would sell really well I think
that'd be a really good idea actually if
if they have chance for that and you
know there's a potentially a switch to
or whatever it's called on the horizon
yeah so you know
hopefully you know Call of Duty can come
to switch and and just the more
accessible the better and Nintendo
platforms they sell really well you know
I mean switches yeah you know I mean
it's still selling ridiculously well I
mean they haven't even reduced the price
for the switch
because it sells so well that is true
that goes to show the audience faces
there might as well you know take
advantage of it so you know maybe yeah
I'm having a eye gasm with your
background yeah yes I'm looking at the
little throat baby
[Music]
it's ridiculous yo I'm not I I look at
everybody's background yeah background
I'm just really looking going from steps
it tells a lot it tells a lot what the
person yeah I know when you look at a
video from like two years ago you can
just see how much smaller and just more
organized everything was and then it
just kept growing and growing and I was
just a monster that I can't stop and
it's just like iron tone but for nerds
but for nerds see it back two ballet
then we got to stop because they keep
flying in yeah
I I just jumped it I got him I got him
yeah
I don't apologize I don't know what this
currency is but it's 10. so young Yeah
question how do you feel about uh CD uh
cyberpunk 2077 it's current state if I'm
not mistaken you reviewed it positively
yeah but covered the Fallout after
launch
yeah uh I mean I think it's clear that
CD project is committed to just making
it up to players and like fixing it and
stuff like that and I mean so far
they've definitely been doing a good job
and I think this expansion that's coming
out Phantom Liberty is gonna be what's
gonna define whether this game goes out
on a high or if it's kind of uh
remembered as a low point for C project
or whatever but just the free updates
alone have been doing a lot
um and then a lot of the features that
they're introducing with Phantom Liberty
that's also just a free update Phantom
Liberty is just a campaign but a lot of
like the enhancements to law enforcement
and how that works within the city like
that's free you know and so I think they
are buying a lot of Goodwill and you
know the best thing we can hope for when
a company messes up like that is that
they will find a way to bring it back at
least like no man's Sky it's worth
remembering that launch right it was a a
shell of what they promised but you look
at it now it's like it's hard to deny
that they put the work in and a lot of
that stuff was free I think it's all
been free if I recall so like if that
can be how they go out then I think
that's fantastic and I wish them the
best uh in doing that agreed I think the
biggest concern I have is like fixing
the reputation of the company yeah they
were doing a good job let me get the
final thought two or three I'll speed
ball them David hot right to another
Super Chat uh thank you love love young
yeah so good to see my favorite content
creators working together salute and we
got Homeless Bird Fallout Super Chat
love to the Lords I'm so excited for
this next Yakuza game especially after
recently beating zero in judgment
congratulations on Landing the role and
thank you so much the final one drunken
ninja member chat of 35 months salute
brother good Sunday Lords glad young is
getting his flowers been watching him
for years and what better place to get
him than on ILP so let's go no doubt so
look let's get into it all right y'all
know the rules of engagement obviously
we gotta respect our guest is his time
but we gotta talk about you know some
gaming and things like that so we got
all the good stuff let's catch to shift
uh back to Lord young yeah his video
game system history his journey into
content creation and voice acting and of
course what led him becoming the English
voice actor for the iconic casaba curio
from the Yakuza Series so Lord young
yeah let's start from the very beginning
what was some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
game
I actually remember the the game that I
first remember playing ever was Mega Man
3 on the NES
um now when we were kids my parents were
a bit more liberal with getting us video
game consoles but there came a point
where we started going to school and as
Asian parents do they're like all right
the video game time is over it's all
about study study study I got up to like
N64 uh they never got me a GameCube or a
PlayStation 2. they never got me a
PlayStation 3 on Xbox 360. so yeah it so
I had a lot of catching up to do once I
um got to a point where I could afford
my own stuff fun Mega Man 3 uh Mario
obviously
um and then like that the games that
really made me fall in love with gaming
were uh Ocarina of Time let's go back to
Mega Man let's go back oh yeah what's up
yeah
did you have to leave your contract on
because there was no save
I did that one time and we were playing
and it was that my friend raheem's house
and we made it to a point where we had
to get to cut man and um we was like
right we had to stop playing we told his
moms don't touch it we're good we come
back yeah I did just to turned it off
damn so did you have to go through any
of those pains because these guys don't
know our pains back in the days yeah you
have to go through any of those pains oh
I'm having flashbacks
every time you guys talk about what
happened back in like the 80s and 70s
40s oh my God it's a gift you act like
it's a curse I didn't know that it's a
gift you got to do your your research
Young Buck you gotta learn how it
started yeah with all the limitations of
the time though you you had to get
really good at that game to beat it so I
got pretty freaking good
um so it was one of those challenges
that was like really fulfilling to
overcome but a lot of we had a crawl and
Claw our way through that game man
um but once it was me my brother and
then uh a friend who would just like
come in every day to try to like get as
far as we could within a day and see
like if we get a little further every
day and eventually you got to freaking
while the clay monster yeah
um what part did you notice um the only
reason why I'm going a little bit happy
on this is because your gaming history
is stunted at a point in time because
it's schooling yeah right yes so I'm
going to like Focus early on in your
game and yeah Mega Man is a certain way
that you had to beat the bosses right if
you beat this boss and you got your
power it made beating this boss a whole
lot yeah right it was a lot of strategy
involved for sure and we found that over
repetition because you know it would
usually we'll get one game and it will
last a year exactly so back then the
internet wasn't yeah you know where it
is now obviously and so we couldn't look
things up right here we go YouTube video
addict so that you could go cheat and
find out how to beat a boss at it I say
that you do that I'm just saying for the
Young Generation
don't bother me
so um like did you find out that the the
heavy strategy someone said it was black
and white literally black and white that
looks so bad okay I'm sorry what's your
question cake I'm sorry no I just wanted
to know the um how long did it take for
them to find out that strategy being
there was three y'all cause everybody
got me grouped up back in the days yeah
we get our friends in the house and we
all huddle up against the TV and we get
that one cartridge and usually we had a
time from the parents to tell you you
have from this time to this time to play
because it was like one TV that we can
play on right of did how was that
experience with your team your core your
group your guy oh man you know this was
a long long time ago literally my first
gaming memory so not everything's
crystal clear but it is one of those
games that we spent years on and um my
friend especially he was a couple years
older than us uh he was really good at
this and more often than not we'd be
backseat Gamers
uh just just kill this thing and we try
to emulate him but we were just nowhere
near as good as he was
um and so a lot of it was just going
like okay we can't beat this we got to
rely on our friend here and uh yeah he
uh I mean the platforming segments he
would just absolutely nail
um I mean I was like four or five I was
pretty young at that time wow yeah yeah
exactly so you know I I didn't have the
experience or the the hand-eye
coordination that he did at the time but
yeah we eventually start noticing oh
like there are Elemental things that
come into play with and certain powers
that uh definitely uh do offer an
advantage and and yeah just just it's
it's that process that we take for
granted that's kind of fun and we feel
really good about it because we figured
it out and it wasn't the internet who
told us you know this is how you do it
it's so easy to look things up now oh
yeah that it you know it it takes away a
bit from The Challenge which is why I
kind of you know when I played from soft
games lately you know I miss that
feeling of like there is no like there
are guides to overcome some of these
bosses to make it easier but ultimately
you just got to be skilled like that's
what it comes down that's what old
school games are all about you just
gotta get good you know there's there's
no way around it um and they didn't hold
your hand they made it hard and so
um yeah just just all I have really fond
memories of those years of just that
communal like struggle yeah yeah painted
the picture it beautifully is in
reference to the struggle back then and
the challenges involved with the
difficulty and things of games at that
at that time without you know social
media all that stuff so that you go to
school there you said there's a hard
stop so at the Hard stop what were the
consoles that were had at that point
just so I know sure yeah so I did get up
to N64 and then from there on like to
play GameCube games I had to rely on my
friends go over to there
yeah exactly and play you know PS2 games
so like Super Smash Brothers Melee I
remember playing a lot back in the day
um Metroid Prime I got introduced to by
a friend who had a GameCube
um I actually my parents never bought me
a copy of Zelda Ocarina of Time I had to
borrow that
um yeah they bought me like the first
game that they bought me for N64 was
Wipeout uh they just
yeah it was actually pretty fun it was
actually pretty fun so I but then you
know I had to convince a friend's dad
and beg him to get me Mario 64.
um so he bought that for us as a gift
but yeah I forgot one game it's like
what's the point of buying me a console
yeah they did buy me a Game Boy Color
though and I remember my first game for
that was Wario Land three
um and so yeah but but a lot of it was
just relying on my friends or I had a
rely on emulation every day back when I
was in Venezuela you know that that's
where I I was born and raised absolutely
and so yeah it was a lot of just trying
like finding people or finding my own my
own way of accessing games on my parents
did not want me to access them it's a
big part of why PC gaming was such a big
part of my life you know we had to have
a PC right and so I download and play a
lot of games on that
um I played Metal Gear Solid one on PCS
where did the metal gear come in yeah
one of those things that you had to like
high that you're playing PC games from
your parents or like did they know you
was playing it's just like we can't stop
them from playing the PC to play games
or yeah yeah they at one point they knew
they just couldn't stop me but
you know the Juggernaut but you know
there were restrictions of here's how
long you can play you know and so I'd
have to sneak in at like 1am at night
and sneaking an hour or two of gameplay
before school and stuff like that
um but uh you know if I went over to to
like a sleepover at a friend's house
we'd be all all night playing all day
all night just just playing I got a
question yeah what was the gaming scene
like in Venezuela
um I was was it a law Community was it a
segmented what what yeah I have no idea
so I I want to get like a overall
question yeah funny enough pretty much
every friend that I knew gamed uh we you
know yeah no we we there was a mall
aware or there was this big game store
and a lot of people would go there and
buy their systems and so also like the
piracy scene in Venezuela was shall we
say thriving and so uh it was easy to
get like modded consoles and you know
with all the games in there or uh people
would have
um you know there'd be trucks uh sort of
uh in some Street and that just open it
up and there'd be just tons of pirated
cars wait they had a truck that pulled
up with the pirate yeah straight up yeah
yeah
games yeah instead of having the the ice
cream face yeah so yeah I got it hold on
because this is the thing that go around
now for schools and you schedule it it's
called the game truck but now I'm
thinking about the piracy truck
I'm trying to paint this picture so like
where did you know this like truck which
is it would come around specific times
like or where in the neighborhood like I
think it would just like sit in a
specific like a food truck you'd find it
in a specific spot and you just go there
and if it was available to sell games
you just yeah was it beer schools where
was it where was it situated schools
it's Saturday yeah it was just in Big
Market areas and stuff like that as sad
as the sounds it sounds like something
that's in an RPG there's this this
hidden shop it's only a mixed box or a
circle at a time yeah like a pickup
truck and they're just like that's yeah
they're incredible and you'd be able to
just like look at their uh their library
of games and just like look and you know
say I want that one and they'd be Dirt
Cheap like a couple dollars that's
incredible that's absolutely incredible
did you ever Miss sitting and ran it off
the road
let's start let's not get let's not get
locked up
it's a statue of limitation I'm sure
it's up by now go ahead and tell it but
but yeah I know I I did find my way
around uh keeping my love for gaming
alive
um and it's funny because uh you know
that that gaming phase my parents were
so restrictive of was the thing that
made me flourish most you know because
it's the thing that I loved and it's
like when you put all your heart and
passionate to something you genuinely
are passionate about you know great
things can happen and so like my YouTube
career was possible because I used to
snuck around uh to game and stuff like
that it's funny I'm sorry please yeah
and like my all my studies and my
degrees and whatever like none of that
stuff really mattered anywhere as much
as like uh my theatrical experiences and
my gaming experiences I I actually have
a family member that went into something
similar uh did and there even know that
they found success for without it is it
still one of those things where like
your family's like I love that you you
know you had success to this it's like
well we still would want you to be a
doctor yeah I was gonna ask you about
not anymore no no uh yeah they there
came a point where they realized just uh
how successful full I was at at this
thing nice and they're like okay you
know what you're doing you just do your
thing they stopped uh to get the cold
sign up yeah exactly they stopped trying
to push me towards their their idealized
version of what I'm supposed to be
supposed to be no that's exactly yeah
that's good you know the whole doctor
lawyer thing that's a that's a thing you
know yeah they they wanted to be because
that's the high paying jobs and you know
it comes from a place yeah they just
want you to be secure exactly parent you
you want the best for your child and 100
you already know like the pitfalls of
life ahead of you so yeah for sure help
them you know you know guide them
through it and what yeah what would be a
most successful path and if your child
is going through a path that is unknown
that's that's yeah right they don't you
know for sure for sure and my parents
you know uh Korea was not in a good
place back then it was a very poor
country ravaged and my parents lived
through poverty and so they they lived
through a very different life than I did
and so part of me understands their
mentality of like these are the jobs
that will ensure you don't go through
what we went through like gaming what is
that gonna do for you and those those
are different times gaming wasn't as big
back then so like I understand but uh
you know at the same time it's now that
we're at a point where we're more stable
and we can explore our passions you know
I think they've come around to the idea
of okay we got to let our kids just kind
of do their thing now because with my
sister I think they're a little like
she's a lot younger than I am there
there were a lot more
free freeing in terms of allowing her to
explore
I'm I'm uh the middle child I have an
older brother and a younger sister so
your older brother had it worse
my older brother knew he wanted to
become an astronomer and my my parents
liked that idea and so he's currently
getting his Doctorate actually trying to
you know working towards getting that
um and so they're like that's actually
like you know that seems uh I'm sure
prestigious you know so that was rough
for you he's not want to be in a
strawberry
I don't know I wanted to be all kinds of
things at one point I actually wanted to
be a game developer and stuff like that
I never thought I'd end up being a
content creator you know that wasn't
even a term we used back in the day you
know uh but I just knew that I I love
the I love gaming and I loved the
creative side of me I love I used to
sketch a lot back in the day and then
acting was always uh you know once I got
into it I just like it I just knew that
I wanted to do this for as long as I
could yeah in school
so one more time did you do a theater in
school yes uh uh a friend of mine
convinced me an audition for Bye Bye
Birdie junior year of high school and uh
you know I didn't get a huge part at
that time but I remember just the and
part of it is that you know some cast
and Crews can get really
um I don't they can be there can be
toxic cast and crew sometimes I happen
to have a casting crew or a very
supportive of each other and it was this
like communal thing we were all trying
to make together and tell a story or
present this play to bring people join
whatever and like just being up there on
stage and having that connection with
the audience and understanding the
impact that uh the Arts like this can
have performance arts uh that Not only
was that a whole lot of fun uh it just
it made me realize that there's more to
this than just uh the applauses you know
it is about that connection with the
people who partake in these shows and so
uh yeah there was just something to that
that I was really attracted to that's
dope man that's dope and um I love
hearing you know obviously it's funny
because we kind of have similar
backgrounds with restrictive parents and
then you realize that okay this is his
gift this is what he loves to do you
know he's at that point and then
obviously you mentioned the theater
background which you know was very
interesting to me he's always had that
passion there so I want to get back into
the content creation part because
obviously there was a push pull at one
point you know yeah we won we have young
we have him our envisionist for him to
do X Y and Z and then this content
creation like what started that talk
about that Journey that kind of pushed
you in there yeah early videos that
whole bit
funny enough my theatrical Endeavors is
what pushed me towards YouTube because I
was auditioning for this musical
um it's called The Mystery of Edwin
drude and one of the roles required me
to have a British accent that I was
auditioning for and I was like you know
I want to test my British accent and I
want people to be honest with me I know
if I like go to my friends they'll be
like oh that's good enough and you know
they won't be honest
kind yeah
oh yeah the internet
oh the internet gonna tell you they'll
tell you exactly so I started uploading
and I'm like okay what's a topic I can
talk about well I love gaming and I
always keep up with gaming news so I
just like I don't know do that and like
do it in a British accent and see if
people notice that I'm not from Britain
videos being British and I I started
uploading some videos and the you people
from the UK were like where in the
who is this dude
that was not the role for me
um
as I kept uploading those videos I began
to realize how much fun I was having
with that and eventually you know like
an MCN reached out and said hey you know
you can make money off of this right uh
and I was like really uh and you know
slowly but surely I I eventually dropped
the dumb British accent and I started a
proper Channel which is Young yeah
absolutely Rebecca what was the old
Channel today I got to know what the old
one day was but he was doing British
still up oh we got the receipts
come on
come on limitations up bro you you made
it you can tell us where you came from
we gotta hear British
exclusive y'all what is it called
it's called project Cheerio
[Applause]
I'm searching right now continue I was
young I was young and stupid all right
this is great dude I got a question
um you know I live in New York City and
you know Broadway was a is a thing and I
know if Sovereign was here uh he would
not let you get away with asking this
question because he's okay frequent
Broadway going do you like as far as
your acting go every dream of playing on
Broadway like even if it's all the
roadway or something like that like a
goal of yours
you know I will always have a love for
feeder in particular
um I love voice acting and you know on
camera stuff I hope to do someday as
well but there's something about just
being live and present with the audience
in the same room right the energy of
that there's just nothing like it it's
terrifying
and it's this uh this connection that
that just
um yeah I I would love to do theater
again uh but it's just it's such a
time-consuming thing to rehearse to
memorize all the lines to block
everything out and then having to be
there because it's not a recording that
you can just have people infinitely Play
It's you have to be there to perform
every night right and so one day I hope
to find some chunk of time where I can
commit to something like that and and if
it's Broadway I mean hell yeah I would
love to do that but man I got so much
going on with content creation Now with
voice acting and all these things that
it it feels like it's not gonna happen
anytime soon uh because I I want to
focus on a few things instead of
spreading myself too thin and so but
yeah it would be a dream come true to be
able to be a part of at least one you
know Off-Broadway or even just Broadway
production yeah bro I got a chance to
see
um like the last performance of cats oh
yeah yeah before they left I got a
chance to see the last performance of uh
Miss Saigon I thought Miss Saigon was
the greatest because they had a whole
half a helicopter on the stage
um it was the greatest performance I've
ever seen
um I saw uh vampires I saw Spider-Man
the last performance of Spider-Man when
it was there that's Spider-Man whoa
nowhere it was dope it was that
Spider-Man I can see why he hurt himself
because he was doing a lot of things
yeah man but being present in the moment
and getting that energy from the crowd
and the actors No cameras is up it's
just you being present and building
memories right there that's incredible
so yeah yeah I hope everything and every
performance is gonna be a little unique
like every night when you do a
theatrical place like you're not gonna
do something exactly the same twice so
every performance is a little unique
yeah it's a not like a movie exactly
where it's exactly the same sound and
exactly the same picture this is just
like the actors are feeling the Vibes
and just acting and reacting
and sometimes they they will ad-lib some
things because maybe something got
messed up and they gotta find their way
back to the proper lines and you know it
generates unique memories every night
and so like yeah there's nothing like it
I I really love the theme so I just
found project Cheerio it is amazing
it is amazing salute to you for that I
like to come clean video but anyway oh
we're gonna move forward but I was gonna
ask you though someone strange yeah it's
great so now all right so you're doing
that you know what was so then you
switch and you said okay I'm doing young
yeah the YouTube channel right so like
now you're creating content like what
was the moment or video specifically
that you personally realized like yo I
may have something special going on
right here yeah
um actually so it was around my second
year of college when I really started
taking YouTube seriously and I decided
to stop
uh stop my college Endeavors stop a year
or two and just try to do this full time
unfortunately my parents at the time
were trying to pay for my older
brother's College fees and it was
getting too much so I I proposed what if
I take some time off from my studies and
pursue my creative Endeavors my parents
were like all right you make a sound
negotiations yeah negotiation and um so
they're like you know we'll give you a
year or two and let's see what happens
and
um yeah that actually early on I started
making Skyrim videos
um and I I'm a big Elder Scrolls fan so
and those videos like were doing
surprisingly well given just what an
unknown presence I was in the YouTube
space at the time so that was an
indicator of like oh okay like I'm I I I
can mix something out of this and then
came Metal Gear that's when I think I
became known as like oh this is the guy
for this yes right uh I became like the
metal gear guy on YouTube because not a
whole lot of people were making content
uh and like making constant uh like
gaming news updates about the game or
theorizing on the level that I was and
then others eventually did start
trickling in but I kind of uh the
consistency at which I uploaded Metal
Gear content just
um made me the de facto guy to go to for
metal here on YouTube during the metal
gear solid five like ground zeros and
Phantom Pain days nice and
um yeah and as you game near closer to
launch you know those videos gain a lot
more traction because it just the game
was trending more and more
um and that's when I got to really
Network and meet a lot of people and um
and and
that's when my channel got sort of in
the tens of thousands of subscribers
okay yeah and then I feel about the
lolly lolly
yeah I was disgusted at that point
that's what Katrina lost me I ain't
gonna lie to you I was all the way there
and I never forget that and I was a
little disgusted young I ain't gonna
like it I felt I felt I felt a little a
little offended but did it did not have
that effect on you about overreacting
with it
big
I I I'm such a metal gear fan that I I
know what he's doing I I can I
understand the story of metal gear
pretty well and so I I personally get
what he's doing
um I'm not saying it's necessarily for
everyone but
um I personally appreciate the Kojima
antics of Storytelling I don't know it's
uh say what you want about it but
there's nothing like it
there's a style and you know not not his
dialogue is not always
uh the most nuanced per se you know but
uh there is genuine heart and like some
always fascinating ideas and themes that
are exploring
um and so you can really feel his
identity as a Creator as an artist
through these games and and like that's
yeah the most I'm taking anything away
from anything he did I thought it was
fantastic everything I mean I was really
invested in the story yeah it's still
that part when he said that part it was
like a lot I said what what what do you
just say yeah yeah yeah I think it was
uh cognac because you know it's a single
player game then we all got the game and
we're all sitting in the house with the
with the lights off and we're playing in
the dark you know we're taking turns if
you die we pass the controller oh sure
yeah so we we got to that part and
everybody just kind of looked at each
other
well actually actually before that I
mean that one was controversial because
you I mean first graphic they remember
the demo for PS2 on the boat and we were
just like regime is in his back this is
the most beautiful thing you could put
the bodies in the lockers and yeah or it
was insane and then we're playing it and
remember the big controversy King was
actually after the big shell board and
you play as Raiden who we didn't know
who he was so a lot of people like yo I
want snake who is this guy remember that
that was the guy I wasn't as mad at that
but um that was a big controversy at
that time with that particular yeah yeah
no for me like I don't know the just
because mentioned sort of towards the
end when all the airlines start going
haywire and for me
the the whole the term was very ominous
for some reason you know it's like it
sounds infantile but it's coming from
this AI that's kind of going a little
crazy and you know these characters that
we thought were our allies suddenly
turned out to be all fake and so now
they're talking about I need scissors 61
whatever I don't know and saying all
these things turn off your game console
and I I just as a kid playing this I I
was just like losing my mind what the
hell is going on yeah and so I I
remember those moments very uh very
fondly in a very like terrifying way oh
it's obvious connotation for you yeah
yeah okay sometimes throwing a term like
Lili low which sounds like gibberish but
it has meaning and you're like what does
what does that mean you know it creates
a mystery and Intrigue to it that I kind
of enjoyed weirdly yeah
yeah I respect it yeah but now
I get that everyone now everyone has
their own different perspectives on
metal gear for some people it's all very
silly and I get that like it can be
really silly and yeah I have friends who
think the same way not not for me for me
it was like the epitome of spy Espionage
yeah because I really wanted uh a
mission impossible game and that's what
it felt like you know it felt like that
it wasn't 007 this was mission
Impossible and then and it's a distinct
too yeah you know Mission Impossible is
in the shadows uh double seven is out
there he's telling people I'm Bond I'm
James Bond yeah yeah yeah and snake is
different you you won't know your fine
snake or you hear about snake or your
sea snake and then when you got
oscillate and all that other stuff yeah
really thought his Games took that
because I would watch the TV show of
Mission Impossible and it yeah took that
idea with it and I thought yeah with
mechs and with Supernatural Powers
it's almost like uh like a superhero
yeah kind of scenario you've got your
your gallery of villains almost with
their own unique powers but it's all
very like he grounds it as much as he
can as well but also there's a lot of
humor and silliness to it so it's just a
unique blend of things that is very
unique from your typical like spy
Thriller of that yeah absolutely just
really stood out to me and I love the
way how Kojima would always utilize the
hardware in new and different ways like
uh take your memory card out don't put
in another style put the controller into
the other slide and that's the way that
you can beat this guy it
the thought process going into making
games with him encompasses everything
and I think he becomes whatever the
title is for that period of time and she
goes throughout the you know the title
yeah yeah absolutely salute I agree I
agree because Jim is a legend and he's
done so many unique things in the space
No Doubt so I'm just going to answer
obviously Venezuela are you doing that
thing at school yeah the channel now at
this point when did the the deal of the
move happen so that was the move at the
start of the channel or before as far as
when Delaware from my understanding yeah
so I was supposed to move I moved in
like May of 2019 is when I moved out to
LA okay I was supposed to move here in
2017. but that was right around the time
when my channel really started to blow
up I started you know I knew that a
kitten just stick to metal gear and news
because you know especially after the
Konami Code you must split happen I knew
that if I just stuck to Metal Gear my
channel would die uh so I had to
diversify I had to just and I had been
covering other games like Final Fantasy
XV or versus 13 and Fallout 4 I covered
those games alongside Metal Gear as well
and so I I knew that I could expand my
horizons and maybe some metal gear fans
will unsubscribe or whatever but I also
knew that a lot of people were there
just because they enjoyed the way I
presented information and so I decided
to just like start covering gaming games
industry stuff in general whether it's
news for specific games or things
happening in the industry as a whole and
and especially with how the Kojima
Konami stuff played out I I started to
become more critical of just how game
companies and higher-ups and Executives
would you know handle certain situations
and stuff like that and so covering Mass
Effect uh Andromeda and Star Wars
Battlefront 2 and just what a mess those
launches were that that's when my
channel got into the hundreds of
thousands of view of subscribers and
that's what I'm like oh I can reach a
million like I can do this
um and that's around 27 is when that
explosion started to happen so I was
like let's hold off on voice acting for
like a year or two because this is a
critical period of my channel where like
I can really
um
set a foundation for it and and set
myself up financially in a way where I
can move to LA and live comfortably
right and just do the acting without
having to worry about oh my God am I
going to make it through the next day or
through the next month of rent or
whatever
and so two years later in 2019 my
channel was like at like 900 and you
know almost a million subscribers I
moved to LA and like a month later I
reached a million and by that point uh
financially I was doing pretty well for
myself pretty comfortable
um and so I'm like now is the time like
I can feel that this is the time and so
in May of 2019 I moved out here and at
the same time while I was doing
youtubing I was doing free voice over
projects yeah yeah for mods I was uh
also just absorbing information there's
this website called I want to be a voice
actor.com
from D Bradley Baker who was one of the
voice acting greats uh he just set up
this free website with all the resources
and and insights you could possibly need
to get you started and so yeah and then
combine that with my experiences with
theater I did a theater for like eight
years straight like every semester I
would do some kind of theatrical
production combined with all that I just
felt prepared you know I was getting the
fact that I was booking
um roles from like these free vo
auditions or like that that were not
paid but the fact that people were
impressed enough to hire me for some of
this stuff and the reactions that I was
getting through my theatrical endeavors
where people had strong reactions to
some of the scenes that I was in I felt
like I was actually good at this because
that's the that's the hard thing to know
about yourself as an actor is like am I
actually good uh
you know how do I compare myself to
other actors and all that but there came
a point where I felt prepared and so
um through that website and you the I
want to be a voice actor.com I was like
okay I need to get some reels voice over
demo reels I need to set up my website
and I have to just like kick off
sprinting I need to like let the vo
World know that I'm here right and I'm
ready to work now
um and so after my move to uh to LA in
May of 2019 I uh E3 happened so I first
did that and got myself situated and
then throughout like October November
December I got my demo reels done for
video games uh animation and Commercial
I set up my website and I also did took
some classes nice
um and in one of the classes uh
somebody noticed uh one of my
performances it was like an introductory
class and they were like you don't
belong in the introductory class here is
my business card and also this is a
casting director let them know that I
referred you to them and they'll and
send them your reels and your website
and then they'll start sending you
auditions and that's how I got my first
auditions for anime stuff um and then in
January of 2020 I got my first ever role
uh marbus in this anime called Welcome
to demon school irumakum and from there
on you know I just kept getting
auditions kept networking and eventually
that started to build and build and then
once my resume got to a certain point I
uh decided I want to get an agent
because that's going to help me land
roles like hiru you know um and so yeah
a year yeah for sure a year or two later
and was it a year later or two years I
don't know time is a blur during the
covet times
um
but eventually yeah I put this tweet out
saying you know this is the year that
I'm gonna get an agent wish me luck
right and gracious Tommy Earl Jenkins I
don't know if you know who he is he
plays uh die Hardman and oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah with the mask yeah yeah
we had connected because I covered some
debt stranding but he also saw that I
was like you know pursuing voice over
and uh when I tweeted that he messaged
me and said I can't guarantee anything
but I see you doing the work and I see
you're really passionate about this call
my agent and see you know or email my
agent let them know I referred you to my
nice to them
and send them your reel send them your
stuff and see what they say and so he
opened that door for me and then they
looked at my material and they're like
they liked what they heard we did an
interview and then they eventually said
welcome to the roster of sbv this is
fire and that's when I started getting
the big bigger auditions for the AAA
games the the union stuff right and
eventually I got into a union project
and got into sag and then that's when
all the yeah that from then on I really
started kicking off now we're talking
like Demon Souls JoJo Adventure
um are we talking lost Judgment at that
point well yeah lost judgment was Union
okay yes last judgment was Union and I
got the audition through SPV uh uh
JoJo's uni was well JoJo wasn't Union
until part uh
five or oh season five or part six in
the manga Sun ocean because that was a
direct to Netflix type of release
instead of an episodic thing got it and
any any anime that comes out on Netflix
is automatically Union so JoJo was Union
and I got yeah yeah and I got the
audition for Poochie and um put my heart
and soul into that and I still can't
believe I I got that one nice and things
just kind of yeah snowball from there
you know because more people start to
know who you are they start to see see
your work and they you know a lot of
a lot about casting is not necessarily
just talent but also like can we trust
this person yes to do the work and to
not be a pain in the ass to work with
and all these things so your reputation
as an actor matters as well and you know
I'd like to think that I'm pretty easy
to work with and pretty cooperative and
so
um eventually yeah more people start to
recognize uh my work and then we get
things are just kind of flying off yeah
do you find that um they tell you that
uh uh so-and-so recommended you because
I had such a great experience with him
yes uh do you find that a lot and that's
how you get the entry in I mean because
it's like a key to get into the door
it's like a pass and you get to pass in
but you got to work your way in there
yes do you feel that um prevalent in
that industry yeah it's not all it is
but there's definitely roles that I've
gotten
um because somebody was like oh I
remember I worked with this guy right
and his performance wasn't right for
this role but I remember just liking
what he did and then I think about it
that he might be well suited for this
role and so might get cast just off that
because of an audition for something
else that made them go oh that could be
good for something else
um or they had such a positive
impression working with me or or what
not that they're like uh you know I
already know what his vocal range is and
I know he's easy to work with and I know
we can bring him in and he'll be
available on the spot let's just let's
just hire him and so there have
definitely been occasions where just
having that Goodwill
um because of your work ethic or your
talent or just your attitude and your
graciousness all that all of that is a
factor in the casting director saying
okay so we'll finish this project but
yeah you are perfect for this other
project that I have yes and look out for
oh yeah we're gonna get to that the
exactly
what was the um what was your question
do you think that your Fame and all your
hard work on YouTube helped you have
more opportunities in the voice acting
thing
because I'm sure you make connections
that in some way shape or form
cross-platform between your YouTube and
your voice acting
not as much as people would think
casting directors off more often than
not don't even know yeah
they just they just want the best actor
you know I mean like they're not looking
for not to say that like at the end of
the casting directors they'll recommend
some folks and then it's up to like the
big honchos running yes the the
development of a game or anime or
animation whatever to be like we want
this guy and so in that sense sometimes
follower numbers can have an influence
where it's like well these two are
really good but this guy could give us a
little more marketing so let's go I've
heard that stuff happen but it's like to
even get to that point where you're like
top two top three you have to be good
the casting director has to notice your
talent and so like I I not a single role
that I've gone has been a result of
somebody going oh young yeah the
YouTuber oh he's gonna Market our game
or our animation or anime he's an
influencer let's let's get him on board
so we can sell more copies like people
overestimate my ability to sell copies
or to make people you know I've seen a
lot of like YouTubers and stuff say they
want to do stuff like that and you don't
see them doing it so exactly clearly
there's more of a barrier than people
think between one or the other yes uh it
they don't they just care about you
being able to deliver the performance
for the role like that's their job but
casting directors are under a lot of
pressure to cast the right actor for the
right role because they know that if
somebody's miscast then it can lead to a
lot of backlash it can lead to negative
PR and marketing and stuff like that and
so they want actors to be to to be the
solution to their problem which is who
do we cast for this character and so you
just got to bring your A game and um you
know I I mentioned how I the reason I
got to know Tommy at all is because of
my coverage of death stranding so like
there's stuff like that where help with
networking of course but why I got into
my agency sbv isn't because I had a
YouTube channel it's because my reels
were good I had a website I had a good
resume
um we the interview went well there was
a whole process to that it wasn't just
yongya influencer yes
what you're saying is
the Yong yay helped you get in the door
but the young a voice actor is what got
you the rose
um
to a degree yes uh but but sbv didn't
like unless like my channel was like
just
I mean talking about all kinds of like
weird crazy things and like I was being
just awful as a human being right it's
like they generally you know and I guess
the fact that I was that I'm passionate
about gaming just I it just helps me
know what to do with video game
auditions because I play so many of them
and I know what that sounds like and so
there's stuff like that where it helps
but uh generally this notion that I'm
getting I've got to where I am because
I'm an influencer is no [__] like it
really is language day but we let that
one slip because we knew that was from
the heart
no I knew that was from the heart dude
you was like Hey nobody gonna say I feel
with you I have a question yeah
um being that on the website the um you
know how to be a voice actor.com did
that teach you to um have all those
things in a row have all those uh
different um aspects set up because you
know somebody might go in with one
aspect but if they don't go to the
website to understand that you need
these tools in order to get this you
know like you you have your reels you
you have your website you have this and
that and the third did that help you to
uh have that package available to be
seen because you you have to come with a
complete package you do um yeah no you
with voice acting you you are running a
business and the product is you as a
performer and so you gotta make your
quote unquote product shine and that's
something that yeah I want to be a voice
actor.com website like outlines all that
like here's once you feel like you're
ready right
um like don't go make spend a couple
thousand dollars on reels when you're
not at your Peak as an actor because
then you're just gonna get bad reels and
then you know the agencies or whatever
they're going to listen to and go this
guy's just not ready you're going to
make a bad first impression right do not
make a bad first impression like
practice the craft I did eight years of
theater that's what made me good at
acting and I was not a good actor
starting out trust me
I can confirm that
yeah uh but uh you know I just I love
the thing and I kept doing it until I
got good at it and so and your your
voice over reels they're your calling
card that's like your business card for
agencies and for any Studios that might
be uh considering adding you to their
roster for auditions and stuff like that
and then the website helps you keep
everything organized in one place you
can upload your reels on your website
you can have your resume on your website
and just have a One-Stop shop place
where if somebody's interested like
maybe I want to work with this guy where
do I go to see like his work they can
boom have very easy access to all of
that information yeah if you make their
life easy to to like gain interest in
you then you know it's just gonna
increase the chances of people noticing
you and your work and you being able to
get in the door and stuff like that so
um it's about due diligence really
that's it it's not about my YouTube
channel and stuff like that I did the
work
it wasn't easy to I busted my ass to get
to the position that I'm in now every
voice actor did I do want to follow up
I'm sorry real quick I see people in the
chat no I'm not saying stuff people act
like just because I ask a question that
like those are going off my beliefs
I don't know that's a good question it's
a good question is there ever a time
where you feel like
you might put up the YouTube sheet uh
the Youtube channel for voice action you
think you'll always be like a mixture of
both
oh I I'd like to think that I'll always
I mean I love gaming as much as I love
voice acting as well and I I love
talking about games so I
I want to keep both uh going for as long
as I can like I can't tell what the
future holds you know I ultimately I do
have a greater passion for acting like
if somebody you know like put a gun to
my head and had to give up one or the
other like yeah you know it'd be a
really hard choice but I love acting
really that's why I'm like that's your
passionate Joy it is my passion exactly
I just want to shout out to chat Tom
Henderson in the chat shout out to Gene
Park in the chat young yay gang all
right
look I want to follow up because we're
gonna get to the Magic Moment before you
guys one other question that King kind
of alluded to and you mentioned earlier
which is a reference to your vocal range
right and one thing I always felt very
interesting about voice acting in a
gaming space especially people who do it
for a long time is this wide spectrum of
voices and characters and you know you
have to it's so varied right so yeah how
difficult is it when you're building
your resume of these personalities and
these roles how yeah how difficult is to
hone these all these different voices
and characters and personalities to it
and like was it just all for the website
like what helped you learn the form
formulate that process
yeah well you know one of the ways that
I'd make my little sister laugh back in
the day was making dumb noises you know
so I've always had a propensity for you
know just just starting like this all
the time at one point or you know going
back down here or whatever you know like
I I would just do dumb random things
with my voice but ultimately you know
the voice is just the instrument the
essence of The Craft is the performance
right it's called voice acting people
just focus on the voice and they're like
well I can make funny noises am I a
voice actor would be sad
as that voice can you be joyful as that
voice can you express anger as that
voice can you take the backstory of that
character and find those nuances of how
this character would behave in a certain
scenario with that voice that's what
makes a performance shine
um right it's like you can be you can
have the best guitar in the world but if
you don't know how to play it and
express yourself through it
doesn't matter how beautiful your
instrument sounds
yeah yeah so having those voices like
there are some people like Nolan North
more often than not performs with his
Nolan North voice you know he doesn't
really try to shift his voice Lance
Reddick he's just Lance right right you
can immediately pick him out he's Gonna
Roll But he like his performance just
just defines those specific characters
and differentiates those characters even
though it's basically just his voice
um so it it's to focus on the
performance is really what's going to
get you those roles but certain
characters do Sid within certain vocal
ranges like kitty was not gonna sound
like this yeah he's better than that
because I'm not buying that much
gotta bring him down
um who did you Fanboy out are we gonna
get there I got you sorry you late you
late I got you yeah
um so but finding all the you know
that's just experimentation you know I
if you turned on a camera on me uh in my
apartment while I'm alone I'm constantly
just like talking to myself sometimes
the scene will pop up in my head and be
like oh let's play with that and I'll
just try to find a voice for this
character that I have in my head and
I'll just I'll just experiment it's like
you know when when chefs try to come up
with new recipes you know they just kind
of start messing around and that's
really all it is just play like it
treat it like remember when you were
five years old and you were I don't know
you were Spider-Man or something and
it's like in that moment you were oh
Spiderman I was being with you G.I Joe's
in the Transformers exactly I was one of
the voices and all that yes yeah true
right yeah you're right and it's like
about going back there where you didn't
care about any of the judges and you
don't care about how silly or stupid or
whatever you looked you just care about
how much fun you were having and how
immersed you were in that moment as
Spider-Man as Superman as whatever
character you embodied in that moment
and if you can get there and just have
fun and just lose yourself in the role
and then trust your instincts as an
actor
you know that that's where the the most
authentic performances come from I feel
no fair enough so now we're going to
transfer this kid was right on point he
was right off point so I got another
question I know you don't got this one
okay go ahead okay
have you ever been on uh um a recording
in that code
I had a cold yeah I had a cold
especially because yeah
well I did have you know there's some
sessions that are very intense where
it's a lot of screaming and so that
strains my voice and that definitely led
me to like having to take some breaks in
between and drink some tea or something
and make sure that I don't hurt my
instrument you know so what does it go
to what is your go-to to keep your
instrument uh in perfect performance
pause there's this
um like it's like the syrup called nin
nimjum
n-i-m-j-i-o-m and it's uh it's this
minty kind of syrupy Honey kind of
formula or something and I just like
take a spoon and and have a a tablespoon
of that and then one of my casting
direct or one of my voice directors
taught me this thing where I just like
put leave that in my mouth and just
gargle for a little bit and then slowly
swallow and then that'll like coat my
vocal cords just really yeah help with
the relief of it nice But ultimately no
matter how what kind of treatment you do
for your vocal cords if you push too far
yeah you will hurt it so there comes a
point where you have to like know your
limits and go okay I think this is about
as much as I can do today if I do any
more you're gonna lie I will facts I'm
gonna lose it and there did come there
was a point in like March of uh last
year where I had a really bad case of
laryngitis because I screamed so much
and it that one lasted for like two
months I was scared
right there yeah that I would not come
back
um and that there was certain vocal
ranges where I just the voice flaps were
just not you know so I went to see a
laryncologist and like made sure that I
was set and all it took was just a
really long rest right wow um but that
was scary so like yeah this is once this
is gone that's permanent and you can't
just buy a new guitar
be very careful great question that was
great all right so we got to get to the
matching boom we've been procrastinating
levels so look you know obviously you're
building this resume wide range of
voices you get the agent you're out
there you know young yeah the the voice
actor is out on these streets getting
these rolls so now you know
how does it happen because
we know Sega we know rgg you know um we
know that the role of Kazama Kiryu but
like you have a funny twist to it
because from my understanding you almost
missed the role you almost missed the
opportunity please tell the people the
whole process I had this happen oh God
yeah so
um there are just some days where you
got so many emails that you might one or
two might slip through the cracks and
you know uh there are some days where
just auditions flooding all at once and
it just it's just overwhelming and the
way I keep track of my auditions is I
tag them uh in my inboxes audition then
I flag and I pin them all the way to the
top and you know I that way I know when
they're due and stuff like that I can
keep track of them and for some reason
just it was the the Yakuza audition the
one that I happen to miss that day where
I just didn't flag it and tag it and
whatever and so for a month or so I just
I was blissfully ignorant about the fact
that I just missed out on some of the
most important auditions I would ever do
but then I had worked on uh lost
judgment before that yes with PCB
Productions uh and uh they you know I I
was uh I I was in good terms with you
know Keith Aaron who's a casting
director and and we had work together
and we had a great time and so uh and I
remember him uh
uh like he he actually had me in mind
for this other role okay for this one of
the upcoming games uh and so he really
wanted me to audition for this and so he
reached out to me directly a month after
he had sent out those auditions uh
saying hey anger we noticed you did an
audition uh I hope we you know are you
like ignoring us or something yeah do
something wrong and I'm like oh no no I
just I was just dumb and missed the
audition and he gave it a nudge yeah
exactly yeah and I'm really grateful
that he did
um though funny enough the first well I
checked my inbox to make sure that I got
that email and I did I'm like oh my God
I can't believe I missed it that first
email that I got with all the auditions
did not have kirio in it okay okay cool
it was the second round of auditions
where he contacted me contacted me
directly where I got all those sites and
curious I'm wondering like if I had
auditioned back then what I had been
cast for another role and would have
never gotten the chance to auditions you
know that's what I'm saying it's like
it's weird did I just get Lucky by
missing that first round of auditions
could be you know what I mean did that
allow me to get cute I don't know
or was it
it's things like that because you're not
in a place that you're not supposed to
be at the time you're supposed to be
there yes you're just there right yeah
and I and I and I believe that um in in
practicing certain things
yeah that you're always going to be at
the proper place that you're supposed to
be yeah I I think you're meant to get
the roles that you were meant to get
like there's just some roles that just
fit you so well within the minds and
vision of the creators of a project that
it's it was always meant to happen if
you happen to be especially at the right
place at the right time and luck plays a
factor into it yeah being at the right
place at the right time but that only
takes you so far if you don't know how
to seize those opportunity moments then
you're just gonna miss out yes
um but yeah eventually I remember seeing
this PDF file labeled dragon and I'm
like no no way God and curious face
shows up it's his lines and I'm just
like
I couldn't comprehend it and now I
literally you know I had like I was
working on a video and I had all this
stuff planned for the next two days I
was like I cleared my schedule I was
like I can't do YouTube right now I
can't focus on anything right now I
gotta nail all these auditions and I did
audition for every character it was like
wow I don't know like a dozen characters
or something that they sent out
including Kiryu I auditioned for all of
them but kyria was the one that I spent
days and days on
and I mean it was to the point where I
would send the audition in a day later
I'd listen back to and be like wait a
minute I have another idea I can do
something else and then I'd be like hey
uh so there's this uh new audition file
that I'd like to send in that I think is
a little more refined do you mind
replacing my old files
yeah yeah and and one of the assistants
at PCB uh her name's Haven shout out to
her for allowing me to do this she'd be
like I get I get where you're at right
now I will help you with this if you we
actually have a few more days uh where
we're not gonna check these auditions so
if you want to keep refining until the
deadline oh that's nice yeah yeah feel
free to keep sending them and so for
days and days I would like get new ideas
or I I'd like hear something I'm like
that's not quite right and then I just
keep keep refining until I I really felt
like I found the character so that was
the first round of auditions and then
came the second round which was the
Callback right uh so that's why I'm like
oh actually you do have a chance like
I'm in the top like contenders
um and the note that I got in the second
round questions was
find try to find more emotional nuances
because in the first audition I focus
too much on the voice and this is what I
mean by like it's not voice it's voice
acting yes
I focus so much on like oh where should
he sit vocally and then I it just felt
really flat emotionally I was just
reading lines as a voice instead of like
feeling emoting yeah emoting exactly and
so for the second round of auditions now
that I had sort of the voice of where he
sits down right and I was like okay I
got a call back so they clearly like
where that voice sits so let's keep it
there and now find those emotional
nuances where's curious headspace is he
sad is he happy is he melancholic why is
he in the state that he is and how does
that affect the way he speaks and what's
hard about Kiryu is he's so stoic
and stoic characters are so hard to play
they're the hardest characters to play
because with a character who's really
expressive he can be really happy or
really sad with Keira it's like I'm
happy I'm sad you know I mean like yeah
obviously that's not not really how it's
going to come across in the game but
what I'm saying is like it's there it's
so the range is here right and you've
got to find very nuanced things that
won't lose the character and the badass
stoicism of Kiryu while still expressing
those little emotions those little ones
yep those little nuances that make you
go oh there's like yeah whether it's in
the pauses or little fluctuations that
inform oh he's like feeling something
here yeah he's going through something
here but he's not trying to show it to
you it almost here is not a character
who shows unless he's like really pissed
and he's like you know Yakuza zero one
of my favorite moments is when he sees
tachibana being tortured by kuze and he
goes
he just like punches me in the face and
it's just the most visceral scream so
it's like
has those moments but mostly he's just
in that pocket right and it also reminds
me of Kratos a bit right because he's
one of those guys right where it's like
you're going he's a pocket so you have
to catch certain little variants to
understand when something is Solemn to
him or you know because normally in his
tone he's angry right yes you have to
when when he's talking to his son
he has to find that gentleness in that
yes right and gentleness right yeah and
that's the thing about Kiryu he's a very
he's what I how would I would describe
his vocal range and performance he's a
very gentle Dragon he's got that
guttural that commanding presence but
you almost feel safe with him when he
when you're when he's not pissed at you
how did you find strength because when
when I hear it I hear strength right
yeah so how did you find that strength
in that character to project strength
through your voice
oh man uh a lot of that is informed by
you know the lines the specific scenes
and then
it's just it man it's hard to describe
how I find that because it's just about
being present in the booth and just
exerting that energy when you're there
right and it's just about finding that
place and um strength isn't just about
being loud right you can you know
there's a you can be you can say you
know you know Screw You versus just
screw you just that one like that
quieter screw you can be can speak
louder than the louder like screw you
you know so it's it's about finding
those moments where Kiryu like
he can be very commanding without doing
much you know what I mean and so it's
about not doing much too much it's about
like less is more sometimes
um and that's the case with Kiryu again
he sits in such a specific pocket and if
you try to do too much it's just not
going to feel like it's not going to be
him yeah good stuff and so yeah but
again he has those explosive moments as
well of like Rage or of sadness or
whatever and those moments you know are
important to capture as well so how long
does um sorry how long does the role
like last
um that you're doing the role and do you
find yourself to be a method actor that
when you're outside of the road you're
going to get donuts or or whatever right
whatever you're gonna go pick up
something are you curious
outside of the booth uh do you carry him
with you until that role is over because
a lot of actors do that and it works it
helps with the performance so I I want
to know does the is that how you work or
or yeah uh so yeah we've been working on
Curie for a couple months now and
I you know I I
I think to me there is a line when it
comes to method acting some people just
go a little too far and go a little too
crazy with it to the point where they
just start being jerks or just hard to
work with and I don't want to be that
threats and stuff
yeah right
for me uh one of the things that I
really took to heart was when I asked
takaikurora doing the Anime Expo when we
met up let's go uh what his advice would
be when playing Kiryu and he said this
really wonderful thing he said
curio the one of the one of his biggest
attributes is he's a gentleman in the
truest sense of the word
if you're a gentleman in real life
then that'll impact your performance as
Kiryu uh it'll it'll help you ground
them as what is he because he's
ultimately yes he has those he has a
scary presence you know he's just
looking at him he's very commanding he's
got that frown and whatever he's got
that stoicism but then you get to know
him
and he's just so kind and he's always so
considerate and he's always trying even
if you if you're a stranger he'll try to
help you even if it takes him on this
insane crazy self-story Journey where he
has to do something embarrassing he'll
still do it for you because he has that
much empathy and it's empathy that
doesn't necessarily come across
physically or emotionally uh because
he's so stoic all the time but through
his actions and um you know once you get
to know him you know through his just
attitude and just how he is as a human
being that gentleness will always come
across and so like yeah I just find that
just just keeping that
kindness and empathy in mind helps me
just get into that space of like this is
who curio ultimately is he isn't iconic
because he's he kicks so much assets I
mean it's part of what makes him iconic
he is badass he is fierce and ferocious
but what really makes him iconic what
really makes him legendary is his
kindness and his empathy absolutely and
that's the thing that always has to be
the core of who this character is within
that stoicism there is a lot of empathy
absolutely and so that helps me ground
the character keeping that in mind and
then I'm behind yeah I got a quick
question for you young uh what out of
all the the stuff let's keep the game
just coming out in the next like two or
three years that we know of what what is
like that dream role that like you you
if if you if they call it tomorrow you
would drop everything to do yeah
honestly
I I want to work on some kind of
dramatic piece with Naughty Dog one day
because God the performance the level of
performance that that demands the level
of emotions and also you're not
concerned you're building a performance
from scratch for these characters
correct you know like with Kiryu I'm
coming in and inheriting this role right
but I want to also just create my own
character who becomes iconic like who I
build from scratch who is based off of
my performance and I think you know with
Naughty Dog they're so performance
driven and they you know with
performance capture and everything I
really want to use my whole body to
convey a character one day
um because I actually fell in love with
Abby yeah yeah that's fair uh a lot of
people did
um I cried when certain things happened
because sure sure yeah I want to
approach those things and then I'd say
another one would be I want to work with
Kojima one day one day
I want to create a character in one of
his worlds and that would bring me great
joy that'd be a
I know we got a couple questions getting
towards Tom but
um we got to talk about obviously you
submit the emotional performance now of
cure you because you're like hey this
was great I found the pocket of the
voice you submit that now let's talk
about when you get the acceptance
uh I remember yeah I know I remember
this day very distinctly I was at PCB
recording for this other project that I
can't talk about yet
um and uh I before the session starts
one of the assistants tell me uh by the
way uh Keith wants to see you and he
wants to talk to you in private now at
the time it had been like a month since
I had sent out the second the Callback
audition
and at that point I figured somebody
else got this part right right and so my
thought process was am I like in trouble
he would speak to you in the back yeah
but the principal would like to see you
now and I'm just like oh no good
accidentally crazy anxiety going on the
whole walk over there yeah yeah yeah and
so but I was in the middle of doing this
other session and uh Valerie Aram uh who
was uh all the voice the other voice
director at PCB who was working with me
on this project uh she kind of gives me
this Inlet you're gonna have a really
good day today
and I'm like and that's when like it
started to click a little bit that wait
could it be no no like I I was like I
don't want to Hope yeah you'll get
yourself hurt I think it is I would be
so hurt so I'm like nah it's not bad
it's not bad it's something else I don't
know some other thing I auditioned for
and then we take a break from that
project we're recording
and uh I meet Keith outside the this
like Courtyard area of this
establishment this the studio and he's
like young uh sit down
um
outside beautiful day and then he just
kind of gives me gives it to me straight
he said so you know we had you you
auditioned for for Yakuza we had you in
mind for this other role that we were
sure we're gonna give to you
but then you sent in that curio audition
and uh we sent it over to Sega and they
loved it
and we got a call yesterday that they
want you to play cure you and it was
like that simple and I just stood there
my ears were kind of ringing you know I
mean because I'm like did he just say
what I heard yeah yeah no I was looking
around for the camera it's like am I on
camera somewhere you're like yeah y'all
punking me what's going on exactly oh
there's the camera
yeah no but uh yeah I know it took me a
second to process the news and and it
was both exhilaration and also like
there's also a side of him that was like
oh my God I'm gonna play cure you and
like this is a this is a huge
responsibility you know this people love
this character I I
gotta bring my a game you know so there
was part of me was like a little
terrified of of just what I'm taking on
you know and and but once I got my
bearings I you know
I this role came to me for a reason you
know and they they liked my audition and
if they chose me
I knew that it was my responsibility
from then on to have fun and along the
way you know just really do this
character Justice and
um because I got to play through all the
the the the Yakuza games recently I was
in a good head space where I understood
um this character's history and there
there are even you know games in this
series often have like callbacks to past
events and stuff like that and so like
I'm like oh I knew what that is I knew
which character he's referencing and I
know what kind of relationship they had
and so like that informs my line read
that informs how I play this scene so
it's like there's stuff like that that
me being a gamer and being so
um
like intertwine with these games and
their stories and like all that really
helped because just me being a fan of
these games really does help in
informing a curious headspace in certain
scenes absolutely um and so I I talk to
you I gotta get I gotta get talk here
yeah yeah and Takaya happened uh you
know we were months into recording at
that point and then I got this
invitation for a panel at Anime Expo at
rgg and they told me that they somehow
managed to get
taco-san to come to the US and
participate in this panel and so we
planned things out behind the scenes
um and then on the day of before I I
went to animex I did have this bespoke
suit made
yeah in some ways on method acting I
suppose I I you know I got the Cure you
beard now
cosplays as much as I can and there's
something about just getting in that
suit that just uh I don't know it felt
like you was wearing it right yeah like
there's an energy to that suit I don't
know because you know it looks just
right and it with the collar up and
everything
gets you in the mood yeah uh but yeah
the Anime Expo day finally came and um
yeah it was a whole day that we had
planned out it was lunch and then an
interview with this new salad and then
the panel and then dinner and so we I
spent all day with with the team from
Japan and with urulasan and it was uh
lovely truly it was uh they were so
gracious and polite and willing to
it didn't feel like Kuroda sun was like
possessive of the role or anything he
was so willing to be like you know
supportive of me uh during the panel you
know he was just so kind with his words
and um uh yeah we we grabbed lunch and
that's when he gave me the the bracelets
yeah uh I I had gifted him this like
Dragon the tattoo patch that I got for
for my jacket I made a second one with
cool last name and printed on it and I
gave that to him
and uh it was a little awkward at first
because of the language barrier then
eventually conversations started to kick
off and I was asking about his
accessories because he's just so the
drip the man is insane insane yes yeah
exactly and so I was just like curious
about his accessories and he uh takes
one uh one of his the one on his left uh
arm off there's a light blue one here
and then a dark blue one here he takes
off the dark blue one and he hands it to
me and he goes that one's for you
um and I was just like are you sure
because that's a pretty that's that
cheap yeah it's not cheap there's like
jewelry in there it's just like I don't
know if this if I'm worthy of this you
know he was like no no this is for you
and later would tell me like I wore this
one a lot when I was performing as Kiryu
and so it really you know there's a
symbolism and meaning to the if not it's
not about how expensive it is you know I
mean it's it's about just the the
sentiment that could express through
that that just gave me a lot of uh
confidence and energy and and
uh yeah I I just feel so grateful uh
that that's just so gracious level of
support yes going into your most
meaningful like you know yeah exacting
job that's that's incredible that
question and that also just made me
understand why Kuro dasan is so perfect
for curio that's the most like hero
thing you could he could have done you
know what I mean and it's not something
that he puts on he he's just naturally a
gentleman he's just naturally that
gracious and he has curious Heart of
Gold and so that made me like
understanding Kuro that sound better
made me understand the character better
in a lot of ways and so I feel like I
can take that and just like Infuse that
and key to you more and
um uh yeah and and sakamoto-sen like
pulled me and say he's like he actually
he usually never
and I'm like yo god let's go bro that's
so dope so that means he truly endorses
you yeah I'm pretty sure that he got a
chance to listen to some of the stuff in
the background like who's gonna be can
over this part and yeah heard it and was
like yeah I got to give him a thumbs up
yeah man I know I I hope so you know I
do want to make uh the folks in Japan
proud and um but you know at the end of
the day I just got to focus on the work
you know obviously I've seen the
cutscenes I've seen how it all Blends
together and um it's it's turning out
really cool I think this is dope I hope
we gotta I'll be remiss if we need to
talk about a little bit of controversy a
little a little mess so um obviously you
know you're out there you do the rgg
panel and stuff like that but then the
internet being that the internet is you
know decided to take some off the cuff
stuff you were doing and then kind of
combine it with footage and be like see
that's the the fittest product of of
yanye's role doing that like how did you
deal with that backlash and as far as
internalizing people try to put together
something that may not be representative
of the finished product yet
yeah I mean you know it's always a
little frustrating when something like
that happens where it
it yeah it's it's because somebody uh
yeah like you said he somebody took just
like
um audio footage from a panel where we
just did this land random line read of a
line that we had we have not recorded
for yet actually honest I don't even
know what the directions for that's
going to be like we don't even know what
the localized version of that line is
going to be like but it was just line
that we decided to throw out there
because we were promoting guidance right
not eight
um and yeah it's just like obviously
it's not going to fit obviously it's not
gonna sound the best either
um but somebody like infused the the
clip with the footage with the audio and
they're like and it they didn't uh add
the context that the line read was from
Anime Expo and so a lot of people
thought it was like
like an off-screen recording of the
official English trailer or something I
don't know a lot of people thought it
was official right and that's the
frustrating part but at the same time
you know a lot of people are not used to
hearing my voices kirio and they haven't
really seen it within the context of the
game and so I get it on some level I get
it it's different it's it's not Daryl
Carrillo that's not what I'm going for
uh I'm going more take that direction
um and you know if you hear
for a lot of people that's great but I
really wanted to bring out kiryu's uh
gentleness you know what I mean and so I
haven't shown much of that side I mean
there's no official footage out there
right and so a lot of it is about just
I'm realizing like I cannot be the news
reporter here I can't just be like
here's an update right right I have to
be patient I just have to stay quiet
yeah let them work the work speak for
myself that's what I was about to give
you advice best advice you just said it
your own self you know what you got yeah
so there was a period where I'm like I
was like trying to be like this is not
official and I'm like I just need to
shut up
fit into the background let people have
the discourse that they will because
when the game comes out that's when
people can really judge and you know at
the end of the day with anything you do
not everyone's gonna be happy with the
way you do it of course
um but what I would say is like imagine
if like the role of snake you've heard
Akio ultugus performance for 20 years
right
um who is the Japanese actor and you
know his voice you know he's a little
rounder a little you know he's not quite
the same as David hater and then the
David hater gets cast 20 years later and
all you hear is kept you waiting huh oh
that was good
and it's like a of course retractively
we know how iconic and awesome that line
is but imagine if like that's the only
reference point you had for the English
name facts after hearing akiotsuka's
performance for 20 years good point it's
like does that one line Define the
entire Arc of curio the entire
performance of Kiryu His Highest his
lows his Joyce his sadness his
melancholy
it's just a line it's one line right you
cannot Define a performance from one
line a line read versus a performance is
different and I'm not saying people need
to love where my voice sits or whatever
like my voice is gonna sit you know
within a certain deeper range and it's
not going to be as deep as corrillos and
again that's not what I'm going for and
some people might not like that and
that's fine like I'm not going to be
able to change those people's minds well
what I do know is that
um we very carefully uh
in in the booth with the director and I
we very carefully try to find that
balance of work your use is
um and where his emotions are at within
certain scenes and Kiryu goes through a
lot around these games so
just just uh
hold out and see the full Arc before
defining up for facts because the
performance is an arc it's not just a
line reader good point no yeah so I was
gonna say at the end of the day
when it comes to stuff like this it
doesn't matter what you do some people
are just going to hate it because it's
not the original person that's why you
said yeah yeah it's nothing you can do
about it yeah and what I've noticed with
stuff like this is like I do think you
you did make the the right decision not
to like bounce back and forth because
until they actually have that in their
hands yeah they're gonna have their
their decision no matter what you said
so it's like just wait to the game I'm
signing off and I do you know I think
that was right I I agree I think that
was the right call he did he handled it
massively I do want to transition from
one question because I don't want to
leave please please please I know you
you're wrapping up in this your last
question
uh okay yeah I was talking in the
background and um the pictures that I
saw uh he didn't have on his trademark
glasses and uh I said uh did he have
Lasik and uh I'll ask I'm gonna ask you
um yeah I've been watching your videos
like forever and you know I've been
tailing off a little bit and when we
showed up in the Green Room you didn't
have on your trademark glasses
um do you want to tell a story about
that or you know how you went about
Lasik because I was going to go get
Lasik gotcha that you know I had a false
nerve palsy and my right eye from a car
accident so I was able to get it so I
was like denied oh man oh yeah like so
how was it and you know and how did you
come about doing it or whatever do you
want to talk yeah I mean I know it's a
little weird for some people to see me
without glasses but I've been wearing
them for you know God since
third grade and you know I don't know
just for a long time and I just got kind
of got did we're not having them all how
long did it take for you to adjust not
reaching for your glasses when you woke
up oh I still have Phantom glasses you
know I mean
yeah uh so that I still have that a
little bit it's going away uh little by
little but
um just having this piece of plastic on
my face just got tired some I started
getting like on the Node like here you
just get these bruises and stuff like
that when I'm doing a voiceover
sometimes like I'm wearing headphones
and then the the plastic of the glasses
rub against the headphones and it makes
a noise and some I've lost a take or two
because I like moved my head a little
bit and it like the rubbing Maiden noise
oh yeah and so like I start to like be
like okay this is starting to become
really inconvenient and then with
performance capture you can't wear
glasses
um and then when I I can use contacts
but I just don't like putting them on
and taking them off and even when I have
them on they can get irritating so I was
at a point where I'm like I am tired of
now not being able to just see naturally
and so a couple weeks ago yeah I set up
an appointment to have my eyes checked
to see if I'm eligible for uh for for uh
Lasik unfortunately I'm at a point where
I I they could perform that particular
surgery on me I know there are other
forms of like uh uh optic Corrections
that's not just Lasik it's like there's
other stuff out there so maybe there are
options for you out there but
specifically Lasik uh yeah I I once they
said they gave me the go ahead I'm like
give me the quickest like the sooner the
better I just kind of want to get this
over with
and yeah a couple weeks ago I went in
they uh it was like a 10 minute long at
most surgery it's very quick yeah yeah
you just go in they put a machine over
your one of your eyes you have to like
focus on something yeah and not move uh
but it really takes like you know 30
seconds per eye once it's set up
um and once yeah it's just they put the
machine down and you see some laser
stuff happening
um they do like peel like the top layer
of your eye off a little bit like that
and so that's when your vision gets
completely blurry and you pretty much
can't see anything so that that moment
can be a little disoriented but it's
scary like oh God did they just make me
blind yeah exactly I'm gonna be the
percentage that messes up I know but oh
God no but that that goes by pretty
quickly they put the machine on you see
some like red lights and stuff and
they're like all right we're done they
put the layer back on and they do it on
your other eye
um now the it was my eyes were very
sensitive to light after the surgery so
I literally cannot even opened my eyes
without it hurting so I had to like go
like this you know
um and I had to wear these like plastic
sunglasses and
um the wrap-arounds yeah the wraparounds
yes right right um but then I took a
like a nap when I got home it was like a
five hour nap and as soon as I opened my
eyes everything was a lot clearer now
for me for some people immediately you
can see 2020 or whatever for me my right
eye took like a week to go from 20 30 to
2020. but now everything's everything's
A-Okay I can see everything just fine
and it is like you
you don't realize all the quality of
life improvements that Lasik gives you
without having to you know wear glasses
all day until you start just doing
activities that you're like oh my God
once upon a time that was kind of
annoying because of glasses now I don't
even have to worry about it
um like I remember just the other day I
picked off some sunglasses off a rack
and I'm like I couldn't do that before
you know I mean
um or or you know using VR everything's
so much
yeah I don't have to worry about
anything anymore I like taking off my
glasses or putting on my contacts good
point it's just uh he was like why did I
do this soon exactly just straight up no
it's worth it uh for me it's worked out
that's what I thought it was a good
question to ask because you know we had
an eye doctor on before yeah and um we
talked about the various things and you
know Cog and uh myself you know have a
little bit of eye issue so you know I
think those are absolutely and it was
great to see you that you got it done
and I'm telling you like at first it was
unrecognizable because I'm like I said
Cog is trying to fool me
is extremely late to the Yakuza series
my first entry is literally like a
dragon right so Ichiban is my guy he's
awesome that's my dude right so you know
obviously I played the game coming from
a Brand New Perspective and curio makes
it appearance so clearly I knew this is
somebody iconic this is the iconic guy
and I'm not gonna spoil it for for those
who played it you know what I mean there
is an appearance of kill you in in like
a dragon so for me Ichiban is like The
Lovable goof with the heart of gold
right he's he Everyone likes him he's
got Dom but he's got what is it adachi
side psycho and now it's played and this
is rare and Attica I appreciate this
normally I don't do English dub in these
type of games I normally don't but I
love this is my man's name kaiji Tang
Taija Tang yes I think he is amazing and
he did such an important like I fell in
love with this character so my question
for you is what's it like for cure you
ask you to play work with Ichiban and
then what's it like for yany to work
with Kaiju well so one of the things
that's that's unfortunate about the vo
realm is more often than not you're
recording by yourself
yeah and like I think with like a dragon
they did say that they managed to find
waste like uh record together and stuff
like that but then covet happened and so
that ended and we had a record by
ourselves but uh more often than not
kaiji records his lines before I do
gotcha and so when there is a scene
where uh akaiji and Kiryu or sorry uh
Ichiban and kiry assure a moment I can
actually they can actually play me what
kaiji did yes and I can respond to that
got it
um and so like like there's that scene
of the the there's that scene that that
that's already out in Japanese of like
the the Virgin allegations
yeah because I don't know if you're the
guy each of us I don't know if you're
the guy I should be going to for
relationship with my exactly because he
teaches proposed to psycho psycho yeah
exactly yeah that scene was a lot of fun
to do hearing uh kaiji's performance and
I could like respond to him and stuff
like that and so it just made things a
little more uh natural and dynamic to be
able to like respond off of something at
least uh kaiji though he had the harder
task because my performance wasn't done
by then and so he had to just record by
himself but he does have we do have the
Japanese references for the cutscene so
we can use that as a guide to find the
proper emotions and performance for for
those scenes and
um yeah no I was gonna say it obviously
you can't well I won't get you in
trouble you're gonna say so um obviously
like a dragon Gaiden right and and you
know Cario the man who raised his name
fakes his own death you know obviously
you cannot spoil but from a narrative
perspective what excites you most about
this story
it's just uh
just finding out what curie's been up to
you know he's such an enigma that uh to
be able to bridge that gap between six
where I mean that the ending of that was
pretty dramatic and he yeah that's quite
a way to go out you know and and to live
a life of isolation like that to make
that the the sacrifice of like death is
a relief compared to the torture of of
having to isolate yourself from the
people that you love and and just just
having to keep them at arm's length and
have them believe that you know that you
don't exist you know I mean like it's
it's a cursed existence yes and and so
and you see it in Kiryu you know there's
that first trailer for Gaiden that came
out where the monks like you still
haven't
um absolved yourself of all of your uh
like personal wishes like family and
stuff like that and you can see just the
the
the the sadness and curious eyes just
the how dead he feels inside you know
and so the exploration of of that and
seeing kiru like come back in Aid and
stuff like that and seeing that Arc it
just really excites me to see like how
you come back from such a
a cursed and and and miserable existence
uh just having to go into hiding to that
level just because
you know because Kyrie's not a bad
person he just he's just involved in a
really dark world and that curses
everything he touches you know karuka
she was going to have that career as a
pop star right in five but she gave that
up because she's like I love kirio and I
know that my association with him will
uh just not allow me to be a pop star in
between being a pop star and being with
Kiri I'd rather be with Kiryu and how
beautiful and touching was that and yet
in six we learned that there were
consequences to that where now that
people know she's involved with the
Yakuza the kids you know if they want to
get a scholarship they'll be like well
they're associated with hadoco who's
associated with the Yakuza so we don't
know if you know these kids have a few
so that ripple effect and so Kitty knew
that like I have to get out of here and
it's like a sacrifice that's very uh
torturous for him and so no bro I'm very
curious to see like yeah how all that
plays out you know super dope getting
towards the end and um this is so
heartwarmingly here it is you know I
love your humility through this whole
process I love you know how you
inspiring actually people to get into
voice acting in in the Indian industry
and stuff like that so this is super
dope you're living you're living your
dream you know what I mean honestly
that's the thing I like there's no
like the hate is is very loud but it's
not anywhere close to the majority of
the feedback that I've gotten and
it nowhere comes close to overtaking the
gratitude that I feel yes for the
position that I'm in you know I mean
like why would I be focusing on all that
when I'm living my best life like
there's
I'm so grateful I'm so honored and
privileged to be in this position and so
for me it's just about living it up and
embracing this moment and just just
having fun doing my best and uh yeah I I
think uh it's it's it's gonna be it's
gonna be something you're right you
worry about a AI try to take your role
in the future
this is why we're striking you know yeah
yeah
right now it's a huge thing without the
writers and the actors are together in
this uh movement uh going forward
because uh I told people a long time ago
that is a very dangerous AI situation
where it's going to steal a lot of jobs
and y'all have to you know be
preventative but that's just one aspect
of the strike the other aspect of the
strike is the streaming stuff that 100
people need to be paid for their Wares
before syndication was a thing and y'all
will get paid for syndication but the uh
streaming is bypassing syndication and
uh the streaming is in perpetuity but
how do you get paid from these different
aspects so I I see the fight and I stand
with you I'm not a voice actor I'm not a
writer but I stand with you guys in that
because I believe that for every work
that you do you should be paid for
absolutely it's got to the point where
from like on Tick Tock or YouTube shorts
It's someone's like voicing
like against it I'm like well you got to
go on the block list
it's important
um I'm sorry yeah but I I genuinely
don't think there is a replacement for
human actors because a lot of the best
scenes out there in film or in gaming or
whatever there's stuff that was just
like ad-lib off of instinct off of the
Instinct of that actor their life
experiences and their knowledge of this
character and uh like there's that I
don't know if you uh God what's the it
was a Django Unchained where the
Leonardo DiCaprio like he like smashes a
cup with his hand and it started
bleeding oh yeah that was like he cut
himself for real yeah he noticed his
blood on the actor's face like he did a
whole thing with that it's like a I
can't come up with that you know what
I'm saying like acting is so human and
so instinctual that AI can only be can
perform off of the framework off of
somebody and and what they input but
they don't even know what they want
until the actor gives it to them or
gives the performance to them and they
come up with something that the director
didn't even think of yes
exactly AI can't do that they're not
human good point and so they can be used
as Tools in some ways and whatever but
human actors will always have just that
authenticity yes and that instinct to
take that performance to the next level
uh to a level that not even the casting
directors or the the director's proper
new the character could go and so I'm
not worried but contracts have to be set
in place
making sure we are not signing anything
that says yeah take my voice and use it
exactly and then all of a sudden with
shopkeepers some random NPCs
to the point where it's like why do
these these corporations legitly feel
like someone would ever sign that
agreement like yeah yeah
so look I'm just giving us way more time
than I've asked for he's been a soldier
your man messed up the the time he's
supposed to be here he still came what a
performance what a professional yeah so
the last question we this is tradition
that we asked forever before we had them
out is with these top five video games
or franchises of all time no pressure oh
God uh let's see I mean
Zelda I think is my number one I know a
lot of people expect Metal Gear it
always it switches around man I don't
know they're both very special games for
me but there's something about the the
adventure and Ocarina of Time in the
sense of open world and like there was
just nothing like it at the time that
that's what really made me go oh video
games are like this is no not a toy
anymore these are experiences you know I
mean and the metal gear solid with you
know the performances and the Cinematic
nature of it uh I yeah I just couldn't
pull myself away from it
um
God I want to say
one of the frontsoft games is up there
uh golden ring or seki or sekiro um
Elden ring so whatever Ocarina of Time
was to my childhood that sense of I
can't believe this game is real and it
exists and it's like it offers me this
much Freedom Alden ring was to my
adulthood I could not believe the sheer
amount of content in this game but
security also has a special place I'd
say like both of those are in third
place um uh but with Elden ring is just
it really blew my mind with the sheer
amount of content
um God and this is not official list
let's see I want to say
um last of us I'm gonna put up there
because it's the thing that made me want
to become a voice actor
when I saw Troy Baker's performance
holding his daughter in his arms and
just and just the impact that that had
on me I'm like I want to do that like
that's what I want to do I've done
theater and it's like when video games
can evoke something like this so now
that we're at this level I hope that one
day I can participate in a project like
that have that much of an emotional
impact
um
one more number five
um impacted you whatever way had an
emotional impact impacted me in whatever
way uh God it's just anytime I'm put on
the spotlight that's when like I'm just
gonna have a list and then my brain's
like no you don't
um
God I want to say
Elder Scrolls for Oblivion oh oblivious
let's go that was the first dangerous
game I ever played yeah yeah and yeah
yeah but but it was mainly just I mean
you could really go anywhere and do
whatever and tackle the story in any way
shape or form do all these side quests
and there was just so much to do and
this expansive fantasy setting that I I
that's what made me fall in love with
Bethesda and I still think very fondly
of that
um
that was amazing I'm glad you gave
Oblivion his flowers he doesn't I know
Skyrim is Skyrim for sure and shout out
to your videos amazing but um yeah
Oblivion the only reason Oblivion
doesn't get more props in Skyrim is
because of Technology differences at the
time for sure but for sure the Oblivion
which was dope is the jump from like The
Mooring or whatever to that and then
having all those systems and and you
just saw the complexity of Bethesda game
object permanence and you know bodies
and the justice system the faction it
was just so all the mods oh the mods
were crazy yeah and the last one we do
before we get you out of here favorite
console of all time and why
oh God that's you can only pick one
taking back hard man putting you on the
island kids man you want me to pick you
gotta pick from your children you gotta
have a favorite child I think I know
what child is I think I know which one
it is too but I'm curious to see you can
only pick one
I think I know okay here's the thing so
there's a big gap of consoles where you
know I wasn't able to own like a PS4 on
a PS2 so there's some consoles that I
haven't owned so of the ones that I have
owned I want to say that
[Music]
for sure it's more about just the the
memory the impacts that the console had
on me obviously they're amazing games on
all these other consoles that we're
seeing today but N64 was my first foray
into like 3D gaming on consoles it's
what introduced me to Zelda and Super
Smash Brothers and all these games that
uh really shaped my love for gaming you
know and it's it's
a big part of why I'm here today
covering games it's why my love for
gaming has just continued to transcend
and so I Gotta Give N64 a big Shadow
because it's so sort of in many ways My
Ground Zero for for how much I fell in
love with video games yeah this was an
absolute pleasure thank you for taking
it out of your day the legendary young
yeah my man bro I mean your journey
you're one of us so to me it's so
inspiring to see your elevation and to
see now you're doing your dream job
probably watching it for years I've been
hearing you know the same for years and
I love your news content I love that
you're still doing it and you know keep
on with your journey let the people know
quickly like where can they find you
what they think for those for those
living under a rock who don't sure
sure.com
yes where I like kind of just share just
random thoughts and whatnot if you want
to watch just my gaming news content
it's youtube.com yeah if you want to
check out my video stuff yang dot com I
have my resume my reels if you are
interested in hiring me for anything or
I just are curious about what I've done
um and yeah those are the the big ones
I'd say yeah no doubt Lord addict outros
for uh Lord young yeah before you heads
out
yeah what's funny is I was in LA when a
cog uh met you and uh I stayed home and
they I stayed at the hotel ate Five
Burgers and played I was like shout outs
I was like that Network he was like yeah
I I just told him like that's all you
I'm gonna sit here eat these Five Guys
because I just don't like the club scene
at all like anything remotely close to
it was like outside but it's cool
so he comes back to the hotel he's like
yo I met y'all yeah I was like cool I
was like how'd that go he's like I think
we might actually get him on IOP you
know
like I I'm not gonna interrupt you added
because you cook him I knew you was a
real one because sometimes I think me
and you share this I go off energy
because let's be honest you know we know
how this thing goes and people Network
oh yeah I got it I'll do it I'll see you
soon yeah the Hollywood and listen I
don't even get mad at it to me I don't
get mad at it but like I knew I feel
like yo I like it I I think if I have it
you know I was like and he was a man of
his word like a true curio fashion
he followed through like so I was like
yo I felt confident I was like yo I
think it's gonna happen salute to you
for that because you didn't know me you
didn't know my platform and and
obviously our platform excuse me and it
was just so cool for you to take the
time out but finish the story I'm glad
you said that you said it oh no no it
was an absolute pleasure I mean I
remember meeting you in person and just
the energy you gave off I'm like yeah no
we we can we can hang I want to get to
know this dude yeah and then the crew so
no yeah this was such a pleasure and uh
you asked some great questions we had
some really fun conversations and uh
yeah I I excited for the future of this
podcast and everything that it has to
offer man uh you love you have like a
really just wonderful personality that
feels the room with positivity and so
you know all of you I think just make a
really great crew and uh I think yeah
there's a bright future ahead for all of
you call cog's the upper and on the
downer he's the balance for the force
he's the best King I'm sorry please I
was gonna say you know what I appreciate
about you man is like there's a lot of
people out there that they have personas
that's so far because everyone ex you
know especially like me We who we are we
just amped up a little bit for the part
okay but when you come across people
that their Persona isn't who they are
it's a completely different person
that's when you go back to the hotel and
you guys exchange and they never show
back up because that's not who they you
saw a different side of them that wasn't
them but what I preach about you is what
you see is what you get oh 100. I'm glad
I'm glad yeah no I just I just try to be
me you know it's when you do that's a
very rare quality yeah a lot of people I
yeah I just you know I I just um
when you make content and stuff you just
want an authentic connection with people
so I don't try to put on anything you
know it's just that's who I am and when
I'm talking to folks yeah I just uh I
just don't want to be ashamed of who I
am you know I just this is me and take
it or leave it you know it is what it is
but my my number one like requirement
when it comes to like people in the
gaming industry in general now like
doesn't matter if you cover if you're in
is like the passion I gotta feel that
passion for the industry and you know I
definitely felt that with you no doubt
Lord King outros for uh Lord young yeah
before you head out well it sucks that I
didn't get a chance to to go to La but
it was you know he would have been there
with God
thank you IPS is crazy thank you it is
so you know I I would have been there
and then when Cog you know hit us back
and was like well you know because we
just texting back and forth and he was
like yo I met young and um I'm not gonna
lie uh I was watching your content way
before right and and I'm like wow man I
like this stuff and to to hear that you
had that Gap in your history as far as
video games go
um and to come back to it and and to
hold on to that passion you would have
made a terrible lawyer right
and I'm glad I appreciate that yeah
if you would have stood there could you
have passion in someplace else right and
you gave us yourself you was a gentleman
even though you used the opportunity to
use a gentleman to allow your your
mother and your father to concentrate on
your brother who had clear aspirations
where he wanted to go and he was in
school and he was like let me take that
step back and let me pursue this and you
you did it at your hardest like Paul was
paying for the dude
so but
um I I love the fact that you you you
hone your craft in your acting and this
was what you wanted to do this was your
ultimate goal but you also had a passion
here that you cultivated and you took
that and and I love people accelerating
at their passion and you move from a
position of strength you said at this
time I can't do this right now but I'm
going to do this when this is beneficial
and I'm at a stronger point because you
did one day to day and I want everybody
to you know look at this uh this example
he gave you the website he gave you
what's your tools facts and he did not
gate keep anything he didn't say you
know easily you said uh your Mentor
could have easily didn't put it for free
um
the fact that you gave those Jewels it
was something that was taught to you and
it was something that uh the gentleman
in you is there and thank you so much
for being a gentleman today with your
time and being prompt and being
professional and I'm telling you you're
going to go so far I cannot wait to see
The Last of Us three with you starring
he could have been Last of Us three
already okay you you speak it into
existence
we gotta see you in that future Final
Fantasy 7 remake of a remake of a remake
I take Last of Us three We're Young okay
well I appreciate the kind words uh but
yeah no you know I know what it's like
to be on the other side of being like of
you know voice acting seems like such a
distant dream when you think about it
it's such a cool job and you're like
will I ever be chosen to be a part of
this this this group and so I I know
what it's like to want something that
feels so far away and like so
unattainable but it is attainable uh you
just really have to work at it and I'm
all about chasing your dreams I think
you have to have that burning passion
but you have to do it strategically as
well you have to know the timing of
things and when to push and pull and you
got to know yourself a lot as well you
got to be uh not self-dec deprecating
but like self like introspective you
have to like know where you're at talent
wise and you know are you ready and
that's hard to like really know and
figure out but uh when you've sometimes
you just feel it and you know when you
know you know right and so like trust
your heart trust your instincts trust
your passion and uh know that it is
attainable and be smart about it but go
for it uh because
you will regret it if that that's that
was my thing I was like if I don't go I
was terrified to move out here by myself
of course but I just knew that I'd
regret it for the rest of my life that I
didn't try and things have been working
out so you know I hope uh salute to you
no absolutely out there go for it
seriously of course no fantastic advice
you know again jumping out your cover so
shooting your shot jumping into a whole
new career moving like there's so much
to it you know love to hear the story of
the journey against salute you we're
looking forward to you like a dragon
guide in right and then of course in uh
like a dragon infinite wealth of a man
Ichiban be nice to Ichiban please
you disrespected him and drag a little
bit
yeah you said go ahead Bob man y'all yay
enjoy your Sunday the legendary
[Music]
all over yo you stupid I can help out
too I can help out too if you want and
we miss off we missed solved definitely
all right there's a lot man I see all
right do we get Gerald Mack where we at
got it you build it
oh I muted myself so stop interrupting
um
like people be thinking I'd be doing on
a purpose like it's my ADHD no you're
good brother you're good brother you
wait a second
he said yo people think I do it on
purpose now is that other guy behind me
it's him he out of pocket we got to wrap
them up all right I'm young he's so glad
to see my favorite content creators
together I don't know if I read that but
we're reading it read it twice uh
homeless bird with a five dollar Super
Chat love uh to the Lords I'm so excited
for the next Yakuza game especially
after recently beating zero and judgment
congratulations on Landing the role yeah
he killed that
uh member chat 35 months from drunken
ninja good Sunday Lords glad uh young
getting his flowers been watching him
for years at what a better place to get
him for the IOP two dollars from Max
City in does Yong have a yeah I still
have his yellow chair Messi
yeah I have no clue five dollars for
chat uh from cure Kieran seven one seven
hey King who you got spin uh Spencer uh
Crawford well what I can tell you is uh
tune in next Saturday uh at uh on
Twitter live and um if y'all do not uh
start tipping y'all ain't gonna see the
fight I'll be watching the fight y'all
be looking at me watching the fight so I
mean I spent 50 bucks yesterday and uh
IOP got nothing to do with Twitter live
so uh yeah see you there the
monetization button is at the top
from no bunting for holding it down on
that SS
xdd pod
oh you talk about the crossover I'm a
fan of Colin but those weird long-winded
explanations for what and consumer
choice so bad absolutely
watching the show getting different
opinions on five dollars subscribe from
Silent Cypher good morning yongi do you
have tips and tricks to get into the
voice video voice acting uh voice side
of the voiceover side of the industry
working on my Fiverr demo at the moment
keep up the good work he actually gave a
lot he gave a lot of gems he gave a
website he gave a lot of gems on that
hopefully you got that that answered as
well five dollar subscribe from zip
Davis all right if you sleep on your
stomach with the door open the beefy
Ferry will up here and leave some
Advanced GG under your pillow
that's what that's the other beat hey
hey hey hey hey
back to you addict
[Laughter]
I love today's conversation and guests
so far uh learning loads about voice
acting industry keep bringing more
guests like this
we'd love to if we knew more voice
actors uh two dollar Super Chat from
Robert kellett
I'm gonna voice Sonic next question mark
Maybe
uh kudos to yongi explaining how it's
the expression that make voice acting
special reminds me of Kevin David doing
the Arbiter subtal of a powerful yeah
great great choice find out some chat
from Homeless Bird I love you as I have
no clue we ain't even trying that and
the Crystal flies the final shutdown had
me had me laughing crying and just
having a blast it felt like the cast had
fun shirakaba in the kaito whatever five
dollars from Harvey shiny hope
everything is okay with solved it was
nice catching up with you in La yeah uh
young congrats on the Cairo roll now if
you could get caught
zero through six because he knows
everyone I admit it I listen I admitted
to the bed I was a fraud I started
nothing I started on like a dragon and
then I'm now I'm going back no I'm not
playing anything inside turn base
battle pass and I'm finishing it this
week I feel like that but salute and
then um infinite infinite wealth with uh
both of them should be turn based with
hopefully yeah
but most likely um him as a party member
with the team one that'd be dope
oh that would be pretty good yeah uh
what happened no no it's some stuff that
I put in the chat that I need y'all to
look at and um graphic God is like uh I
think they might be busy right now okay
right now okay okay ten dollars from uh
c-dub813305 is he giving this is
Nintendo switch code or something yeah
cause the series is my top three series
of all time I just hope Microsoft
doesn't buy Sega and ruin it because we
know we know how they do five Jokes
Aside great show so far and great guests
absolutely salute two dollar super truck
from uh Robert kellett uh Yonge being
the next MC for The Last of Us Part
three uh maybe five dollar Super Chat
from Ellis uh I think that's a Canadian
supertrad actually thank you for yange
IOP the place to be great guest as
always and two dollars for Robert yellow
it's saying Cog voice Captain beef in
the next Final Fantasy let's see if
that's all though
[Music]
yeah that's all that's all right no
doubt don't doubt oh and Cedric H just
gifted 20 IOP members chats uh yeah I'm
not reading all those people you guys uh
oh Central
Cedric and thank him because that is a
lot of people
I expect some at cedrics and thanking
him for that yeah he just he blessed
y'all in the room right now that's
what's up Salute Cedric age he's been
rocking with us for a long time salute
to that as super important what we're
gonna do is get the poll uh last week's
poll results are in and the people have
spoken
um with the path now clear for Xbox to
acquire Activision Blizzard King and
Xbox being on record to look into more
mergers and Acquisitions what do you
think Xbox next move should be the
winner this was a super close poll
four-way poll all the way around 33
was buy smaller Studios and avoid
regulatory scrutiny so this was really
close they pulled that out coming in
that second place was at 25 of the vote
was uh get a publisher who could be
self-sustainable and continue to feed
the Game Pass model group in third place
razor close 22 was I don't care Xbox
invested in themselves and we held the
damn line and in last place at 19 of the
vote was still all closed ABK and
Bethesda are enough manage what you
currently have more official in groups
so King the people want smaller Studios
they don't want another publisher so
where do you sit with that those are the
mustard heart dudes
like I don't care if you if you got a
mustard heart and you scared a
regulatory process it was it was 18
months King and then my heart can't take
it
I don't know how to hold the line oh man
get out of here man nobody thinking
small with you get out of here big so
all you little mustard dudes go sit in
the corner and let us handle the
business and y'all can come out and act
like y'all was with us when we was doing
it they scared the publisher got you
scared we we need to get a bunch of
little things King so we don't upset
nobody walk around the house like a
little mouse like the rats you are oh
that's not us brother we walking around
like rhinoceros knocking things over
that sound like General talk that sounds
like General talk you know because I'm
just tired of these muster heart dudes
okay so monster heart is a mustard seed
is so small Mustard Seed is so small and
that's the size of your heart your heart
is not in it bro like you not built for
this why don't you just go sit down and
go play retro games
a game that has been established go get
a console that is dead you gotta worry
about it I love it though but the red is
good though the red is hilarious because
you know what they want you to be they
want you to be weak like them we want
company
I'm not hanging out with you weak dudes
keep that away from me do not infect me
oh man oh frail and stuff go drink a
protein shake oh I'll get shave of the
road damn y'all better follow Cog and go
get beefy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah I'm not beefy at all he's got these
down beefy dudes
oh man take a lean beef
screw the regulations screw in any Eddie
okay I see what we do let's see what we
do but anyway we're gonna move on now
actually we got a bunch of patreon
questions
shout out to snail killer hello Sith
Lords after Bobby's recent comments
about being involved as much as little
as needed do you think they cast him
into Exile quickly so I guess Bobby
after the thing they said P.S Lord King
let me know if you want that Spider-Man
no Spider-Man plates for your PS5 I'll
Super Chat you the money you good with
that okay
um what you can do is you can Twitter me
the money
yeah you can go to Twitter hit the
monetization
um yeah I want the place definitely I'm
gonna get the plates and yet Bobby is
going to the shadow realm we all knew
Bobby
was going to the shadow room with the
stuff that he was a part of the whole
part they paying 68 billion dollars to
put him into the show
you want somebody gone did you pay 68
billion again oh man the board agreed
they was doing fine it was like you know
we really don't like Bobby we got to
take this dance
get out of here everybody but yeah uh
yeah it's a monetization button on my
Twitter all right no doubt make sure you
hit that that's how you help them with
it hit the button if you want to get me
wings
wigs for the fight stand up adding your
comments on Bobby think they cast them
away too quickly I think there'll be a
transitional period I think he'll be
around for probably six months and then
he'll be yeah oh the horns sound much
quieter I appreciate it
um um jarvar jar of our Indie I think I
pronounce the correct that's my men when
oh that's gonna run for 20 members yeah
but it's no it's actually low it's
actually super quiet can't hear it Chad
should I turn that down more because I'm
sure like hearing that 20 times yeah
well people who are generous in the room
today there's yeah it's quiet when the
ABK deal is over Xbox will become a
Powerhouse of Studios do you think Xbox
will then buy fewer AAA games into Game
Pass and more double A oh it's not like
Monster High kids and boy and Indies
since they will be putting out enough
Triple A game actually no it's not most
of our since they will be putting out
enough AAA games
into Game Pass themselves so he's
basically saying
um to buy so basically because they got
you know ABK on stuff the Triple A stuff
is going to be feeding the Game Pass
right automatically so do you think they
need to buy like the third parties
remember how they give a third party a
bag like a lot
do you think that that would they will
buy less of that why did they have this
what I think is
um Game Pass is gonna be a breeding
ground for trying like your new IP that
is unproven that you want to get
multiple eyes on uh like it's turned
into so I think it'll be less going to
get those established titles like you
say uh um like a Capcom Resident Evil
whatever
you don't need to do that because your
your development houses can produce
enough games to put inside Game Pass
so this is not must the heart uh talk
this is business talk
um and from a business perspective it uh
behooves like a Capcom from using an
unproven IP uh and setting it out on its
own in the wild instead of just putting
it on Game Pass so yeah I think you see
a lot more lesser known titles going to
Game Pass uh new titles that can get
that start there and you know and
flourish their opposed to AAA titles
that is already established that does
have a fan base and can sell someplace
else not fair enough attic do you think
that uh they'll slow down on giving AAA
companies the big uh bag for Game Pass
now that they have
um their own or they still wouldn't do
the same thing
I think once they have an established
party uh line I I think they'll pretty
much halt that to nothing I think
they'll do it occasionally with stuff
like that makes sense like you know
uh the the show I think stuff like that
will happen you know I think they'll
still do Indies but as far as like AAA I
I think you'll see almost none of that
like they slow up because what's the
point of building your own portfolio if
you're still gonna rely on other
people's stuff I still think they're
gonna do it but not it's just you'll
you'll see maybe one a year if that not
fair enough fair enough and then we got
the daring one with the recent releases
of Final Fantasy 16 and both Zelda games
departing from series Roots do you feel
some fans of D series are rightfully
upset about the departures we all know
the reason they didn't put different
titles on those games it's because new
IP is risk but is it worth jeopardizing
the Loyalty of the fan base of the
series in order to get this new thing
out as a fan of Zelda from Lily the
beginning I wouldn't have bought tears
of the Kingdom if it wasn't for my son
and that saddens and angers me as fan of
the series I'm still attic on this one
because this seems very pertinent to him
and his feelings sometimes
I mean at the end of the day that's what
you need to do to expand the franchise
and do it uh as long as it's still good
because the games are still fun it's
just they don't feel like they're
predecessors and that's fine to a point
but it's like he said you know uh just
because they're having more success with
these newer titles what did that success
come from it comes from pretty much
spitting in the face of all your older
fans like that like literally was in the
trenches with you for years to build
where it was I like what
what Yakuza does Yakuza saw found a lot
of success with turn base with like a
dragon and they didn't just make
everything turn base they're like look
you get this franchise for your turn
base because we realized that a lot of
our newer audiences like this type of
gameplay and we're still gonna do our
traditional game play because we know
that's what our fans like they just say
oh we we we hit we hit a gold mine with
breath of the wild we don't care what
the other people want we're doing that
again like yeah I think
it's one of those things where it's like
do you care more about the franchise
going forward or do you care more about
how you want to play the franchise it's
not fair enough fair enough uh King your
thoughts on that sir please repeat the
question now you're good just as far as
Final Fantasy 16 and Zelda tears of the
Kingdom some people feel it's departing
from this series roots and um do you
think that um it's risky for them you
know to kind of depart and put it you
know how like they used still the same
name Final Fantasy and Zelda is it risky
for them you know to to try to put a new
IP completely and go away from the risk
from their room okay well um Final
Fantasy doesn't feel like Final Fantasy
to me it feels like another title okay
um tearsity Kingdom feels like Zelda to
me because breath of the wild felt like
Zelda to me
um I played Skyward Sword felt like
Zelda to me so um I was already into you
know Ocarina of Time and all these other
games Zelda has always tried his hand at
different things right and they have
been wildly successful in doing so
there's a lot of lesser-known titles in
the Zelda uh franchise that you may not
remember uh because maybe you didn't dip
your toes into that uh so if it's a
specific way that you want Zelda to be
played I believe they have uh mabryd of
uh titles that's available for you same
thing with Final Fantasy
we can't ask for change and then when
they do make change we want the same
I don't want this Final Fantasy I wanted
to to go back to turn base I like turn
base but like addict said there's a
turn-based game being released next week
and if I want to try that then I can
play that but they are trying different
things not to be stagnated they don't
want to make the same game over and over
again right they do want to reach a
different demographic they do want to
see if you like something different
maybe they could do like uh Dragon Quest
and give you the opportunity to play it
in both ways
um it it may happen if y'all are vocal
enough and respectful enough maybe you
could sway them into taking a different
uh thought when doing the next Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy 17 maybe they do
have a turn base and action oriented
maybe that does happen but um no I don't
I think uh sticking to the same formula
and expecting different results it's
it's foolish you know we want that from
Halo but when Halo tries something
different we scream that that's not Halo
you have to stop being that old man on
the lawn and expecting it to stay the
same but want different fair enough I'm
sorry I got it I was gonna say like the
only pushback I would give to that is
you know we've seen franchises keep that
type of style of gameplay and and be mad
successful yeah you know you could argue
that when Final Fantasy started doing
its rapid change and gameplay that's
when the Metacritic started lowering
that you know sure some games sold
better because 15 sold like 5 million
and in like a week but at the end of the
day like that was a game that was hyped
for like 10 years so like I think that's
like more of an outliner than the actual
thing you can use to compare it right
but like you look at like Dragon Quest
they haven't really had a profit and
Metacritic score they've been highly
critically successful commercially
successful Persona 5 is like one of the
a lot of people argue is like one of the
best turn-based games you could play and
it's like a 92 or 93 right and it's like
you haven't had a final fantasy hit
above a 90 since like 10. well no I get
it I mean for me um Final Fantasy
is always subjective in the sense that
to me they've already established that
each one is going to be completely
different from the other one it's not
really going to be you know there's
going to be some tropes from the jrpg
standpoint but I feel like they always
feel like they gonna try to reinvent
something and that's why it's not a
continuous series that leads into
something else but I do feel that the
you know the base has the right to be
upset if they feel it you know went too
far off a jrpg sensibilities but you
know that's on them as far as uh Zelda I
kind of feel the opposite I don't feel
like Zelda went too far away from the
phone I felt like Zelda kind of stayed
in their pocket but they just got more
creative in the same space that was my
only nitpick when I first saw it I mean
when I was like it looked kind of
exactly the same but then when I saw you
obviously the creativity and all the
things you could do in the world
whatever so I get it some some basis the
hardcore bases are not gonna feel
certain things if there's too much of a
departure yeah I just recently played
like Ocarina of the time and Skyward
Sword last year like they're drastically
different like the formulas are not the
same like I would actually say Zelda is
more
it is staying a little bit more to its
core because even though they changed
that and they drastically like didn't
put a lot of time into like the temples
and they don't feel like they're wet as
well done as they used to be like to a
point Zelda the new ones is a little bit
of Zelda uh but what I will say is like
16 is a shell compared to the previous
Final Fantasy it's like it's it's it's
stories better than 15 but 15 was still
a share competitor final fantasies like
there's not even Elemental damage like
like marbles like they they didn't they
don't bad breath has been notorious
since the beginning of Final Fantasy to
give everyone bad uh you know bad
debuffs it gives you blind all this on
16 none of that's existing you know
Elemental damage where you fight like
the fire uh the fire um bombs
you can hit them a fire and it doesn't
it took away the elements the game
doesn't even read it and that that's
final fantasy like those those little
knacks that they've always had in Final
Fantasy is what makes Final Fantasy that
game 16 is an action adventure game with
the Final Fantasy game on it's on on its
title it's it's not a final fantastic a
lot a lot of people agree with you um
I'm just gonna I actually forgot to
answer um Joe Ross question for myself I
didn't answer the first two um I do
think that um they will slow down on the
AAA um Game Pass backs a bit like addict
said I feel like there will be some that
they will but for the most part now that
they got all these Studios in-house they
won't need to pay as much you know
because they'll have so many exclusives
for themselves and then for snail
Killers
um yeah I don't think they cast aside
Bobby quick I think like King said
Bobby's got his bag he gonna be out of
here they know from a public relations
standpoint that probably not the
greatest look to keep him and Bobby's
perfectly fine taking his old golden
pirate shooting dancing off all right
dip that we got two more he did an
interview where he said that he's going
to be around until March of 2020. yeah
he said he'd be willing to stay if they
need him there's going to be a tree we
don't need you Bobby going now go on
Bobby that's this so I got two books we
got to move on because we got two I
don't know what Bobby gonna do other
than snitch
Bobby down with the rat Squad oh man dip
down games and Anime the homies the
world is coming to an end due to reasons
unless you fall without breaking softer
here can come to an agreement on one
console
and like a king's face and the
exclusives that particular console to
play for the rest of your lives so God
help me if you say PC Steve deck or
wrong alley so I'm gonna make this easy
I'm just gonna make this easy I think we
could all fundamentally agree on Xbox I
would assume right yeah
we got Spider-Man for the whole year to
hell with them dudes I would actually
say probably Nintendo switch oh we
definitely not know
I guess we got worlds coming to an end
there we not gonna live
that's fine no he ain't gonna live
because they're going to dip down
all of us have to agree on this this is
I I just there's too much been too too
much inconsistency like if I have to
live off just exclusives and no third
party I just until I see Xbox deliver
more in that vein I can't just sit there
and be like y'all I'm gonna play your
games the rest of my life like when it
comes down to like Nintendo I generally
am more satisfied with Nintendo games
than I am purchase a Nintendo title for
the kingdom and that was and the party
as a standard is we all have to agree
this is not yeah we cannot live unless
you're going to
agreement together the part of the
question is to work he's just trying to
get us to argue no you're trying to get
us to argue we need to get a solution
I'm not gonna how do you like your human
well oh my God this man is willing to
die for all of us all of us die because
we don't pick his choice that is selfish
you're trying to say
it better I'm not willing to pick the
other two pick because I want this one
thing that's what you're saying what are
you
mad games just coming down the pipe with
these dudes I am not worrying about no
480p system go away no no no no well it
looks like being that he won't agree and
we're gonna eat him no no he won't agree
because I'm not arguing with this all
day so um sovereign
or for just the games because he said he
said um Ono actually was just a console
the console Anderson
okay okay so okay so okay cool we're
fine moving on because I'm not spending
two hours on that
um Brian howdy as the ABC ABK deal
starts to wrap up there's still a tons
of chatter in The Ether about how this
is bad for gaming was Netflix bad for TV
or did it put pressure on cable in
original programming to step up I've
heard the argument that Xbox Studios
won't Foster the proper development of
these Studios and everything they make
will be trash if that's the case what's
stopping the employees of said Studios
from leaving and creating their own
Studio we've seen Vince simpella and
countless others do it it's ridiculous
to assume that everything Xbox creates
moving forward will be a banger but at
the end of the day pressure makes
diamonds I can't see it how the pressure
from this purchase in Game Pass in
general doesn't push the industry
forward and put pressure on PlayStation
and others to create better games and
provide better Services what does this
acquisition and Game Pass as a whole
what ways does this acquisition in Game
Pass as a whole hurt the industry long
term or do you think things get better
there's not a rallying Kai just not a
rallying cry just a conversation I was
having earlier this week and I think the
Lords might shed some light so basically
what how does this acquisition and Game
Pass hurt the industry or do you think
things will get better so let's start
with addict
ah
I don't know let me think go go King let
me think okay so do does this
legitimately push things forward does
this hurt the industry with too much
consolidation you know long term does it
make the industry better of Microsoft
acquired APK oh okay so weak businesses
uh fold in larger businesses you know
consolidate those weak businesses into
the fold so it doesn't hurt the industry
at all um I think Colin and a lot of
other people alluded to the fact that uh
other companies will be formed and they
will take the places of those other
companies that are absent in that void
um
Microsoft purchasing ABK will lend to
Greater competition because it would
force Sony to do things that they
unwittedly want to do they would not
they don't want to give you day and day
inside uh Playstation Plus uh they don't
want to do uh uh AAA titles launching in
PlayStation Plus
so if they see Microsoft Game Pass
gaining and overtaking of course you
must compete you must come out and fight
you must do these things do you know
what uh Spider-Man day one inside the
PlayStation Plus would do for their uh
branding uh for their their ecosystem it
will grow their base you know it will
force people to to uh use the service so
I just feel that competition is
definitely necessary in this space and
the fact that Microsoft is forcing
competition will only lend to Greater
games being made because you want your
services to be seen this is the reason
why you have a game like Spider-Man
looking as great as it does there's a
reason why tears is the kingdom is uh
potentially one of the games of the year
you force competition you force
Excellence you force other companies to
dig deeper there's a reason why Forza is
the the king of the racers you know uh
you force it they'll be without Gran
Turismo there is no Forza so you you
have to understand there's always going
to be something to push competition this
pushes competition to this highest level
okay addict your thoughts on the
industry positively or negatively you
know with the um ABK deal let's say um
hurt the industry or not hurt the
industry long term I guess it just
all just depends on you know how far
does this go does does Microsoft try to
buy like more massive
you know Publishers if they went out and
buy like Ubisoft or an eea like I do
feel like
getting one isn't going to affect the
industry too much but if you start
getting multiple I'm just curious you
know how creative freedom will be done
like I don't know because it's never
been done like stuff like this has never
happened in the industry to this degree
like most time companies will merge but
it's never a console manufacturer buying
them so you know we're kind of in
unchartered territory like I go on at
just what they're doing I see them just
having a Call of Duty Sweatshop to a
degree and I think that's going to
improve a little bit where some of these
devs are going to be able to work on
projects that they actually want to work
on I just don't know what the
replications are going to happen like
long term doing this oh fair enough look
watch this kind of Remains the Same I
feel like um it's better for the
industry long term short term I'm a
consumer first what I care about is what
I could access and what gives me the
better deal is a gaming Game Pass is
unequivocally the best dealing game it's
not even close and then you know the way
I look at it is this again we've said
this this is the third place company in
the gaming space you got 10 cent you got
Sony you got all these people Nintendo
above Xbox this is them getting more
competitive getting more content in that
space which then makes the others you
know more competitive now as far as the
other things people wouldn't talk about
is the access before ABK deal right
there was a lot of people who did not
have Call of Duty Nintendo switch only
streams it wasn't even on so that to me
makes the industry better more Gamers
playing a game that's let's be honest as
a multiplayer live service game that
depends on engagement right if more
players play in Live service online game
that's better for the health of the game
one of the worst things is when a game
hat is great but doesn't have the online
community to support it and then as far
as the the other stuff my thing is I've
always said I said this to Colin we had
a great uh secret symbols crossover of
the finally Duke episode is my thing is
everyone is fearful of consolidation but
no one talks about the alternative when
the acclaims the midways all these kind
companies that we grew up with are out
of business because video games are
expensive and then they get dissolved
that's the part no one talks about and
it's like my thing is I rather you fight
to Live Another Day under someone else's
Banner then you be eradicated from the
history of existence and we don't even
get your games anymore so that's where
I'm at with it and the funny thing is
like people want to talk about oh
Microsoft's in the wrong for going out
and buying these Studios like like
PlayStation has been literally securing
whole Publishers of all their games they
try to do a Bethesda they did with two
of their games trying to go for the
third they do it with Square Enix like
there is no difference the only
difference is one of them owns it and
one of them just has exclusive content
to it it's just like look like at the
end of the day
I look at them both equally but at least
Microsoft is going to invest into the
ecosystem sure could be negative could
be positive we don't know we have to see
Starfield we had to see something
Hellboy too but it's just like these
games have literally being secured off
of an entire platform just because they
want to secure that like Sony might as
well but have box score units like
almost all of their games are either
exclusive to PlayStation or not on Xbox
I don't look at them as the same um
there's a renting uh mentality as the
owning mentality it's it's a difference
you go into the store you're renting a
car you know they're nice leasers but
they gotta go back right
um you going there you finance a car you
purchase a card that's different you own
that so it's it's a different mentality
but it let it goes to the greater uh
idea of it it's the wallet I'm pretty
sure if Sony had the money of Microsoft
they would have purchased ABK years ago
okay
nothing years ago so it's just what
you're able to purchase and move how you
do we gotta respect how Sony is moving
in the streets with the size of the
purse it's crazy right no I get it and
and that to me is is is part of the game
you know saying and it's just it's the
scale the principle is the same but the
scale is different and we get it like
you said King if another company the
same thing like tension or anything is
in the same position and has the
financial resource to do so you best
believe they will do so there's no
kindness and good of their heart you
know oh we're not owning anything
because no you just don't have the
capital to do it but if you did you'd be
doing the same thing and last thing I'll
say is this whole ownership stuff and
and cons this has been going on in other
Industries on a larger scale before all
this so to me there's nothing illegal
here it's just that some people have an
issue and it's not their favorite
acquiring stuff owning stuff versus
other stuff saying we just got to get to
that part too and see people in the chat
saying I think there's a difference I
didn't say obviously there's a
difference if you own something you
don't I'm saying in terms of practices
if you go out there and you go to a
company like squares you say you know
what I don't want my competition to
having your games I'm about to buy time
to school City on everything and some is
full-blown exclusive right they pretty
much said we'll never get 16. yeah so
it's just like there is nothing
different than that and going to
something like Bethesda in in Activision
saying you know what instead of doing
time exclusive on eBay we're just going
to buy you a company it's basically
um ownership one Fell Swoop versus death
by a Thousand Cuts I'm gonna keep
cutting you exactly by All These Little
Things eventually I'm gonna get you all
the pack all the stuff off your platform
and on our platform it's the same
mentality to better your platform it's
about statements too PlayStation always
gives the illusion the next Square you
this game might show up on Xbox
Microsoft shows up and says we buy
Bethesda and we say in their games are
ours it is what it is I have no problem
with it at the end of the day that's the
game all right we got to move on so this
is
addicts topics so we got um let me set
you up are you good you can set me up
all right so we got Xbox game pass core
coming this September it looks like gold
is becoming Game Pass core starting
September 14th with a new selection of
games going into Game Pass core it's the
evolution of Xbox Live Gold Coral will
give players access to Advanced
multiplayer and a collection of over 25
games to play
um with exclusive member deals offering
9.99 per month or 60 per year so they
list all the titles and then they go
through the plans and there's obviously
the core plan at 9.99 there's the
console playing at 10.99 the PC plan at
9.99 and the ultimate plan which is kind
of like the all-in-one Stop Shop and
then last couple of bullet points
um yeah September 14 Xbox Live Gold
members will automatically become Game
Pass core members with no change in
pricing all right then member deals and
discounts will also be part of Game Pass
core games will go will come to an end
September 1st and then yeah that's
pretty much so Eric I know you had a lot
of thoughts about this a lot of a lot of
discussion
oh you're on last oh okay yeah all right
so um
uh okay your thoughts on Game Pass core
okay um from what I hear it sucks uh
because it takes away uh fundamentally
something that's supposed to be doing
whatever I'm a Game Pass ultimate dude
um this really doesn't affect me but if
you're doing tears you're not supposed
to be taking away something from one
tear uh that's you know like you know
you have something that's a base right
and then the next hair that's up should
have plus more and then a tear higher
than that should have more and that's
how tears work it's not this tear has
that and then this tear costs more but
has less that's kind of crazy this is
what I'm hearing from it I really didn't
pay too much uh mine to this uh because
again I'm a Game Pass ultimate um
subscriber and I've been doing so for a
long period of time
uh I felt that they should have
Consolidated gold a long time ago and I
think they didn't know how to do it uh
to roll it in and if this is your answer
to it
um it's two cantankerous you might have
to scale it back uh to get a better
consensus on how to roll it out we
already know that um we pay for
multiplayer
right and you know the PC player doesn't
a lot of the console players are upset
that they feel that the PC player is
getting a better deal and paying less
than uh what we are and we're footing
the um holding the line for those guys
for better uh for uh lack of a better
term
and I see that to be true
but I also feel that whenever that
you're at a deficit inside a market you
must use whatever you whatever is
necessary to gain Market penetration all
right
um so if you choose and you see that the
PC is the better option for yourself as
far as uh you know Game Pass goes then
you know by all means go to PC right
there's there's nothing preventing you
from going to get a PC and going to do
that you want equal opportunity on both
sides of the board but you're not
willing to go purchase a PC uh to do so
right you can't screen for equality and
not willing to make that happen if you
don't like your treatment in one spot
abandon that spot and go to the place
where the treatment is better if you
feel that the treatment is better here
abandon here show them that this is not
working out for me but I'll be over here
and you're not willing to do that all
you're willing to do is complain willing
to complain and talk about mistreatment
you can't have it both ways so wait I
just want to you're saying for the The
Game Pass console guy because I think a
bit of the debate is that the Game Pass
console tier doesn't have online
multiplayer right right whereas the
quote-unquote lowers here right right
which is Game Pass core does have it but
without the full so you're saying if
you're a console guy you feel
disrespected for that then you vote with
your wallet and then go just leave just
leave but you won't do it because you're
so used to complaining and going through
the things normally and this is the sad
part of what we have going on now you
guys are not revolutionary
you're just talking to talk right do it
get rid of your Xbox and go to your PC
there's nothing stopping to you go get a
rug right go get game pass over there
you're not paying for uh uh multiplayer
over there and then you have all those
games right but you won't do it you'll
just talk about it because you want to
get into those spaces or you want to get
on the Twitter feed and you want to rant
and you want to Rave and you want
somebody else to do it for you you want
somebody else to push the uh the
narrative for you but what you're going
to say is King we all should be equal
that's not how it happens over here is a
closed ecosystem and they can control
this they can't control that over on PC
so what they have to do on PC if they
have to get in where they fit in so if
it's going to be a better deal over
there because people look at Steam and
be like the steam is cracking what makes
me think I might need your your game
pass ultimate or you won't need it so
you have to show that deal you have to
show the diversity over there so I
understand what's going on over there I
don't want a game on my PC even though I
have ultimate I have the option to do so
but now that I have my Rog the ability
to do so let's makes it more versatile
that's the versatility that I have with
ultimate so I'm not looking at them
bottom tiers but if you are looking at
those bottom tiers and you feel that
you're being treated unequally I will
tell you to abandon there and go to
where you feel that you're treated best
because this is your dollar right so
stop stop getting smacked in the face
stop it now take your Xbox down to
GameStop or or put it on yeah
and sell it or trade it to somebody for
a PC and have a wonderful life playing
on PC and don't complain that's it but
I'm not gonna listen to you complaining
about you being treated wrong because
you're not being treated wrong you like
it you'll stay there you don't like it
you'll leave all right all right I'll
jump in because I had to go and last
um this one I'll be honest I heard about
it for a little bit and I was surprised
that it got as much backlash as it did
but my mentality is different and look I
don't want to be taking part I want to
be disrespectful to the console guy
because the console guy is like hey you
know this tier is you know less featured
like if you if you put them all next to
each other it looks like a tier system
that's going from lowest to highest but
for me I don't look at it like that
because to me
Game Pass gold
is was always a separate thing Game Pass
goal like forget about all these tears
right it was hey you want to play online
you got to get get you got to get um
XBox Live gold right and we'll give you
these two games per month you know for
free just bonus for the right to play
you as a bonus for paying for our
service right then it was Game Pass came
out right yo all these first party games
so to me the user had to say hey I'm on
go I play online right and I want this
game passing I'm gonna pay for gold and
I'm gonna pay for game pack you're
paying two things yeah for the right to
do what you want to do now if you want
to get into the philosophical aspect of
should people be paying for online I I
won't fight you I won't fight you that
is a completely separate thing the way I
look at it is that Xbox let's be this is
where the hustle and it's all full
because it's our fault because when Xbox
Live debuted in 2001 or whatever it
debuted right we said oh wow that is so
cool we could put a broadband connection
in the back and we can talk to our
friends I'm willing to pay for that I
was an Xbox Live Alpha tester I was like
this is great king is home addict is
home solve is at his house off I pay
this address
bro we fell for the banana in the town
pipe early so they got all lists of
revenue for all of these years of dude
paying for this right so this is how I
look at this is not a corporate car they
are not going to be like out of the
kindness of our hearts we are going to
stop letting you pay because you know PC
is over there hey now we're gonna lose
all this this check that's been coming
for impetus we're gonna say no check for
the good of the people we're gonna give
you this it's not how it works so it's
either two options here because I think
I know where addict's going right to
solve addicts problems I know what I
think I know where Alex going in but
he'll explain when it says to her is
that addicts like bro when you look at
this this is less value if I'm a core
dude right and I try to go up to um
console right I'm getting less features
right the way they look at it is they
want you an ultimate yeah let's just be
real let's just call it let's just
corporations Go corporate they want you
or here's the real deal here's the real
deal
may agree with me I don't know let's be
real dated when Game Pass started to
cook
they like that Xbox Live Gold guy still
messing around out here whatever the
percentage of the power let's just say
it was seven I'm making up numbers Xbox
I don't know let's just say with 70 of
these dudes who just saw gold who pick
up Call of Duty and batted in 2K every
year that's it they just won't play all
out right right so they like nah we
gotta get him into gaypad remember when
they aggressively tried to pull gold
everybody's like oh hell no Xbox they
say right so they like okay Dad we can't
do that they like that right yeah
they're gonna fight that so what they're
gonna do is they gonna say okay
look for the actual if you look at it
from The Gold Guys perspective he is
cooking nothing has changed all that's
changed is his name he went from gold
that's my Live Gold to Xbox Live cool
right to Game Pass call right now he
gets not only ability to play online for
the same but let's be real they'll get
them Xbox Live games will go is dog
water like we knock on them can we be
honest
at one point they were decent less
people
right at one point and Xbox was battling
they just threw a Game Pass Jersey on
that dude you're gonna be Game Pass
right so you're gonna count towards
these numbers that we need that let's be
real this is Game Pass Jersey time
you're gonna win I know you resisted but
you go away this jersey and guess what
nothing gonna change we're going to keep
the price the same and we're gonna give
you this this little little Buffet you
know what I'm saying
you were all this you know what I'm
saying whatever and look at the look at
the titles on this list it's funny like
some of them all right Halo Wars Twitter
Fallout 4 like hellblade one you like
hellblade because you know the two is
coming right you know what I'm saying
then we got like a lot of these games
with sequels Forza Horizon four right
great A lot of these games are great
value and dope games Elder Scrolls
Online all stuff that may be on the
fence and you're going to give them a
variety game but the key is see that's
the key will September come around
hey you see you record dude you were
cool you're a gold dude that got
transformed the car and you like yeah
I'm not I'm not really paying for Game
Pass like I'm here for online but you're
friendless got that Starfield you're
friendless got that force of Motorsport
you're friendless you see all and
they're like yeah but just just for like
a dollar two more you can just go up
there ultimate and you got it all family
this is the hustle this is this is the
is it it's a drug dealers this is a
hustle I'm not even going for it is I
don't think I do at this girl but I know
what they're doing they gotta transform
you into Gamepad and get the numbers up
so that they can get more games to track
more Publishers to the platform that's
that's the part I was about that's what
this is I mean when PlayStation did it
nobody cried right because they get they
gave their joint and they rolled the
PlayStation Now into PlayStation Plus
and it happened I get you but to
addict's point PlayStation
PlayStations to your system is is it's
really a tier system yeah yeah it's real
with Xbox let's be real Xbox has always
been Daniel is gold and paid for Game
Pass right that's what it's been and
let's be super real
Xbox was charging for the free to play
at one point people had to push back how
come it's free to play but I still gotta
have gold and New Freedom right so so
that's what it is so they got rid of
that right that that was two egregious
so they got rid of that so that's what I
think it is I just think that and and
the final point I'll give it to Alex I
know you're gonna go in is
the argument you could say that is pro
Xbox and maybe addict doesn't agree with
it a lot but it at least on Xbox you
could say
hey
I don't care about
online multiplayer right
you get Game Pass console now all I'm
here is for the game I don't care I
don't want to play with others whatever
whatever and then the second one is for
the guy who's the opposite right who
just like look I'm just here for online
I don't really care about I want to buy
my games when they come out I want to
pay my 70 I don't want to do your star
field netflixy thing or whatever you're
doing
I'll be here on the core level so at
least with them they do have the option
to choose which type of guy you own you
can make the argument that you have more
choice of what type of gamer you are but
to addicts point and I feel him I know
he's gonna go and I think I know it's
good is that when you put out the chart
and you see that in the middle and it
looked like you getting a less feature
as a Game Pass console the Optics are
bad and that doesn't sit well with
people they look at the list long term
so the question I have added I'm gonna
give it to them is if they do what I
think you may want which is like yo give
the console Guy online multiplayer I
guess my question is would you be
willing for the overall prices to go up
because then in my opinion they're not
just going to give that away after being
able to hustle for so long on Console
God's plan so I'm curious I want to know
your answer yes I mean the prices
already went up okay Game Pass already
went up a dollar or two yeah so it's
like you you raised it for no value at
that point just just because of you know
cost of inflation or anything my issue
is is just the weird
the way this is structured first off is
only a dollar between regular Game Pass
and Game Pass core and it's just like so
it's like I said on kiss moves uh on
planet Xbox like you know what that that
animal game whatever it was at right now
I don't know what it's called Primal or
something yeah yeah like so you're a
core member and you're just playing this
uh you know Call of Duty with your
friend and you're all right you know
people talking about this oh yo just
upgrade the dollar more you'll be able
to play this game then they download it
then they're getting into it it's like
oh we want five extra dollars if you
want to play online you're like but I
was just playing online like five
minutes
they're gonna be like yo get that
ultimate fire for the five dollars and
it's just like regardless if this is a
hustle or not I'm not gonna just bend
over and say it's okay it's just like at
the end of the day like if they're going
to structure this people say attic it's
it's Games with Gold they just change
the name yeah they changed the name and
made it into a structure system even the
chart is a structure system you don't
have it core it's like it's like the
Elite control I don't have it with me
it's like the elite controller they
named the elite controller part two they
named it core for a reason because it's
the standard Elite controller and you
could buy the extra stuff if you want to
so you can go into the core the core
membership and you get online but you
upgrade and lose online feature like and
to me then that means they're putting
way more value on Ultimate like
shouldn't the fact that you have EA play
on there you have uh you have the cloud
computing on there shouldn't that sell
that more so it's like are they putting
more Spotlight on the online than there
are actually everything else like you
shouldn't sorry I just one question and
I think I can solve your argument
should online be on all the tears then
yes that's what it wants I know that's
what he wants the moment the moment you
popped in see you have the core the only
reason that core has online is because
they can't convert people and lose yeah
if they were able to come because it's
probably illegal to take stuff away from
people and switch you because what
they're doing is they they they're doing
the the switching role they sell
PlayStation do it and then okay let's do
that because PlayStation artificially
bumped up their numbers it's our turn we
doing it now and they can't just take
away an online infrastructure like that
that people because I think legally
because we have it with patreon if we
switch a patreon we take stuff away from
yeah patreon makes you get rid of the
tier facts yep you legally can't take
away something legally you can't do it
so you know what they're gonna do we're
gonna make it a core entry position you
know what we're gonna put in there we're
gonna we're we're gonna and I think this
is the right direction for switching and
getting rid of the uh Games with Gold I
mean getting rid of Xbox Live Gold in
general it's just it's just the it's the
marketing behind it it's like I said
like you're going to be marketing these
high infrastructure
multiplayer game pass games that's not
in the core subscription service and
you're gonna have these people
come have access and let's say that okay
I don't I don't want to pay 60 for the
animal dinosaur game
I'm gonna go back and just play Call of
Duty guess what they already switched up
so when they go to play Call of Duty
with their friends that they just play
30 minutes ago
we want you to backpedal to a one that
you just went for and pays less money
and you want us to either Pace a dollar
less
to to go back to online or we want five
more dollars for you to continue to play
online
it's not the right it's not the right
it's it's not the right movement
it's very predatorial I'm gonna be real
with you they they're deliberately
making something look like more value
but they're taking away the most biggest
thing that's in it but wait hold on it's
not predatorial for the game pass the
Xbox Gold guy the goal if you're just a
gold Guy Xbox Gold that guy is winning
he's getting it all I just want to be
clear on that part I I have no predatory
on the go God because the go guy is the
one that's gonna have to train and
switch up
he never had the option
they're putting you in a situation where
they're thinking you're gonna actually
Captivate they're gonna put something
like this dino game in there and you
feel like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna break
the dollar and I'm gonna play this and
then they hit that okay now not only you
paying the dollar you paying the other
five on top
you can switch back to what you just had
and play Call of Duty
it doesn't make sense I'm gonna give you
horseback If I Was A Game's gold dude
and I wasn't looking at Game Pass anyway
he it ain't lit none of that stuff
mattered to me yeah but it never
happened
you're giving fake scenarios no but it's
not a fake scenario the majority of the
game will go do the majority of the
people on games on Xbox Live gold right
now is a lot of the Casual audience
that's why they never switch because
they'd only want to play 2K
they are setting a a piece of cheese in
front of them putting them over that's
giving that's not predatory they're
giving more value but the thing is
they're setting this cheese and like yo
come over here and play these extra
games but then they go over there
so so they're going over there and this
is not a fake scenario the majority of
these people don't want to play these
games that's why they're putting them in
the court they've been in the Xbox Live
Gold for years right so they're like
okay come and play this dinosaur game or
whatever it's called EXO prime or
something yeah okay I'll give you the
extra dollar and then they're like okay
I'm not paying 60 for that I I don't
want to do that I'm gonna go back and
play what I was playing so then they're
like okay you gave us the extra dollar
and now the game that you actually play
on our Xbox we want an extra five or you
want to have to go back to the previous
tier you was in or you can't even play
that no but what previous tier you know
either once you're in Game Pass goal a
game pass
because gold is just
to Game Pass so if you're a person that
plays Call of Duty every year and your
fans jump in the park like yo let's play
this this actually still gonna play Call
of Duty okay let me jump over that and
try it so you get over there and you
play that in the regular game pass at
this point and it says yo if you want to
play online you got to give us an extra
five dollars on top of the one that
you've already gave us to upgrade from
court to regular games
the discrepancy is that guy was buying
Call of Duty for seventy dollars
regardless he was gonna play online with
gold regardless he was never but my
point is you've got that dude to switch
because he wasn't him
I'm listening to you but it's like it's
don't be done because it's a
conversation that you're having but
you're not trying to I'm gonna finish
so you you give this person
let's play this EXO Primal they're in it
because they want to play Call of Duty
but they're willing to try another game
okay I'll give you this extra dollar so
they go over there and like yo if you
want to play online with uh Primal you
got to pay the extra five to go to
Ultimate or you got to go back to the
previous tier where you were so they're
like okay I don't want to do that that's
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go play
Call of Duty because I don't want to pay
extra money to do that but then they
they boot up Call of Duty and it asks
for that again
if you because once you go back because
they're going to go back and play the
game that they're originally playing
which is cod Madden 2K right and now
that they've got them to upgrade for
this game that they can't play because
they can't play online in the middle
tier they're either gonna have to go up
to Ultimate to play Call of Duty again
or they have to go right back down to
core to play Call of Duty again
I'm confused because Game Pass they
won't be able to play EXO Primal or Call
of Duty if they were Xbox Live Gold guy
that could have got converted to core
they can't play that game so they were
going to buy 70 dollars play the game
and have the online version as a core
guy that that the only temptation is if
they see EXO Primal and they see Call of
Duty as part of Game Pass but their game
pass core they have a curated list that
is only these games and that's it they
can't do Starfield they can't do it the
hope of Xbox is the hope that they
upgrade to to that now if you saying
they upgrade you know will they upgrade
to
um to console Xbox console that's
different because then if you upgrade to
Xbox console you lose the ability to go
online my assumption or I'm saying that
assumption but what I would think
Microsoft would do is say hey you're a
core guy
go to Ultimate right so you're I know
what you're argument your argument is
the upgrade path right and then right it
isn't right because you give people the
scenario like because like I said
there's a reason these people ain't on
Game Pass right they're mainly playing
just the same games right absolutely I
get your points
I got you now and then they get in that
tier they're gonna pay more about to
play these games I gotta try to play
these games online and then they go to
play the first online game in game
package when you go up they're not going
to tell you what you lose I guarantee
you if you switch from core to Game Pass
then I could say yeah you better lose
online your question is is Court will
Game Pass console even be an option for
a core guy and will it be well that's
the question right but but here's the
point that's on that chart let me give
it to you very specifically I know what
you're gonna I think I'm sorry I can't
finish
my my issue with it is once you're in
that middle tier
and you're wanting to play something in
that game pass you either have to go up
like there's no there's no getting
anything separate like when you go from
that middle tier to play some of that
first year to play something in that
middle here if you want to play online
you have to upgrade again or up or or
downgrade back to the original one so
there
look sure people could go back down but
most of the time they're going to get
that dollar from whoever wants to
upgrade to the game pass and then go get
that extra five if they want to play
color most of these people I did I did
call service for two years at Dish
Network most of these people ain't
really educating none of this matter
they're gonna upgrade they're gonna
upgrade every time they're gonna be some
people that gets upset go back down but
my point is you giving people the option
to upgrade to play a game that you have
promoted as a multiplayer game you're in
that core membership but you know once
they upgrade they won't have access to
that game online now if they upgrade to
Game Pass console yes
now okay I'm gonna give it to you I know
the thing is this
and I think this is where our disconnect
is is that they know from their
analytics and their metrics and their
Telemetry The Game Pass gold the Xbox
Live Gold guy was not moving he was not
tempted by Game Pass he was not moving
so they transformed him into Game Pass
core and he's got better value and in
their mind they're like yo you could
stay there you can you haven't shown
that you're willing to move nothing that
game pass does is enticing you you're
cool with paying for getting seventy
dollars and playing for online and we're
happy that you're there we're just
changing your name we're giving you a
jersey nothing's changing and I think
that's how they're resolving it they're
like look we're not gonna move that guy
off his Square he hasn't moved for all
these years so that's what it is but
that's what I thought King I'm gonna let
you finish then we can move on but all
right
um I go to Taco Bell
every week every week I get two cheesy
bean burritos
two cheesy bean burritos is the cheapest
thing on the menu
doesn't have any meat just have bean
cheese and rice okay I can work with
that
Game Pass that's the whole menu That's
the smorgasbord you can get everything
if I wanted to go in there and get a
Cheesy Bean Crunchwrap Supreme it'll
cost me extra money I could do that
the game's a gold dude it's me cheesy
cheesy Bean dude I can see whatever the
hell you have up there I don't care what
my who's in the car getting what who's
upgrading to what I don't care I'm
getting my cheesy bee in the mouth and
nothing on your menu is gonna entice me
Game Pass look that deck Microsoft
looked at them was like yo these dudes
are never coming over man and the
numbers is consistent this guy goes out
he spends his money for Forza whatever
the hell whatever the hell he spends his
money on he or she they stay there and
that's it
I don't see because you you made uh a
scenario an assumption
that that guy that got converted from
gold into core is going to be enticed by
anything he hasn't been enticed by
anything ever
so why would he be entice just because
they changed his name right and I don't
think that's a valid reason to have the
argument but I must say this
online should be available in autism
fact that's the issue here that's that's
bigger that's the big issue here that's
what we all agree on right it's the
online console guy yeah dude that's in
core that dude that was gold
he's always gonna be gold he's all you
just changed his name he don't he's he
doesn't care if Starfield is coming out
because he wasn't playing that anyway he
was going to go get him I'm gonna call
my man where Frodo at the chat he a gold
dude put your hand up code I want to
know how this affects you because this
really he's a guy that will refuse to
buy gay fast but I'm sorry okay I see
you it's just the fact that I think it's
disingenuous to assume that the core the
games of gold bless you the game's a
gold dude who is now a core dude just
because he got his name changed is now
going to have a different appetite for
other games I don't believe that that to
be true I believe that that person is
going to be core and he's going to stay
core and probably don't even be enticed
by anything that's inside Game Pass core
that will just continue to just do his
online stuff just to play online stuff
or whatever and play those games that he
normally plays he or she whatever but I
feel that fundamentally as a business
practice core has online the middle test
should have online
I think we're all in agreement there and
I think that's why to addicts point
there is a a slight problem with the
messaging and confusion like that middle
team when you look at it across the
board yes my whole point is just to
justify that that middle tier should be
online regardless right absolutely I
know where you're going brother the
point is is if you offer a tier system
people in the chat saying this isn't a
tearsome yes it is they want you to go
from the core system to either to the
middle or get Game Pass ultimate they're
not going to offer you the the PC thing
that's just saying that that's existing
this is definitely a tier system there's
no way around that
I don't think it's a tier system but I
do understand the point of being a Xbox
console guy not having online seems
weird that's just the bottom line it
it's just weird and it's something that
we as console Gamers should have never
signed the blood Money contract but we
we got listen it was at its time it was
revolutionary nobody was doing it you
know we thought how great they they put
I always give Xbox credit for um
pioneering the Broadband era into the
space the ethernet in the back of the OG
Xbox I was an Xbox Live Alpha tester I
thought that was the greatest thing to
be able to talk to someone in Australia
who never met me before and we're
playing Ghost Recon and I'm like yo this
is amazing from that point on everybody
adopted it PlayStation started charging
Nintendo now does this thing so again
not saying it's right
and to King's Point though King got I
think had one of the strongest points
out of all of us
the problem is console dudes just talk
and King is right if if you truly put
your foot down because according to Xbox
they want you over that's the most
closest PC
so dudes that's a completely different
argument in itself true the fact that it
that line between a PC Xbox ecosystem
yeah in an Xbox like the console Xbox
system keeps getting bigger and bigger
first it was a little bit of time
exclusives now that you don't have to
play online and then it's EA play is
in-game pass for PC but not Game Pass
for console and then on top of that you
pay five dollars less to be in PC game
pass if you do console Game Pass yeah
and that's the thing and I think they
know the PC guy I mean excuse me the
console guy doesn't want to buy a PC and
the PC guys content where he over there
and that's why we're in the situation PC
thing Microsoft should be ashamed of
himself for doing no they don't they
should do exactly what they're doing
I'm the consumer first
me too and apparently not like you don't
care about the concert I don't care
my PC my PC is right there if I want to
get busy with my PC pause I will get 50
with my pieces I don't like my PC that
like what what in your personal opinion
what is more
of value PC game pass or console games
it depends on the individual yeah
like five dollars less okay time out
time out you're gonna ask me
I play on my console
the PC can burn to the ground for all I
care I don't care about PC game pass and
I don't care what exclusive games they
got popping off over there I don't care
to look inside there to figure it out
what I do care about is when I go turn
on my Xbox series X that I paid that 500
for that the games in there is on there
that's it and don't tell me about old PC
then they got something Skylanders too I
don't care like I'm just it's just me
but it's an option
come over and do it you don't feel a way
that PC game pass pays less for what you
pay for all right you know what it is I
don't care about what somebody else
doing
my like my mentality is not about what
somebody but you're paying me they're
often different consumers the same
product as you at a cheaper price I have
ultimate if I choose to partake I can do
so that gives me versatility now what
you're trying to tell me is you know the
PC guy I have a PC guy uh shout out to
uh uh big fat Eli he plays on his PC
inside of his country because
financially it's it's just it just works
that way for him right and he's able to
be a little bit more versatile in doing
so and it works for him
I can't begrudge him for for uh the fact
that he doesn't pay for online I don't
even know what his infrastructure is
over there but my thought is if I did
have a problem with it my series X my
series s's that's all over the place
they'll be gone and I just game on this
bad boy right here I don't care to do so
I'm not I don't envy what the PC people
are saving in that five dollars because
what they what also goes along with that
is I gotta update these drivers on my PC
I gotta go on my PC and do all this
other stuff that I don't care to do I
like to turn on my Xbox and it works so
if that five dollars is a convenience to
me that I feel that that five dollars is
well spent in that convenience in that
ecosystem then I'm going to game there
that's why you don't hear me screaming
about this but you do hear me screaming
that that middle tear should have online
and I think fundamentally we all can
agree the problem is that they don't
offer online in that middle tier to hell
with what the PC dude is doing because
I'm trust me I'm telling you I get
disgusted when I'm playing fortnite and
I see a little PC pop up in the corner I
was playing on it because I know it's
going to be a problem
I'm sorry you you can feel that way
that's fine that's just something we're
gonna have to agree to disagree because
I don't like it I don't like the fact
that they try to sell us the same
product essentially for for more
products right I mean but but I don't
have to boycott something not to like it
I can do both oh
no that's fair look that's fair I think
that um you know addicts make a good
point as far as the online thing I think
that's the fundamental issue I think
King's making a good point about the
convenience of console versus the PC guy
why people still stay in the uh the
console ecosystem versus the PC guy that
is to put the entry points to Costa we
could go on and on for that but I do
agree that the for us to have this
discussion about a chart means that
there is somewhat of a messaging thing
that could be addressed as far as yeah I
think that's the online part is is the
is the messaging on this particular
problem but for me I do want to defend
on one last point before we go I do feel
that it is not I want to just be clear
on my part with this I don't feel it's
predatory for the Xbox Live Gold guy
that guy is getting a way better deal
than he ever had before I just wanted to
stress that guy because if I whatever
the metrics are I don't know what the
splits are 70 30 you know but they want
to convert that guy and this was the way
to get him in and then ultimately this
is the way long term to say hey third
party company we have a hundred you know
instead of you know 30 million Game Pass
subscribers we have with this 70 100
million now that that goes to the
business model right that that's
ultimately what they're trying to do and
thus I think that's where we're at but
it behooves Microsoft at some point
maybe to look at what I would say which
is The Game Pass console guy and why you
know he has it and then have those
important conversations that if we if
they do include online multiplayer
what the price is going to be because my
opinion they're not giving that a free
they're going if you're doing anything
to be honest with you they may not if
they were wanting to do anything they
would have did it when they did the
structure to your system they didn't so
I have no intentions that they'll ever
fix this and and unfortunately it made a
point and to your point that's a good
point there and to King's Point you know
it puts the pressure on the onus on the
consumer to say you know what I don't
like that right I don't like that this
is predatory I feel this this other tier
is not giving me good value I'm out it
puts the bonus on that person to do that
so it's a good discussion though I do
like this let us get these super chats
and let's see what we got what we got
um I don't know where we left very
adversarial show today what is what we
do I think what they tell us like yo
what did I walk into this is normal like
we do this all the time so it's just not
like people get confused when they see
the Lord's debate because disagree this
is light I had to be honest we disagree
but we disagree a little bit more
cantankerously yeah we way more do
people get oh I'll go with it like we
get go hard so anyway let's see I'm
going to go back to I don't know where
we missed all right y'all got the chair
all right I'm gonna start with L boogie
because I think that's I think I
remember reading zip L books tell our
Super Chat love today's conversation and
guess so far learning loads about the
voice acting industry keep bringing more
guests like this salute the L bucks
salute the grown women gaming we got
something cooking with them soon that's
gonna be fun and all hopefully I think
they're gonna packs to packs West so
that'll be dope Robert Kelly 2000 Super
Chat gonna voice Sonic next I guess that
was for young gay Alvin with the five
dollar Super Chat kudos to young gay
explaining how it's the expression that
makes voice acting special reminds me of
let me take over because I've read oh
you left so I was like yeah because my
brother was knocking out oh okay okay
uh 13 is the Tampa area code where I
live 305 is Miami where I'm from I have
no clue where that came from
Robin King telling us beef up
damn
from Robert Kelly Final Fantasy has it
been turned based in over 20 years 20
okay well I'm still playing retro games
sue me
twenty dollars uh Super Chat from cdub
the first two hours of the show is Peak
reasonable King first time I agreed with
everything he said on 40 plus so I've
played them all in Final Fantasy 16 is
one of the best I'm gonna be honest like
Jay-Z said like the oldish but my uh but
my five mile yeah he didn't spell it
right here yeah if you like the old ish
buy my old albums yeah yeah five dollar
Super Chat for Robert Kelly
um it has the story tone and heart of it
so what if mechanics are different again
every Final Fantasy is different so
Final Fantasy can't try actions for one
game I don't think no one said that uh
100 Super Chat from uh Dango uh sorry
King no cash app on Switzerland here's
my money for the plates oh he sent you
the bread for the foot for the wings you
go rip the wigs off
wigs gonna put the onus on me hold on at
it now you're gonna put the onus on me
that I gotta be putting up These Wings
solve right now is isn't feeling well
and we waiting for um some answers so
we'll uh I'll send that over to solve
and solve and send that over but I do
appreciate it thank you so much oh ten
dollars super trap from c-dub what
exclusives are what there's a Super Chat
that is so out of pocket okay what what
exclusives are uh what exclusives are
objectively better on Xbox than Nintendo
and Playstation y'all have talked more
about PlayStation and Nintendo
exclusives than Xbox make it make sense
I I can get I'm gonna go in on you
because I'm the Xbox dude so you're not
talking to these dudes today on over
there playing on that
um Halo I love that I love you can
literally set fire to anything on a
PlayStation roster and I would not trade
my halo for it I don't care what
iteration I got Halo Wars I'll take that
um Forza what you gonna put what racing
game you gonna put up that crappy Gran
Turismo throw yourself in the bush I'm
not even gonna listen to anything that
you're talking about because it makes
zero sense right
um gears I throw gears up against your
gear your God of War y'all y'all came
and try to manipulate the formula and
try to do what they do without guns oh
yeah oh we got an ax now and we're gonna
be a father to a kid that's not mine ah
get out of here with that that stuff I
like the gears I like the ground and you
know the chainsawing people in half and
I take guest tactics Where's God of War
tactics go away like you really think
you doing something but you really not
your third party machine like your
machine is really built off of other
people games not your own and the fact
that you did get a game would you The
Last of Us you're gonna milk that game
right now to the cow can no longer walk
so what are you doing really tell the
truth Shane the devil I don't care about
nothing that console can disappear the
date but I'ma tell you I'm a rock with
my Xbox so if you're gonna ask me you
talk so much about the PlayStation and
you put on so much about Nintendo I talk
about Xbox all day that's how I hold the
line started bro
find me
okay King smoking um you gotta read the
next fanatic this is crazy
[Music]
um
I'll read it okay let's snack on each
other's meat sticks for five dollars
Super Chat
where is the Cognito Buffet
I've been craving some blood sausages
and some thick juicy beefy thighs
I need the music kid this is of this is
oh oh
that is different
back to me Jim oh yes salute to everyone
in the realm
but with for 24 months Game Pass for
console actually change not sure why
anyone is having issues with that for
corn ultimate you have a point in that
you lose Games with Gold core gets
something ultimate get screwed shout out
to hard Geet then we got Michael
Bradford five dollar Super Chat disagree
with attic here I see it as only two
tiers tier one gives three choices
online game pass with no online or PC
tier two is you get everything attic you
would respond to Michael
all I have to say they named it Game
Pass core for a reason what what else
could it be besides the tier system if
it's named Game Pass gold if that wasn't
the The Dilemma that they were doing
they would have just kept it at Xbox
Live Gold
pragmatic Eagle member for 45 44 months
there is no middle tier console and PC
are the same for the respective
platforms core is the upgrade from gold
all our tier one game pass ultimate is
tier two there is no middle tier
the middle tick the first tier is core
that's the entry fee of Game Pass the
second tier is Game Pass that's the one
that you upgrade from core or you can
get PC game pass and the third and final
tier is Game Pass ultimate that's the
one that you would either upgrade from
core or upgrade from Go Game Pass
I guess they're trying to say that no I
don't know are they trying to say a lot
of things well I think if they try to
say from the the core guy goes to
Ultimate but okay
Cheo Walker five dollar Super Chat Game
Pass console has been around for years
without online if those guys want it
online they would have changed what they
had years ago okay resting Craig face
five dollar super chat if I upgrade to
console Game Pass will it allow me to
downgrade to get multiplayer back am I
going to have to wait until the next big
cycle that's a good question I don't
know that that's actually a great
question
um uh the black John five dollar Super
Chat PC has access to EA access and play
E8 play regardless of PC game pass there
is no middle tier because ultimate is
the upgrade PC game pass is a dollar
less by the way all right uh cylinders
Bane remember for six months my solution
Game Pass core 8.99 a month and 60 a
year game console game pass with
multiplayer 12.99 a month 125 a year or
ultimate an ultimate with PC console EA
play and some DLC for 16.99 a month 180
a year so that's you got the solution
seat up eight one three three oh five
twenty dollars attic wash y'all with the
PC console game pass on it he's right I
got rid of my Xbox series X I can hook
up my PC to my TV via HDMI if I want and
get a better experience than console for
cheaper that's the dude I don't know
what they did or what they don't do it's
about the practice that's what that's
the dude I'm talking about you did it
you went out there and you did it and
you said it with your chest and you put
it in the Super Chat use about that life
now what I need you to do is I need you
to show that process to all those dudes
is crying the issue I have with that is
we give criticism to PlayStation all the
time we've been giving criticism to Xbox
all the time with that mindset we would
have just bent over years ago and just
bought another platform there was no
acquisition what's all this bending over
talk like the difference between
anything
the difference between the Xbox uh Game
Pass ultimate and the PlayStation is
there is no PC pathway for these dudes
so all they can do is like you said
today pause bend over and take it
CW 813 with the five dollar Super Chat I
said that because with attic red my
Super Chat he joked and he said it was a
Nintendo code their area codes that's
where it came from oh okay all right
there you go C double kid oh he cooking
five dollars Super Chat
um King none of those games have been
relevant in a decade besides Forza
that's why Microsoft stopped caring you
said a bunch of nothing my G okay so if
it's not relevant why are you super
chatting
obviously I touched you in your fields
because I told you the stuff that you
was feeling wasn't real
but I told you that the stuff that I'm
feeling is real I mean listen right now
what is your online presence when it
comes to any of your games stop it there
is none
bro play Halo right now
okay back to you Jim attic fragmatic
Eagle 200 attic PC Gamers can't use
console console user can't use PC same
tier core is as I said the upgrade from
gold it ain't even Game Pass for real
Ultimate is tier two love you bro but
you're wrong no core game PASS gives you
a set of features and you can either
upgrade a game pass or upgrade to PC
game pass I I and I said that when I
went over it I didn't say they were
together pragmatic eagle or you could
upgrade to Ultimate and utilize both of
them so listen and have critical
thinking before you Super Chat and
attack me
[Music]
I don't care about your Spiderman anyway
so look we got we got to get to um the
next tablet king um this is kind of a
combo topic between me and you and
there's a lot going on with Sony so I
just want to start off initially with um
obviously there was the trailer Venom
you know trailer Spider-Man 2 looking
really fire we got that and then we also
got the announcement of the PS5 Marvel
Spider-Man 2 limited edition bundle
comes out pre-order comes out July 28th
got the console looking all delicious
got the control looking sparkling you
know what I'm saying so they got that
that's gonna again you got the pre-order
you got the Dual sense or symbiote
design all that good stuff and then also
they all gave the option okay to rip
your wings off freely you can just buy
the wing things you don't have to get
the limited edition I think I'm gonna be
doing that too and then they got the um
the what you call it the uh the
controller separate as well so if you
don't if you miss out on the bundle and
uh yeah the full bundle will be released
is October 28th who purchased the bundle
receive a voucher for the digital
standard edition of the game we'll get
some pre-order incentive items so then
we got more news I saw Tom Henderson in
the chat earlier uh tell her to say how
much can he's
I I think that um if it's a pro console
oh if you talk about this console it's
gonna be the same price oh probably 50
more so let's see they're gonna give
that does it come with Spider-Man
um I believe if it comes with Spiderman
um if the digital code comes with
Spider-Man later they're gonna attack in
the price of Spider-Man so you gotta add
the price of Spider-Man and probably
like 25 to 30 it says so players who
purchased the bundle that has a vouch
who has a voucher for the standard
digital edition of the game will also
get the pre-order exclusive so I'm
assuming yeah they get the thing to get
the game all right so we got that then
Tom Henderson cooking up on inside
gaming you know he was one of the first
to tell us about the um detachable the
PS5 protocol slim with the detachable
disk drive you know what I'm saying as
far as that it should be able to be sold
separately Sony interactive
um said they can tell that new iteration
of PlayStation 5 will be Slimmer and
lighter which is something Sony has been
trying to implement effectively with its
latest PS5 model so we got that going on
then the other news you know I'm saying
which is really big cooking it's again
Tom Henderson is on fire right now
project Trinity they look like they're
going with all the The Matrix things I
think I forgot which one was the
Morpheus I think I the VR2 but uh yeah
so PlayStation 5 the details so far code
name project Trinity it's been in
development since early 2022 the dev
kits go out in November
some basic uh stats you know just
accelerated Ray tracing nothing hardcore
just yet we don't know that the inner is
targeting a November
2024 release so we got that cooking so
it's a lot of news and obviously King I
know you wanted to talk about potential
um showcase or Hardware reveals as well
as there's also a room of a huge uh
price decrease imminent for the
PlayStation 5 maybe to make way for the
slim and the and the pro so King this is
your topic where you going with this
what's your thoughts on all the
Playstations
well I think they they're focusing a lot
on Hardware I don't hear any software
you know of course we got Spider-Man
coming
um and that's pretty good
um I don't think that Tom I don't think
there's gonna be you're not gonna hear
no 99 thing for me I mean 99.
like the price to pie no I didn't
actually I just gave you the price of
the PlayStation 5 plus the VR came up to
exactly what I said was 1200 bucks for
real yeah all right so
um the PlayStation Pro is a kind of an
enigma because
um
do I feel that we need it no I thought
we needed the PlayStation 4 Pro with the
the because of the VR right and it
needed that added boost I thought the
PlayStation 5 was supposed to be able to
give that an eye from everything I've
heard from every PlayStation VR2 guy
that the PlayStation 5 is handling it
adequately and and it's and it's
performing well so what they just need
is software
um the PlayStation slim this is the
conundrum
I gotta pick up some wings from my
PlayStation 5 right now right does the
PlayStation slim is just a little bit
smaller and still keeps the same form
factor with the wings because I think
you're on to something and to remove
yourself from that market where you can
either sell the wings separate and and
instead of buying a whole console
because a lot of people missed out on
that PlayStation 4 Spider-Man uh console
like myself I went I was dying to get it
and then when it did hit the aftermarket
it was astronomical in price
um so now this gives you the opportunity
and it I think it cuts that market from
the scalper that uh they can try to
scout the PlayStation 5 uh you know VR
uh I mean um the PlayStation uh
Spider-Man uh console but it's not going
to be as effective because you just can
go buy the wings so I think they they
can subvert that um aftermarket it being
sold that way and I think that's a smart
thing what would this slim look like
like would it keep that fact there is a
lot of questions but price and wise I
think they're going to stay in the same
whale house I think they're going to do
like uh Microsoft did with the little
man and they're going to lower the price
on one and keep the same core price
initial price of uh like the the the the
next little man with the bigger SSD
um I think they're going to do the same
thing so I think they're going to slowly
phase out because we I don't see the
distance ones anymore that much on the
desk in the store and I think that was
like a market employed to act like they
were under the the number and and some
people got a lot of discless ones I see
more people with the ones with the
distance you know without all the ones I
did pick up was was the one with the
disc so I think they're just gonna fall
in line I think they're going to just
start uh you know lowering schools skus
and just eliminating uh some of those uh
those console fluff and this will be the
standard so the next one you're gonna
get is going to be the slim and then
you're gonna have the pro and they're
just gonna take over for the what we
have now the disc list one and the one
with the day so Tom got a question for
you he's he's cooking he says okay so
what do you think of this for the
PlayStation 5 Pro price 500 standard and
an extra 100 for a drive the new
PlayStation 5 entry point Point price
point where the new console would be 400
and he says he doesn't think the new PS5
will be branded Slim
um you would know more to me uh when it
when it comes to that aspect
I don't know in the climate that we're
living in now right where everything is
inflated as far as uh prices go
I can probably say fifty dollars more I
think they're gonna go right back to the
the whole uh 649.99 a 549.99 I think
they'll start packing I I think they
start tacking on the fifty dollar SKU
right
um because if you go to any high-end
stores they don't do the 99
they do the 49 right so I believe that
the 49 would be uh the the entry point
so if it is a a full over 399 it will be
449. if it is uh you know 4.99 it will
be 5.49. understand what I'm saying so I
just think they use the the 49 SKU
instead of the 99
real quick Tom do you think there'll be
a slim
yeah I'm hearing that they don't think
there's gonna be a slim he put the
report out he said
[Music]
oh man I got so many damn articles oh
man here we go yeah he said he called
the detachable new PlayStation 5. they
saying that I think that this is this
year they said um it's set to
PlayStation 5 said to get a unique
overhaul in the middle of financial year
2023 with the new console launching
around September of this year so they
said um sources are familiar with Sony
plans have shared details around the
condition of anonymity about the next
iteration of PlayStation 5 it will
completely replace the other a b and c
chassis this production line will be
called chassis D which will have
identical Hardware to the existing
consoles on the market the most
surprising feature of this new PS5 this
year is that the console will have a
detachable disk drive the detachable
disk drive will be connected to the
PlayStation 5 use it in the extra USBC
port on the back of the console it is
understood that this new PS5 will be
sold on its own or in bundle with the
detachable disk drive it is also
understood that the disk drives can be
purchased separately so if it gets
busted there's no need to buy an
entirely new console so yeah it looks
like they they're going to separate the
both of them it's supposed to be coming
this year which is yeah
no slim that's what Tom Anderson said so
always just calling it's just detachable
all right I see what you said okay
that's what you're saying because I was
told like two months ago that they
weren't even making this yeah it's just
the pro Tom corrected me he said he
agrees with you he said yeah no slim the
new PS5 has been called a slim because
of SEO but I think it's just the PS5 so
it's a PS5 without the drive gotcha okay
I got you thank you for the clarity
there okay okay so you got your question
and then there's the same disc list
thing with a disc yeah it's detachable
it's just they'll probably take a little
bit more stuff out just to make it a
little Slimmer it'll probably Define but
it'll be around the same size like like
looks like it's kind of crazy I think
first off I think that Spidey PS5 is 100
more
financially it makes more sense for them
to to just make you buy another whole
console so you have if you want that
extra like customization uh Playstation
5. and to me if they're giving you the
ability to be like yo at it we got you
you don't have to give us 500. just give
us 80. or however much the the wings
gonna be called I think they're gonna
take that cost on the actual console
itself they're you know we're going to
give you a PlayStation 5. instead of it
being you know because if it's got
Spider-Man I'm I'm adding the 50 that's
what I'm saying 100. we're gonna charge
you for 50 for the Spider-Man stuff and
then we're gonna charge you another 50
for Spiderman itself so you're gonna
save a little bit on Spiderman because
it's not going to be 70 but we're gonna
charge you in a an additional 100 for
the Spider-Man bundle with the
Spider-Man game
I'm trying to look I'm on the site and I
don't see the comments there's no price
why is that price there the only thing
that's up there is the Spider-Man 2
collector's edition of the game and
that's 229 yeah to me people are like oh
it's gonna be the same price there's no
reason to hide that if it's the same
price there's no reason at all why even
why exclude the price unless it's not
the price that you think it's going to
be shout out to Tom Hannity he says so
not they can just manufacture One
console instead of two okay I see what's
going with that so um yeah I'll jump in
look man um that PS5 the console's fire
bro yeah all right so are you gonna just
buy Wings though yes uh thank God they
said I could rip my wings off and just
buy those wings because I just do not
like the PlayStation 5 aesthetically I
think it looked like a beach whale on
this side I do not like it the way it
looked but at least half my beach well
looking right so did you see Jay Rock
put up the back side of it yeah
he's so messy yeah I didn't even think
about this like King's right this is
going to destroy the second hand market
like absolutely obliterated because
because now people aren't going to just
hold on to these I'm kind of curious if
the wings are because obviously if you
switch the wings they're going to be
changed yes I'm curious that the core of
the console the thing you can't switch
is that going to be different in any way
shape or form to show the difference
between a custom one or one that just
ripped off the wings and replace that's
a good question yeah that's a good
question I mean yeah does the the one
the console that's already got the wings
all in the bundle is that any little
different I was probably guessed not
it'd probably be the same thing but yeah
man I'm looking forward to that I get
the controller separate get the wings
separate that's dope
um I gotta have some fun with y'all
doing this this the real thing I want to
ask both of y'all
so shout out to my man ran out though we
had a fun debate
and this is about the pro we got to talk
Pro now this Pro is coming
Pro coming y'all 2024 Ray tracing High
frame rates you know so the talk is the
mindset is
you know when that digital Foundry come
round
and then uh multi-platz start getting
compared and if uh you know someone's
out here consistently hitting 60 frames
and above and someone ain't and um
you know the unique position of Xbox
this generation because uh last
generation right
PlayStation 4 did bring a pro to the
market first now the argument I had with
my good brother Randolph thought because
he corrected because I forgot about this
I said well PlayStation Pro came out
first right they were first to the
market this is not nothing new and then
Scorpio Xbox One X was announced at E3
and then they came after but what he
told me he was like hog you forget
the series the Xbox One X even though it
came after the PS4 Pro they knew about
it and they announced it at the E3 with
a borrower and all in them like hey guys
we got something coming even though the
PlayStation 4 Pro wasn't to market yet
so the question I gotta start my stuff
addict versus fun the question I got
do you think because we've heard two
different things we've heard one in the
past Phil says yo we will never be
beaten on power again right then we
heard just recently Phil Davis Spencer
saying
yo we don't think we necessarily doing a
mid-generation upgrade this thing we
good for Series S and X
what do you think happens addict do they
does Depression start to be on if this
thing is out here cooking it PlayStation
5 Pro or do they say hey we good we
standing pack
I don't think if they're not star if
they haven't already started a
you know research development on a
series X uh version 2 or Series S
version two they're not doing one at
that point it takes it takes a little
bit to do that and to me by the time you
get the research and development get it
out in the market if they haven't done
it now where it's out in 2024 2025
what are they going to do it for like a
year because I mean they said they
expect consoles of 2027 2028. so like at
that point I think it's just too late
like you're not gonna ask people to
upgrade for a year and a half to two two
tops so it's just like
if they don't do it and they have if
they don't have something right now in
the line to come out they better hope to
God these games come out and start just
just start bashing the PlayStation every
five seconds and hold the line with all
the games you got in the Acquisitions
you got because because I'm telling you
like and then it would depend on like is
the third party gonna take advantage of
it if PlayStation was smart yeah and if
PlayStation was was smart and Microsoft
doesn't respond with their own midgen
they need to spend a whole marketing
Budget on these on these third party yo
you know I I'm seeing this you ain't
taking like there's three percent of our
system you ain't took advantage of I
need you back in that lab right now
so it to me if if they don't do it it's
Sony does something like that where they
know because there's a difference
between not really hitting that spot
because your competition is is blowing
you back out with that when it comes
to like balloons when they come to like
the Xbox One X compared to like the
PlayStation 4 Pro nine times out of ten
the Xbox One X was doing like
substantially but if you had the pro by
itself
maybe you spend more money making sure
it's utilized and that's all I'm saying
so so that grand theft looking and you
need to Grand Theft six and in the
PlayStation five don't fix your face
okay the PlayStation 5 Pro is laughing
the series X well it's six great traces
60 frames and then we see the the series
X is 45 unstable
that's why I think that you know I don't
I don't believe that they're not doing
one oh so you think they play possible
they maybe maybe they have these like
high high classified like the like you
you got to be in the know and you have
to be in the know and they don't want to
know about this system Jason like this
is like Jason wrong it's Jason exclusive
right now like three people on his team
they trust what kinds of Clans like you
gotta have some like top Clan right
government
so that all right here we go now let's
let's throw more sauce on it this Barber
cakes so my thing now is
now when if you cooking secretly there's
the secret only the wizard no only the
great wizard Jason Ronaldo know and two
other people and they was gonna hold out
but now they see this thing and they go
when do you announce do you do what you
do with Xbox One X and steal the Thunder
at next E3 and say hey guys
and you have the you have the Montage
with all the executives in each box just
for breakfast
we do it however long it because we have
the unn confirmed on the pro you do it
however long Jason Rado knows right that
there is no going back for the okay but
like so so so E3 is still a thunder or
wait see what they do then come after
and announce
Jason Ronald knows what's going on over
there
on each side you win the three people
they got people on these sides he knows
and and you do it when you have to if if
they're able to come out next E3 and
they know for a fact PlayStation is
locked in these specs I say that yeah
yeah then do it at E3 okay so you see if
not you push that back because you don't
show your hand and Playstation just
changes a couple things on the back end
because they have enough time to change
things there's nothing been officially
announced that's what they're even
making one if they're not making one
it's like I said Perfect Dark better
come out and smack out of worlds two
better come out and smack hellblade 2
better come out and smack because if
you're not gonna hit them with power you
better have the best games every year I
mean with Call of Duty active version
you know there could be okay what if
Phil say oh we we already got jobs yeah
but Call of Duty is big but PlayStation
is is a Big Brand itself and you know
you might have called of Duty but it's
not like it's exclusive you're gonna
have a huge Advantage when it comes to
subscription Services it comes to Brand
recognition because you're going to have
your name at the end of every Call of
Duty commercial but they can't even
realistically do that I think they said
to like 2025. so you know because
apparently there's a claw or something
if that's true so it's like it comes
down to it is what it is I I don't know
I've not seen the contract I'm just
going off what I've seen
one of those things where it's like if
they're not able to utilize Call of Duty
to its fullest they need to make sure
everything else comes out and it hits
hard all right because at the end of the
day like if we know the third parties if
that's if PlayStation cares they could
come out there for pro and it'd be just
as strong as the series X we don't know
I doubt that but even even if it is
stronger
I've seen incidences where Dev kits have
been leaked and it's been stronger and
they've been thinking that's the
strength and it's not so I don't know
but at the end of the day there's a
couple variables that matter the
PlayStation cares if developers actually
use that power because that's important
also
are they willing to be in a market that
Xbox could potentially be in right right
and are they going to pay the money to
to
make another skew of their games because
keep in mind in mind third party doesn't
or do does take advantage of these skus
their first party has to so they have to
spend the extra money for the dev kit
spend the extra money in general all
right all right so so
you already pushed the button already
got you to push the button so you can
pushing it if Jason the T you part of
the email you said you go push it and
you own pretty much is like you gonna
get one you're gonna get one with if
you're gonna get the the series X x 2
billion whatever it's called whatever
you're doing it
he muted or he talking to somebody I'll
get back to you on that question all
right let's cook so um yeah so now King
PlayStation five we the Tom Henderson is
in chat you know it's real time are you
ready for this Tom Henderson in the chat
so it's real right
yeah he get a lot of PlayStation news
right so we know he's one of these
places you got a lot of insiders but we
know we so PlayStation 5 Pro let's say
November 2023 Ray tracing in these three
six in November 2023 I mean 2024 excuse
me sorry 2024 sorry sorry he ready yeah
Tom's ready hit the chat so now they
cooking
as a series now this is a little
different kid because this is a dual
School excuse situation right last
generation there wasn't no s is the S
kind of an X
can you sit back because you got just
got ABK you got we saw the hell blade
and all that's coming with the games and
let me go let me go let me give you a
little more extra I spoke to Kyler
Colin knows the PlayStation ecosystem we
can't take that away from that man he's
like COG I'm seeing two major bangers
per year from PlayStation with the
exception of a three maybe like a
exclusive deal like how they did Final
Fantasy 16 but if you look at the year
right he's kind of on point because it's
Spider-Man and what was it for spoken at
the top maybe if you want to say that so
so right it's okay but so that's their
case and Game Pass you got all these
Acquisitions Call of Duty you got ABK
you got all your ears
decadence according to quarterly right
so can you stay Pat and be like yo let
them dudes Rock nah we got the games
We're Not Gonna Stay Pat no what are we
doing okay so
all right for the uninitiated the dudes
that don't appreciate it I'm gonna give
you something that you wish I didn't say
because you're gonna hate it
um
you already saw a mid-gen refresh
they did it at this E3
um
series that's back in black black man
little black man but what you're gonna
see is the the little white man slide to
the side they're gonna start cutting his
numbers down
all right and you know he's gonna be
replaced all right so that's done
PlayStation is doing it right in front
of your very eyes
they're gonna they're gonna make
it one skew right and they did it
they're gonna have the digital joint
with a disc in the back that's gonna be
the de facto play State five Thomas
right so get rid of both of those two
skews that you got there have this one
skew here boom and then you can buy that
little detachable pregnancy thing like
everybody umbilical cord later
oh man no don't do that don't do that
too much death stranded
baby don't don't throw Baby by
PlayStation 5 please
I want it to be see-through so we can
see
[Music]
but that's smart right all right because
your next move is your PlayStation uh
five Pro and your favorite the reason
why your PlayStation 5 Pro is coming is
not really because of Xbox and his power
because it didn't really show any true
dominance over it so it's not like
they're running from anything to be
honest with you but what it is is you
saw Final Fantasy 16. and you saw that
it didn't it wasn't able to push those
numbers that you wanted it to push this
is not an 8K machine never was never
will be but you have 8K on the box right
yeah so what you do want is you want a
4K machine you're not even a 4K machine
so you do want to to get that power to
that level all right so this is really
more about them and their self and
operating in their own Windows Xbox
ain't hitting in the 60s no no no I'm
not I'm not saying I'm not listen you
know but XX has more 4K games than these
dupes 120 uh frames per second okay and
these dudes these dudes over there they
ain't looking kind of sharp so let's
let's let these dudes worry about them
and get their stuff together so respect
to these dudes that's going into the lab
and they're saying yo we're
underperforming at this SSD I thought
SSD pushed Graphics
shout out to Quantum error it's double
the speed please show it your back your
game better show it he should show his
game people yeah your game is on the
line we're not liking what they saw but
that's right we're we holding the line
to see if your game can hold the line oh
all right you picked a team you better
stick with it continue all right so
again so that's for them and that's
gonna work great for them they're gonna
finally get a the Final Fantasy is going
to finally run at 1080p wait a second
let's go let's get it right we outside
the problem is Phil Dominus Maximus are
really expensive doesn't care about what
the hell you're doing right now he gets
the purse string so he said they don't
feel about a mid dream refresh they're
not going to call it that oh they're
just gonna wipe out the place the the um
Xbox series X and they're gonna put an
Xbox series X plus it's just gonna be
just like they're gonna do little man
and they're gonna announce it at E3 you
guys it's gonna be coming out
you can go all sweet and dude's gonna be
right behind you like shut up so they
gonna drop it like they gonna do like
they did Scorpio where they go just talk
about it like yo we got enough monsters
another skew that we eat y'all all right
all right so hold on top let you finish
yeah
they did cookies right now they're lunch
meat I got more I got it I hope you're
right I really do you ain't gotta hope
I'm gonna stand on my squid cause I just
saw you doing a lot of dancing bro
I'm gonna stand on my screen
I'm not giving my attention
if my opinion is the to the king it's
dance
Jason Ronald and that's Squad Pride bro
okay okay you're not gonna he's not
gonna let no detachable pregnant baby
machine come out here and outwork his
baby oh it's just not gonna happen
and yo they not gonna take away the disk
drive you ain't gonna have to buy no
optional baby attachment system
all right we're kidding we can't start
in the trend bro all right fed up but
let's let's talk about some practical
realities you are us two excuse system
right Series S it's out of time Anderson
he said I think Xbox was banking on a
series that's selling more than it did
that's why they put the X they did the X
prematurely to get ahead of the PS5 but
covet disrupted everything then he said
now they changed acquisition to compete
what I was going to add on to you just
made little black men or the production
line right you just like him and getting
rid of little white man and we heard
that a lot of reasons why series X's are
not in the Shelf because you pushing a
lot of our souls towards the cloud
because you just got ABK you you need
these series X's to be an Azure servers
in Europe and Brazil and and right
they're affect the pylon right so could
they can they realistically make it in
time with all of this stuff going on
listen
they all work with AMD
um
that's the snitch in the room
that's the snitch in the room let's see
what the difference is
who's that who shows
who really rock with who right every
time you turn around Microsoft is where
AMD some place to eat lunch Sony y'all
just shop here they are peoples like so
you think you gonna go make a concert on
these dudes ain't gonna be like but yo
let me tell you what they working on
you're not gonna get no leg up you're
fighting in your own box you're not a
competitor nobody looks at you as a
competitor Nintendo doesn't even look at
you as a girl you're fighting yourself
like you're literally Shadow Boxing all
day long
it's great I just want to play Final
Fantasy 16 in what it was supposed to be
or what you showed because it was
showing it on PC so so tell me what that
level you go to get your man Phil
Dominus Maximus he said in the courts
that it was like that they don't think
they don't think they doing it this year
they don't think they're doing their
prices is not today prices
why am I tipping my hand to these dudes
that do underhanded stuff you're talking
about a strategist here he gonna wait to
smack you in your face when everybody's
watching like he ain't gonna hit you in
the alley when nobody can see it the
sound heard around the world is when
they tell you that the Xbox series Pro
whatever is going to be called it's
gonna be launched in November and y'all
dudes is gonna have the happy sad face
like
[Laughter]
keep it on Twitter but
I don't yeah I can't with you in that
box I can't wait for you guys to fall
flat you guys y'all think you're gonna
win but listen I can tell you this I
will not be buying a PlayStation 5 Pro
oh unless unless there's something
because I brought the PlayStation 4 Pro
because of the VR
unless and this will get me to buy your
VR all right what you gotta do
if it adds something to it like because
the PlayStation 4 VR added performance
to it because they showed you the
difference oh yeah remember they showed
you the difference so I looked at my
PlayStation 4 like you know you gone
right and I got the Triple Decker
sandwich I didn't care I went out and
got it and I did my VR so this will get
me to get the pro
um and and get me to get the VR I'll
probably pick them up okay right you got
to show me what enhancements it does in
your ecosystem it's really not about out
doing the next two it's really about
doing what you can do inside your own
house because some of your games aren't
hitting the targets and you know um
digital Foundry already let y'all know
y'all not really competing with those
other dudes anyway so you're really
competing with yourself and I thought
the series X was holding y'all back but
it seems like you're holding yourself
back oh man that detachable pregnancy I
don't know Tom Henderson has been in the
Navy you prematurely but he said buy the
PS4 Pro 5 Pro for the pro uh project Q
I'll apparently be getting you yeah I
don't know if he's joking or he said
yeah you winning yeah I don't see like a
veil of a slightly he knows he knows Jim
has to make that money back from the
snitching fiasco
look we gonna see this is a fun one I
like I said we ever been able to talk
we're kind of going at it and I'm trying
to look at it and it's tough because
what threw me off was the recent
statements like yo you know we we don't
plan on making any [__] re uh refresh
this generation and then to see
PlayStation so aggressive with the
opposite and that yo PlayStation 5 and
for the record laws of game and that had
that right shout out to my man's gaming
we talked about the PlayStation 5 Pro
was going to be coming and people
laughed us out the rule shout out the
man's gear that's what I was gave that
now you can always check that out there
but um salute to Tom Henderson for the
cosign you know saying that's been going
on now but um look it's tough
King I just feel because the roles are
reversed in a way
Xbox kind of got the games now they kind
of do you know what I'm saying you can
say it's one star feels common Forza
this year you know the ABK deal is
massive I think they're gonna deliver
and yeah and we saw the Showcase and we
saw everything from Xbox game studios
and everybody looking at that face
people looking at Fable like yo the drug
looks so good it can't be real like like
so I'm at that point where they're
having that case Xbox is so good right
now call call that people are making
videos about us almost weekly yeah like
you know it's cooking like they can't be
really fans of the platform like that
it's got to be bags being sent off or
whatever that's when you know dudes in
their feelings but at the end of the day
like I'm torn because I do also remember
feel like yo we are never losing the
power narrative again
and here's the thing
I know Jason and the team in that three
email group that uh attic is clearly on
oh
feel like they always cook it
they're always cooking right it's just a
matter if you're gonna push the button
and release the same way like what was
the um the Keystone right they was
cooking they had that they got it's just
whether or not they're gonna release it
so now they're like oh maybe we don't
even fall back we got the APK or
whatever we fall back
right now
gone to my head
60 40 they make
our announced in Newcastle
I think that they let they value
those digital Foundry comparisons
remember series X Xbox One X got sent to
digital Foundry remember that they let
them in they let
um a homeboy LED better
have that they value they knew in the
PlayStation 4 Xbox one generation they
could not have the 1080p slanted the 79
720p 900 piece Landing going again
I think they're sitting Pat now but I'm
telling you if that with that
PlayStation 5 Pro come out and numb
joints is talking dirty it's gonna get
ugly it's gonna get ugly and you know
how that's why I just personally feel
like there's no way that they're not
looking at what could happen if they
don't respond to that Pro right so I
think to King's Point they playing it
cool maybe they doing a little mental
gymnastics with the with the you know
regulators and I think they coming now
until they to to my point though I do
think
it's I think it's coming I just think
maybe they don't have to rush because
they know they got software they don't
have to rush but it will be interesting
if they get dirty and announce it before
like in at E3 2024 yeah if they get
dirty that's the only question will they
or will they wait and just let them have
a cycle and show all your games that's
coming because remember they still got a
valve they still got hellblade all last
next year most likely they did that this
year they had a great show and they said
at the end of the show yeah little man
nobody saw a little black man
yeah yeah
yeah oh the SSD size on little man is
the problem well here it is but all
right they went in there to the dev kids
and they made sure that they took the
the extra space inside to make little
man a little bit more viable so fast
let's not act okay
and they don't want to lose the price so
they're going to keep the price and
they're gonna keep the power so as soon
as these dudes make it official they're
gonna put a ring on it they're gonna be
like yeah we coming out with our
PlayStation 5 Pro they're gonna say Coco
[Applause]
we got you where we want it okay okay
and E3 we're gonna Flex on them
here's the other thing here's the but
here's the secret sauce though at it in
the court documents Jim Ryan was very
animate we didn't want to give them
their our deaf kids that's right Call of
Duties with avk you gonna know what's
going on Xbox is going to know what's
going on with them they are literally
their biggest third party publisher with
Minecraft and Call of Duty they will
know what that PlayStation 5 Pro is
doing and if that Pro is really cooking
in my opinion do you best believe they
coming with something so what's the best
thing of reverse engineering
so good okay so I think we could all
agree that
there's a good chance that this thing
has
um
that that this is coming out like I do
truly think that there's no way that
they just don't respond to the pro and I
think we all agree on that I agree I
agree I agree now
what's the Dome
Tom Henderson and he's been pretty
accurate now yes I think that maybe
Microsoft knows that uh you know this
particular thing maybe they are holding
this I got a really really high to that
but what happens if they generally do
not respond with the pro in the series X
just isn't getting an upgrade the whole
generation how do you feel like like
over time that's gonna because I think
short-term it's not gonna be an issue
even if they don't respond to it by the
time the PlayStation 5 comes out
probably into 2024 yeah they'll have a
good three years of getting like hit
some not hit some but if if this really
did catch Xbox all like out of pocket
like they didn't like they really
thought with Tom Henderson like that the
series s is there like there's their
actual system and the X's their their
pro version
Xbox needs to be on the phone every
third party how much it will cost for
you to make sure that you use our x to
the best
how much it's gonna cost no look it's
gonna be it's gonna be interesting
listen I this is the rare time that
listen I want to accomplish I want to
upgrade I'm I'm a console guy first so
I'm with this where I'm at this
ecosystem I like I want the most part
I'm will I'm the Enthusiast I'm willing
to play for pros I am the Scorpio guy
that is me so if they drop a PlayStation
5 Pro yes I'll be there if they drop a
series X2 billion double X with extra
cheese I'm there so this for me
the question now to me though is the
series s
because now you're introducing a third
skew and I'm just curious if they do
drop the a bit generate refresh
do this they what
do you phase out little man
oh no time over the course of the
generation let's just say he he holding
stuff up with his little Ram his little
Ram is a problem and for what's going on
give him give him attachable baby drive
expansion
a boost in his belly so we're just gonna
scale down they just gonna get the
lowest it's gonna be like remember where
attic had the Xbox One S
and he was talking about his games okay
this is different all right so the
architecture that we're dealing with oh
yeah guys I gotta go my aunt just passed
away oh I'm sorry oh my God oh God oh
God we got it we got it today's just a
rough day all right no brother go do
what you gotta do we got it um this this
is a different
um please so send your wish I love the
attic it is on man oh my god
um this is different he was talking
about a different generation okay this
generation is the same it's just scaling
up a PC and scaling it down when I watch
fortnite and I'm watching these guys
play fortnite these high-end PC dudes
right
on a PC I'm seeing no textures like
they're playing this game with no Texas
I'm playing on my series X and I have
all these textures and stuff I notice
now what they do is they strip the game
in order to make it run in its most
efficient Factor
um there's always going to be an entry
point for certain stuff right there's
always going to be a high-end Microsoft
has always alluded to the fact that
there will always
be a console yeah in a premium space
fair enough now in saying that
I know Phil I know I'm enough to know
his dude wants to win
and that power thing bothered the yeah
right so his first order of of of his uh
was the series X
um XBox One X right and that that that
one console right there was he didn't
care if it sold a lot he didn't care or
what it uh truly ultimately didn't
achieve because I don't I think that was
the most underutilized console in
existence or what it did establish from
the rip was power yes so
um a Forza 4K 60 we saw um Assassin's
Creed 4K 60. we saw these things and we
was like oh yo this this is here to play
we saw it in in our space he was very
proud of that machine yeah that was his
but what he was also proud of of is us
as Gamers or us as Xbox Gamers
understand and he said it with his chest
we will never he did say that but the
power narrative go you will never be
stronger so you're fighting you're
Shadow Boxing yourself because when the
dude that has the ability
to put out something right after you
told you you're never going to be better
ever you better get your software game
up oh you're never going to have a
better Hardware
it's a fact and it's gonna stay a fact
and that's just something that y'all
gonna have to die with
oh my God if he died he died if he died
look I mean he just say that that's my
gut still leads towards they will do
something you know I think they've
already already sitting on something
right now in my opinion it's just a
matter of the timing the deals the games
all that good stuff and uh yeah I just
want to see what the if they do it the
price point and all that good stuff but
it was a fun debate I did want to talk
about that and again a brother addict
said some love to him you know I'm
saying it's on past me rough day in the
realm a little bit we had a great show
with young we did it got a little
roughly with um with attic and then
obviously saw you know going through
what he going through I'm gonna read the
super chess cake and then I'll just get
this popping so we got c-dub813
um he found out some chat he laughed out
loud I'm super chatting because I'm
supporting the show love you guys but I
got a push back it's all good bro we
love it we love opposite opinions
appreciate your support Ty caceres with
the 14 15 I think Australian Lords what
are your thoughts about uh Halo being an
Xbox IP or just abort IP have a good
great day Lord
the Halo yeah about Halo being an Xbox
Xbox IP or oh like you know what dudes
be like um yeah it's on Xbox but they
brought that they didn't make that like
that kind of like well bungee like that
kind of engine like okay when I buy you
you mind like what what part are you not
understanding like you guys are really
weird when it comes to that if my logo
boots up first like when you when you
put it up and it goes Microsoft Studio
it's mine
so it you know I didn't have no problem
when um I put on MLB to show in Game
Pass and it said Sony studio I was happy
it said that right does it take away
from anything but you're gonna say
that's the Sony first party Studio at
some point in time they brought them
they didn't come from the ground they
brought them Insomniac with Spider-Man
logo come out was they did that organic
okay so you think it's just a form of
credit stealing that's what just do well
I'm still as hell out that credit I buy
you put my name on the front like yo so
when you got married
um you put a ring on him
so you had a different last name that's
not yours right her last name was Tor
Road now it's Johnson
I kid that man okay so it's a former
credit score
all that credit thank you anyway shout
out to uh thx13 1138 follow us with chat
Sony marketing releases the PlayStation
Le limited edition Spider-Man 2 on
September oh on September 1st same day
as Starfield Premium Edition Early
Access oh
how does that do
when does Spider-Man come out they're
releasing the console for you to wait
until
you what you gonna do you just gonna
look at it
you can beat it with your concept
[Laughter]
come on and I'll keep sitting there
playing Starfield and you're gonna be
like hmm I see you in October man bro
get off my timeline
I showed up hmm
get out of here why are they gonna look
at it though it sound like that what is
it gonna do
I'm gonna play the old Spider-Man is out
already what is it gonna do oh man you
are messing
putting up a a great game against a
console man get out of here man that's
that super L they should just why ain't
they releasing that console in October
just to have you looking like a fool
sitting there like but in October though
I'm gonna be lit
I just now man
and you can't get gas until October
they parked the Lamborghini in front of
your house but you can't get the gas
until I kill it you are ridiculous
don't stunt on me
anyway this guy's out of pocket time for
a king he is messy today all right shout
out to the professor with the father I'm
sorry I think it's Canadian plates are a
nice feature of the PlayStation five but
all the plate designs including
Spider-Man are lazy all the Sony talent
and these are the plates we get damn
really like them things I thought the
place was fire but well on one side it
looks dope a J-Rock shout out to J-Rock
they showed he showed the back side of
it just got a little um Venom logo on
the front it got a nice little splash
listen the same thing with the three uh
the 360 plates in the front yeah take
them off those stuff is aesthetically
pleasing if you don't like what you
originally have I do not like
vanilla Wings on my PlayStation It's
gotta go and this thing makes it look a
little bit more appealing in my room
though and it goes with my room because
it's right next to my Spider-Man
yes I definitely want to shout out to
the professor looks like the uh no he
said that we said that one already
um Diego uh padal with the five I
believe Sweden sorry uh guys Microsoft
just signed a deal of parody to
PlayStation 5. if they have a
PlayStation 5 Pro the most popular game
will have to have parody to the series X
Max
I don't know I don't know about that we
got to see we gotta say I Know parody
for them with series X wait wait wait
this is what Diago said he said guys
Microsoft has just signed a deal of
parody to PlayStation 5. if they have a
PlayStation 5 Pro the most popular game
will have to have parody to the series X
Max I still think they got to take
advantage of the other PlayStation 5 Pro
okay so you don't understand what parody
means
and I understand it's cool
um
listen if your system can't do
volumetric fog you think I'm going to
remove volumetric fog out of my game
just because your system can't do it oh
we gotta dumb it down because you don't
know how to do math oh so I gotta add
gum just to make you feel better about
yourself that's just not gonna happen
what you're gonna get is if your system
can do whatever the maximum your system
is going to do it's going to be able to
be pushed so if you do 720 like y'all
been doing y'all gonna do the 720 and
we're gonna be doing the 4K it's just
how it is but it's not going to be
intentionally dumbed down that's what
they're talking about when it comes to
parody it's going to be equal it's not
going to be extra features inside the
box that your features can do just for
the sake of doing so whatever the
capabilities of your box is that's where
the parody comes in they're going to do
the features on their box and you're
going to do the features but it's a
first party title and you should be
happy that you're actually getting it
now stop it stop it I didn't like Call
of Duty anyway but now the Call of Duty
conversation is happening yes
there are two choices for the path going
forward for Xbox when it comes to the
pro they can either get a mid generation
Xbox upgrade themselves or they could
aggressively buy aggressively said it
capitals buy more Studios and start or
start a marketing game campaign that
says Gamers game so that's where he's at
with that okay and then oh JD JD gamer
again followers which they can Market
Gamers game and we've got the games this
is the this is after they have but
that's the ABK Sega IO damn certain
Affinity Avalanche Christmas okay okay I
see what we doing he's buying up the
whole store you buying up the whole
store Gamers game that's the slab okay
oh c dub is back seat up with the uh ten
dollar Super Chat I look forward to the
show every Sunday with my jerk wings and
my wrist like ah all right you already
talked I relate to y'all because I'm
also an 80s kid and we talk junk I had
an extra red stripe today
he was spicy he was fine I like that's
how we came up from snapping on each bro
that's how we come from Salute to you on
that Robert Kelly two dollar Super Chat
can't wait to sell my soul for Xbox XL
and PS5 Pro yeah all right Robin Kelly
we're gonna both lose kidneys oh yeah
we're getting it I'm not having that out
there and I don't have it Robert Kelly
oh damn Xbox has PlayStation 5 Pro Dev
kids hey if the Call of Duty game
finalized somebody gonna have to show
something Robert Kelly again two dollar
super chat so you want an Xbox with
extra beef
yes I I like the extra beef on my you
know what I'm saying extra cheese on
mines too JD game with 10 super chat
side note did they really release the
full specs of the new little man no one
has seen it does it have more memory too
is it faster hmm we're getting more
power baby power of X what you think
about that I believe I believe they
really they open something up because we
all know for some reason Nintendo or I
know it's battery uh related with the
switch they can release more power in
that switch there's no reason why tears
of the kingdom was running at a lower
resolution than um this thing so they
just they just worrying about battery
life yeah yes and then the uh next one
looks like oh shout out to uh big bad Mo
remember 36 bomb and JD gaming my
grandma haven't seen him in a minute
yeah he's up in their lower bronze in it
no doubt oh JD game up five hours of
chat condolences and prayers for Atticus
thank you enough yes please I do the
speedball this last topic this was
solves topic y'all want to read it and
this was in reference to um revenue and
it was in reference to um PC profit
versus console uh Activision I believe
had posted
um second quarter 2023 financial report
and it stated that PC is currently more
profitable platform than both the series
X and Playstation 5. according to
Activision for the six months of the
year PC made a 1.2 1.25 billion for
comparative purposes all consoles
combined made 1.19 billion in the same
period however even the PC platform was
no match for mobile mobile is currently
check this out this is crazy this is a
good soft topic mobile is currently the
golden cow of Activision Blizzard as it
brought 1.9 billion so 1.9 billion was
Global I mean it was uh with mobile 1.25
billion was PC 1.19
was console and that's console of both
all the consoles switch
wow so in kga he said now in case you're
wondering the success of both the mobile
and PC is not only due to the Diablo
series interestingly interestingly
enough Call of Duty also has more
players on PC yeah than on both
PlayStation and Xbox and they showed the
splits and he talked about that
now they know uh Microsoft I mean Call
of Duty is filled with um you know micro
transactions they can say that but uh
yeah this is this is interesting that um
they said Activision Blizzard is the
second publisher for which the PC
outperforms console Capcom has also
stated that PC is more profitable these
days than consoles yeah let's talk about
it because
I say this and let's see what's the the
commonality in all of it is the fact
that console has you pay for online
you know um your cell phone
um you pay for service but technically
when you download games and you play
your games you just you know straight
the plan and then you you know you they
have a different free-to-play model
um same thing with the PC jump in play
player games whatever you purchase
um
I think the PC is marketed to in the
phone it's marketed to
people that financially are able to
sustain
uh their habits right whereas you know
um consoles is looked at as gifts uh you
know to kids for Christmas or whatever
and it's a hobby and that's something
that they do it's just a demographic
that is skewed to uh who has a little
bit more disposable income but this is
when these uh these companies tell you
that you're not enough or that there's a
ceiling and they're trying to reach a
broader audience we all know mobile is
the broader audience that they're both
trying to Captivate and trying to get to
so the ABK deal is really King is really
the prize in that deal
um because that will facilitate uh
bringing in more revenue and that's
that's what everybody's goal is to to
get to that market everybody has a cell
phone right and it's in your hand it
surrounds you all the time so I can
market and I can get games to you
through your cell phone and I can I can
do things more more versatile than you
carrying around a console needing a TV
screen see a lot of people is at work
they can just dip in do a little
solitaire do a little something that's
in the corner multitask at the same time
while they working
um
that stuff happens gaming you really got
to set time aside to do so and I feel
that's where they're at a disadvantage
when it comes to the other two so at a
market wise I believe that the other two
have an advantage opposed to console
where you guys set time aside because it
does only one thing besides the fact
that we can watch movies and stuff there
but it's really a sedimentary you're
right here your settings time aside to
do that here we're on the PC you're
doing your bills you're doing uh this
you're doing that it's more versatile
your cell phone is more versatile the
gaming space is a little bit more
sedimentary and a really uh one-sided
when it comes to what you're gonna do so
of course the revenue is going to be
greater in those other spaces as opposed
to console yeah it was surprising to me
it was surprising to me to see that you
know PC you know for Activision Blizzard
specifically all consoles combined still
you know made less so it goes to show
you that you know what Xbox was trying
about in terms of the console Market
being flat and you know looking we saw
their their biggest growth as far as
Game Pass was PC game pass right and um
that is interesting so again it kind of
alludes to what I was saying earlier
yeah you have the lower price going into
it because they have to be aggressive in
that market to see that growth yeah I
mean that exactly I mean we own PC
players are not paying for online which
kind of LED back to the game pass Court
thing that's just the reality and to
King's your point you know I mean like
if you're a console gamer and you feel
that second-class citizen energy then
you need to reevaluate where you want to
be the reality is a lot of Gamers you
know especially casual gamers don't want
to deal with the headache of any type of
twinkling tickering on a PC and they
just want to fire something up so
they're still value to that there's
still that but that market is starting
to be flat and PC is starting to gain
growth and now we even see him let's be
honest because a lot of places you guys
were really upset when you know we were
saying that yo they're going to mimic
what Xbox is doing that is money on the
table if you do not put out a
PlayStation port or PC a PC Port from a
PlayStation game on PC now you can say
hey it's coming later that's fine it's
still coming they're still making it on
the platform and that's that's Revenue
that is Big Time revenue and we all do
the writings on the wall we we saw a
Nixon Society is a studio you know
that's my heart you don't even know who
they were to stop it
[Music]
PC points for PlayStation are
outstanding I played uh Spider-Man I
played a lot of this stuff is
outstanding so this is where it's going
um the mobile thing is surprising too
maybe more than all of it
you know mobile made more than all of it
as a person who does not care about
mobile at all
you know what it is I used to play like
some card joints and then they got to a
digit I was like I gotta stop like this
this is just literally free access to my
credit card to buy a foolishness I tried
to do
um that Marvel snap I thought it was
full I was scared of that game I know
those type of games but it doesn't it
doesn't have the Allure to me but I did
see a Final Fantasy game that had that
Allure to me first of all graphically it
has to hit
um for me in certain games it could be
uh mild Graphics but it has to have an
addiction Factor like I paid mob control
and I play
um oh what's that other game uh the you
know Crown Kingdom or whatever yeah
um I play these puzzle type of games but
there's also a mechanic in it that has
you like if you you hit a stump you can
pay your way out right and if you fall
down that rabbit hole
things go bad for you but I can see how
this can Garner
more interest than that because again I
can do this anywhere oh facts you got
your phone with you anyway right and
it's not our generation let's be here
right no it's it's like your son I mean
you know maybe that is something you
know a younger generation where it's
just like yo that's what they do they're
playing and I forgot Call of Duty's on
mobile yeah that's big so and it doesn't
look bad yeah so and I remember Paul G
and all that was a mobile they've got
mobile versions running around look I
think that
it's it's it's this is one of the main
reasons why Microsoft did this deal
they're looking at that Revenue look and
all that stuff from what I heard King
was the acorn oh that kid was definitely
that and what Gamers don't want to hear
is a lot of the games that we like that
we consider hardcore games and the first
party bangers are technically money
sinks for them right they're not happy
that it just did three five million you
know what I'm saying like they want they
want that bigger bag and I think that's
right yeah well we did yeah we found out
that you know all those AAA titles that
Sony was clapping for wasn't making the
bread I mean and Call of Duty was to do
yeah I mean they did they did say they
couldn't exist without it but it is what
it is I got it for 10 years
I see what you doing but yeah you know
we'll see we see what it is and that
last thing I'll say on it is just that
you know this is where the industry is
going I know some people have issue with
that but just swear it's going I mean
um to me all I care about is obviously
the console gaming State space and all I
want is synergy synergy cross platform
cross progression with a cross play with
the with the playing with each other
pause across uh what you call yes very
big pause and also you know cross I want
to be able to if I played it on like
right now one of the greatest things to
me in cyberpunk yeah play that on the
Alley has Cloud saves I can go to series
X and S continue right from well if I
can go to PlayStation continue I just
want to be able to go where I want to go
with the same data you know what I'm
saying don't make me buy game over and
over and then start brand new that's
because I hate that so that's what I
like that they're slowly remember the
Xbox play Anywhere Cloud slaves like
let's get this continue to grow that's
what I want to me that's the Future
these companies to to buy into that yes
um and I think Sony is buying into that
they're just doing it a little bit
slowly but they understand that the PC
market is the market the mobile market
is the market they do make mobile games
so everybody is trying to get there I'm
mad at Microsoft yo where's my gears pop
get my gear well it's certain ones that
do well that's why it's like it's the
Candy Crush they push it though but it's
the games that we don't care about is
what's popping and the crazy thing is I
know Gamers don't want to hear like oh I
don't like that mobile it's not as good
yesterday we got the numbers right here
we've got the numbers right here it
literally mobile did 1.9 billion more
than all consoles combined more than
just um what's called the um PC platform
that's crazy that's the number one
Revenue regardless like that's a big
deal we can't ignore that stat just
because we don't like those type of
games are we scared with the industry
and that's a fact so
I'm not terrified at it because as long
as we have Gamers at the helm of these
corporations that you know that are
making the games for us
um I feel that there will be a place for
console at some point always
and you know that's that's what my hope
is yeah I know at some point in time
we're going to become dinosaurs Cog and
we won't be viable anymore especially
with metrics like this if it keeps
trending yeah this way this is scary
yeah then it's a future for us that we
we as hardcore console Gamers look I
still think there's always questions you
want to say to the to the Twitter people
the people that's playing Twitter shut
up because these uh these uh phone dudes
is outpacing us and we need to stop
worrying about some more games we need
to battle the mobile dude
these mobile dudes is outside I don't
know I don't know any of them but
they're clearly more of them than us so
that's what it is but look that's all I
got let's wrap this thing up and get the
super chats and get it cracking all
right we got let's see thank God they
got that fun fan funding thing because I
can find it easy do I see it yeah when
you go to the chat if you go at the top
where he says live chat and what you
call it he's a little drop down box and
you see fan funding but I got it shout
out to uh my man oh you should think
five dollar Super Chat Phil has to
decide spending 2 billion on Xbox Pro or
allocate that to Studio Acquisitions and
games which do you prioritize power has
never won again
he's right about that but what he's
asking the question King do you if he
got the choice he could only do one or
the other
more Studios more games or you go for
this Pro Studios what the hell it came
from like literally the series The the
switches out here mopping dudes up all
over and they run around 480p and I
think hard geek that's the greatest
Point argument for them not to do it
right so no no yeah well
I'm a general out here in these Twitter
streets bruh like and I do not need
these dudes having a power narrator oh
this is your personal it's your personal
this is all about beef I'm just like
beef forget about that this beef right
here I found a fan of all right Stitch
with the follow-up chat with the new
PlayStation Pro is Sony
the conditioning the physical dudes to
the inevitable move to All Digital sorry
to hear about the attic situation
thinking about that do you think Sony is
conditioning on people to go digital
with their you know the detachable no I
think they're giving you the option okay
I think they want to sell you
they want to sell you something and they
want to sell you the digital uh the I
mean the discs separate and that's cool
right you have the option to be all
digital if that's the life that you want
to live or if you down with the physical
and like a lot of dudes are you can go
by the physical thing me personally
regardless of what I do a lot of digital
gaming so I love the fact that they're
giving the option to do so if you want
to be physical cool go do so I don't
remember the last time I brought a
series X physical game period yeah fair
enough fair enough and then we got c-dub
he's back ten dollars for the chat so I
just brought my first OLED got the G3
what what pixel brightness and black
level would you recommend for gaming and
how the heck do you turn off the
annoying magic remote for the yeah that
Metro remote for this annoying damn
almost here cassava people tell you this
is a solved question
I'll be downstairs playing wifey's
upstairs on the LG upstairs she uses the
magical remote oh
what if the goal of both console
manufacturers is to get them on PC or
mobile and for those that want to stay
on Console they can but the console will
soon be sold out of profit instead of a
loss
what if the goal of both my Xbox and
Playstation is to get you on PC and
mobile that's that's the long-term goal
okay who cares I mean they can listen
I'm the dude they go to Taco Bell they
get the cheesy bean and rice burrito my
PC's sitting in my face I turned on that
PC game pass once to have one
Castlevania type game that never came to
console
but I don't care and if they go away and
they think that I'm supposed to follow
them on PC then they're gonna miss out
on me that's the last time you want to
see me all right let's do this uh pull
and get about an ear all right new pole
with the rumors of a PlayStation 5 Pro
scheduled in 2024 can Xbox afford to
stand Pat without a mid-generation
refresh the choices are a yes Xbox now
has ABK the Studio's in exclusive games
to funnel Game Pass consistently this
generation B no Xbox cannot be outdone
in the power narrative and will tool up
like they did with project Scorpio or
see I don't care none of this really
matters until we address the real
Champion room that Nintendo switch 2
coming in hot that is what it is go Rock
the vote when it comes out shout out to
the legendary young yay the man held it
down gave us bad bars educated us on the
whole industry it was just a pleasure to
talk to him you know one of the real
ones one of the real ones you know I'm
saying some people I could tell well you
know I look him in the eye and I can
tell he's gonna give me a favor
shut up
it was beefy energy in the room he said
he fought the vibe it was a nice vibe
listen man shout out to the holy I'm
super proud of him he did his thing
um and see what he gonna do to kill you
and Jacques is one of my favorite is he
working for Sega so you gotta you know
but
um
no doubt again send some love both to
addict and soft today we really got hit
hard in the room you know attic uh just
had a death in the family sent some love
to him Saul was going through a physical
issue right now he's going to keep us
updated I know that kick I'll speak to
you offline and see what's the latest
update because I was running to try to
get a chance to see how personal chat as
much but um send some love to us man we
listen this is real life we ever all of
us got real life problems and King no it
takes a lot for us to do this show to
get up here consistently and do this for
y'all so I know we may agree and
disagree sometimes but just remember we
humans we got lives we got stuff going
on I got stuff going on King's got way
stuff that he don't even trust me if
y'all knew this stuff he does just to
get on this show to do this I I love so
just be thankful for that and
appreciative of that for my kind or
content creators not just us this is not
easy there was one more um last uh Super
Chat I want to read and it looks like my
man Lloyd Metroid two dollars to the
chat if
if I can't put that thing in the hole no
money what are we talking about
hit the music
[Music]
facts I don't know where that was going
yo look I'm interested the disc man I'm
talking about the dick you got them this
that was IOP after dark bro I didn't
know where you was going with that you
left it like that you know what she was
doing you know what she was doing
that's yo yo everybody enjoy your Sunday
we up oh my God
first first you first
first let's go let's go let's go my
heart goes out the attic and his family
yes
um
I gotta reach out to my brother yeah
yeah after this he has a death in his
family yeah
two years ago so so that's one
two Sovereign
so this is the time when I say yeah you
um send your love to him tweet at him
say you hope you're okay whatever he'll
disclose whatever's going on if he
chooses he chooses to right
um but my prayers and I'm calling him
right after this that's that's that's
happening
um
I just knew
I just knew the you know the man that
gave the news and very insightful and
very very detail-oriented in the stuff
that he did do and very very good
um
and I I I I I learned of him because of
brap
uh shout out to uh Captain flip-flop
um
and then I know Yang yay now for theater
the art the the Transcendent renaissance
man
um and he learned something in this
journey to be a gentleman
and he learned it from the ultimate
gentleman
um that's a beautiful story
I I will stand on my Square he would
have been a terrible lawyer a doctor
because his heart is in another place
and I'm glad that he's not I'm glad that
he's in this space because I get a
chance to see the versatility in this
individual
um the space is better for him being in
it thank you so much for gracing us with
your presence today uh we do this show
and this show uh is a lot you know we
come on once a week but we also have
stuff that we're doing during the week
with that being said R and R with the
Lords with um my host Ty yes oh man
titano uh they are definitely uh
something that you will love uh please
check it out on patreon it's in the
background and it's it's a it's a great
show we did a year-end review of movies
and we talked about Indiana Jones they
talk about mission impossible as the
headliners and we talked about also
secret Invasion that's on Disney plus
right now so if you're watching those
shows if you saw those movies and you
want to see the Insight on that just go
to patreon and check that out also uh
Kos is uh making his debut this week on
Twitter live so
um now uh yeah the king took the splash
to go on to Twitter blue P
um that blue should pop up at some point
in time but um also combat talk with the
King will be on live on Twitter
I'm bringing you something different
that your content creators will not
bring you I'm doing something different
that other content creators will not
share with you we're gonna do this
journey together we're going to do it as
a team and I'm going to probably try my
best not probably I will try my best to
give you the most different diverse
content that nobody else will bring to
you and I'm going to show people how to
use Twitter in a positive way in a
better way than what they're using it
for right now so I just want to get an
update from attic on his Twitter this is
Paypal information and cash app
information
um he just put out on his Twitter
um hey guys I never do this but my aunt
died and my family's not doing well my
mom is stuck in Arizona and still stuck
there please give anything you can so I
can get my mom here and he's left his
information so I'll put the tweet I put
the information in the chat again this
is at your discretion you know if anyone
wants to help my brother you know
obviously we're going to try to help him
with the situation as best as we can as
we always do but I just want to this is
the Tweet so you can see it from his
account not just from my mouth and um
we'll follow up with him so look that's
pretty much we got real life situations
going on but again appreciate y'all oh
another Super Chat oh thank you Robert
kellett shout out 2004 chat bless you
both for holding the line salute we
gotta hold it down man that's what the
team do they held me down when I was out
there and I'm moving about and likewise
we got to hold them down so look
everybody enjoy your Sunday we will
catch you next week you know that no
kick anything else we good I know peace
all right peace
thank you
[Music]
foreign